THINK YOU'RE WHAT EVERYONE
WELCOME TO ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT
HEARING- TO START I WANT TO
THANK ALL OF THE STAFF THAT
IMPAIR. OUR RETURN THE CAPITAL
TO HEAR BILLS POP. TWO MEN TO
MENTAL WORK. THAT HAS GONE ON
MORE I WANNA THANK. I'M CO
SPEAKER STAFF AND CERTAINLY
SERGEANTS- IS THAT THEY HAVE
DONE- AND HIS JOB TO TRY TO
KEEP US ALL SAFE. DO THE
CURRENT STATE HOMEWORK. HEARING
ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE CAP
BUILDING WE'RE ONLY ABLE TO
HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WATCHING PARTICIPATE IN THE
HEARING IN PERSON. WE HAVE A
FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR WHICH
IS TO MONEY TODAY. SO I'M IT
TOO FOR THOSE ARE HERE IN THE
ROOM WE ARE HAVING- SCREEN
JUSTIN IN PERSON HEARING. IN
THIS SPACE YOU CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE SEVEN MEMBERS A
MINIMAL CONTINGENTS DAPHNA LET
REPUBLICAN MEDIA SO WE CAN
MAINTAIN. SIX FEET OF SPACING
THEY'RE ALSO STRIPPERS GO
DISSING PROTOCOLS FOR THE
PUBLIC TO ENTER AND LEAVE THE
CAPITAL. HERE TODAY. THE BEST A
ON BILL OF PLEASE RAISE YOUR
HAND ALLOWS YOU OPPOSED TO MAKE
FUN OF PEOPLE TIME OF COURSE. I
WOULD ASK THE PUBLIC TOUCH THEM
FROM. YOU CAN EXIT THE HEARING
ROOM ONCE YOU'RE DONE
TESTIFYING OR TURN YOUR SEATS.
PLEASE BE SURE TO OBSERVERS
CRITICIZING UPON LEAVING THE
CAPITOL INCLUDING LIMITED.
ELEVATOR USED TO ONE PERSON AT
A TIME. A FOR A WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOM WITNESS IN
ADDITION TO BE ABLE TO TESTIFY.
FROM INSIDE THE ROOM WE DO HAVE
A SOME WITNESS MAKING USE OF
OUR AND WITNESS VIDEO COM ROOM.
HELLO HERE IN THE CAP. THE THIS
IS THE PURE ON THE SCREEN SO IN
WHAT SOME. FROM OUTSIDE THE
HEARING ROOM. AND ALSO
QUESTIONS OF THESE WITH. WE'RE
ALSO GONNA BE HAVE A USE A
MODERATE PHONE SERVICE THROUGH
WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN TESTIFY
ON THE BILL IF YOU'RE CALLING.
BY PUBLIC COMMENT WE ASK YOU
STATE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION ON THE BILL- WE
ANTICIPATE A HIGH CALL VOLUME
TODAY THIS IS. THE SAME
PROTOCOL AS IF EUROPE IS WE
BUILD IT DURING- DURING
ORDINARY CIRCUMSTANCES. YEAH
THE EXPERT TO OR OR THE OF THE
SELECTED WITNESS TESTIMONY FOR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITE. AND
EVERYONE ELSE THAT WANTS TO
CHIME IN ON A BILL SIMPLY
STATES NAME. ORGANIZATION OR
AFFILIATION IF ANY AND WHETHER
THEY SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THE SO
THAT'S GONNA BE THE SAME.
PROTOCOL BUT JUST THIS TIME BUT
BE DIALING AND- CALL A NUMBER
FOR THIS HEARING IS
877-692-8957 AND THE ACCESS
CODE. IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR THREE SEVEN. YOU'LL FIND
THIS NUMBER ON THE LABOR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON
THE TV SCREEN. FOR CALLING IN.
OF A BOOK PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO-
AS THE AUTHOR THE BILL YOU'RE
TESTIFYING ON IS BEGINNING THE
BILL PASSED STATION THE
OPERATOR OF THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO IN
Q. IT'S A- PORT. OR OPPOSE.
ELIMINATE ALL NOISES INCLUDES
MEETING YOUR LIVESTREAM
BROADCAST IN YOUR SMART DEVICES
TO REDUCE THE SOUND DISTORTION.
PLEASE ALSO BE ADVISED IF
YOU'RE- PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR
OR AGAINST A BILL YOU'LL REMAIN
ON A LIFELINE I WANTED TO MEET
YOURSELF UNTIL YOU'RE CALLED
ON. TO SPEAK. HAVING PROBLEMS
WITH THE MODERATE OPPONENTS
ARE. ALL THE COMMITTEE AT NINE
ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE. TWO
ZERO NINE ONE AND MY STAFF WILL
BE THERE TO TRY TO HELP. ALSO
KNOW THE READ SOMETHING WRITTEN
TESTIMONY. ON THE COMMITTEES
ROADS. I DO WANT TO THANK AND
WITH US AS WE IMPLEMENT METHODS
TO CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA ALSO BE. FOR THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE ALL
FACE. AND I WILL NOTE THAT I
HAVE ASKED OF FOR ANYONE THAT
COMES INTO THE ROOM. THAT
ANYONE THAT COMES INTO THE
ROOM- TO HAVE A MASK ON AT ALL
TIMES WHILE IN THE ROOM. THE
TWO EXCEPTIONS ARE THE SIGN
LANGUAGE INTERPRETERS THEY DO
NEED TO HAVE THE FACE VISUALLY
SEEN AS WELL IN ASSISTING. THE
INTERPRETATION ALSO AT. MEMBERS
OTHERS OF HIS. I HAD TO DO THE
SEPARATE KEEP THE MASK ON- AT
ALL TIMES AT THE TO. REMOVE IT
OF BRIEFLY. WHEN SPEAKING NOW
ALL ALLOW THAT BUT TRY YOUR
BEST IF YOU CAN TO TRY TO KEEP
YOUR MASK ON AT A TIME PAUL. IN
THE- OR BRITISH. THE WAY TO ME
I ASK THAT YOU KEEP YOUR MASCOT.
SO OF WE CAN HAVE THE WILL CALL.
ALL RIGHT HERE. THE ALRIGHT
HERE FLORA HERE LEARN HERE
GLORIA YEAH. WELL WHERE RATHER
OKAY. NO I THANK ALL THE
MEMBERS FOR BEING HERE IN A
TIMELY FASHION WE WILL BE
TAKING. AND RECESS AT ONE PM
FOR FORTY FIVE MINUTES AND THEN
WILL DOUBLE RESUME THEN. TO BE
CHALLENGING AS YOU ALL KNOW TO
BE IN A MASS FOR A VERY LONG
TIME SO I THINK IMPORTANT FOR
US TO GET A LITTLE. FROM THE
MASS. THE WORD. I'M I. CAN
ACTUALLY. IF THERE'S A M<c.cyan>.</c>
ON THE CAN. CALENDAR HI AS A
MOTION A SECOND OF ECONOMIC A
ROLL CALL VOTE PLEASE. YOU HAVE
TO APPROPRIATIONS THE FOLLOWING
BILL. AB TWENTY SEVENTEEN AB
TWENTY THREE ELEVEN AB TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN. AB THIRTY FIFTY. AB
THIRTY ONE SEVENTY FIVE AB.
THIRTY THREE NINE. WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND YES YEAH
WE- MOTION IS A MEMBER RIVAS
SECOND FROM VICE CHAIR FLORA.
KALRA I. CALL RIGHT. I LAURA HI
MARIA. MARIA ALL RIGHT. HI THE
KNOWLEDGE HI WELL AS ALL RIGHT
SOMEWHERE. RIGHT RIGHT RIVAS
FIVE FREE THAT'S RIGHT. HOWEVER
DOUBLE BUT DON'T ABOUT A THIRD
OF OUR- BILLS GREAT NOW UNDER
THE FIRST BILL. IS THE A. B.
EIGHTEEN FIFTY BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GONZALEZ AND I'LL JUST
STATE IN ADVANCE OF YOU PEOPLE
KNOW WHO THE ASSIGNED- OF
WITNESSES WILL BE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. WE DO HAVE A JOB THE
PENAL WORKERS SET BY PHONE AND
LINDA SOLEMN MONNING WHO WORKS.
UBER LIFT ALSO BY PHONE OR SOME
OF AGAINST US. LEARNING MATH
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT OF ACTED
THE PROBLEM. MY WAY. BACK THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
WITHOUT THE HYPERBOLE OF
EVERYTHING THAT ABOUT EIGHTY
FIVE WANT TO SPEND A LITTLE BIT
TO TAKE YOU BACK TO HOW WE GOT.
IN A TWENTY EIGHTEEN UNANIMOUS
BY. SUPREME COURT DECIDED THAT
THE NUMBER OF CASES THAT THEY
HAD SEEN ON THE CLASSIFICATION.
ALONG AND IN ORDER TO DEAL WITH
THAT THEY WERE GOING TO CREATE
A TASK THAT WAS MUCH MORE
SIMPLE FOR ME SUPPORT WORKERS
TO UNDERSTAND THE LAW. THANK IT
UNFAIR THAT THE BRELO TEST
WHICH IS AN ELEVEN POINT TEST.
WHAT HE'S FAT. THE WORKER
REALLY DETERMINED A
PACIFICATION UNLESS THEY
ACTUALLY FILED A LAWSUIT. WITH
THEY SAID IT'S CLEAR THERE'S AN
A. B. C. TO MAKE IT EASY AND
THEY PROVIDED NO EXEMPTIONS BUT
A LOT OF RATIONALE. THERE WAS A
LOT FALLOUT FROM THAT DECISION
WE STARTED HEARING FROM
BUSINESSES WHO ARE CONCERNED
THAT THEY WERE LEGITIMATE USING
LEGITIMATE INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS OR HAVING A
BUSINESS TO BUSINESS
RELATIONSHIP. BUT WE'RE GETTING
CAUGHT UP IN SESSION OR WOULD
BE SEPARATE TOOL LAWSUIT
BECAUSE THAT DECISION. WE
STARTED HEARING FROM WRITER WHO
HAD LOST JOBS FROM OUT OF STATE
BECAUSE SESSION. NEW THAT I
THERE WERE THOSE OF US WHO
REALLY WANTED TO PROTECT. THE
WORKERS THAT WERE PROTECTED NOT
DECISION IN AT THE SAME TIME
MAKE THE CLARIFICATIONS
NECESSARY. BUT IT WORKED FOR AS
MANY LEGITIMATE INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS AND SMALL
BUSINESSES AS POSSIBLE YET
PRESERVING THE FACT THAT. MS
CLASSIFICATION BECOME A HUGE
ISSUE. WE PASSED MAYBE FIVE
LAST YEAR AND A- SOON AS IT WAS
FINE WE STARTED HEARING FROM
INDIVIDUALS WHO FELT LIKE THAT
THEY WERE CAUGHT UP IN THE
LANGUAGE. WE ALSO HEARD FROM
INDIVIDUALS WHO WE KNEW THAT WE
WERE GOING TO HAVE TO MAKE
CHANGES FOR WE HAD SETBACK AS
IT WENT FORWARD. SO HERE WE ARE
WITH ATP WHICH IS THE BILL TO
PROVIDE RELIEF FOR INDIVIDUALS
IN INDIVIDUAL AREAS- THAT
REALLY DID GET CAUGHT UP. I
INTRODUCED IN JANUARY TWO CAN
WORK WE STARTED TO PROTECT
WORKERS RESPONSIBLE BUSINESSES
AND TAXPAYERS AGAINST THIS
CLASSIFICATION. AND AS WE FIND
OURSELVES A MIST OF A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC THE NEED FOR A BI FIVE
THE IMPETUS FOR DYNAMAX
DECISION COULD NOT BE MORE
CLEAR. MAKING IT MORE DIFFICULT
FOR EMPLOYERS TO MASK THEIR
WORKERS HOLDS THE SOCIAL
CONTRACT ENTERED INTO BY
EMPLOYERS EMPLOYEE IN THE
STATE. THIS ENSURES THAT WILL
NOT MIND WORKERS RISKS OWN
HEALTH EVERY DAY ON THE JOB
MILLIONS OF AMERICAN. WOMEN
SUFFER. THESE ARE ABLE TO THE-
SAFETY NET DURING THESE TIMES.
REALLY CLASS OF EMPLOYEES ARE
ABLE TO BE ON THE STATE SOCIAL
AND PRO. INCLUDING AND
INSURANCE DISABILITY LEAVE PAID
FAMILY LEAVE IN ADDITION A
CRITICAL WORKPLACE BENEFITS AND
PAID SICK DAYS WORKERS
COMPENSATION OF A CONTRACT IN
NINETEEN THE JOB STRICT HEALTH
AND SAFETY THIRDS AND PART IN
THE GET POLLUTION. THIS
PANDEMIC WE'VE ALL. HOW
DETRIMENTAL ECONOMIC IMPACT OF
MISS CLASSIFICATION CAN BE ON
LAW ABIDING BUSINESSES AND
TAXPAYERS COMPANIES THAT MISS
CLASS BY THEIR WORK FORCES HAVE
NOT PAID INTO OUR UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE FUND. WHICH IS FOR
THE COUNTRY THE FAT INSOLVENCY
AND LET OUR STATE TO BECOME THE
FIRST TO BORROW FUNDS FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO ADDRESS
OUR DEFICIT- WHO WERE AROUND
DURING THE LAST LOAN KNOW WHAT
HAPPENS IN TWO YEARS WHEN THAT
LOAN BE. ILL BUSINESS ONE
FACTOR. MEET OUT THOSE WHO HAVE
PAID INTO OUR SYSTEM ARE
COSTING US UC BERKELEY LABOR
CENTER ESTIMATED THAT IF RIGHT
SURE COMPANIES LIKE UBER LEFT
HAD PAID INTO THEIR FAIR SHARE
INTO YOU I FUND THEY WOULD HAVE
CONTRIBUTED OVER FOUR HUNDRED
AND MILLION. FOR THE WORKERS AS
FIVE YEARS AND WE WOULD HAVE TO
A LOAN THE NATIONAL WHAT PRICE
NASH HIS THAT'S MADE THAT THE
UNDUE BURDEN ON LAW ABIDING IS
INFORMED INCREASED. IN ITS.
EIGHT HUNDRED. THAT GETS BORN
BY LAW ABIDING COMPANIES. IT'S
UNFAIR AND IT NEEDED TO BE
CHANGED. THIS IS ONE OF THE
REASONS THE LEGISLATURE PASSED
SB FIVE. BUT WHEN IT PASSED
WITH KNOWLEDGE THE RULES DON'T
WANT TO BE IN THERE ARE COMPLEX
ISSUES THERE WAS BREAK DOWNS IT
TALKS AND IT WOULD. TELL YOUR
EFFORT. MANY PEOPLE. IS THE
LARGEST LABEL. THAT WE'VE HAD
IN DECADES. NATURALLY IT'S GOOD
GET TOP TIME TO TALK EVERYTHING
OUT EVERY. DO IN THIS.
SOMETHING OUT THAT HIS MESS.
BUT IT'S BEEN OVERLOOKED. THE
FIXED AND THIS WELL AS WELL AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
HERE- INSTEAD OF MY DISTRICT
ABC TESTS ACROSS THE BOARD. AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY. SYSTEM WITH A.
B. RECOGNIZE THAT INDIVIDUALS
WHO LEGITIMATELY OPERATE THEIR-
THIS CONTINUE TO DO SO. UNDER
MORE LENIENT CLASSIFICATION
TEST WE FOUND UMBRELLA. IN AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY I'VE MADE
CLARIFICATION TO PROVIDE
GREATER CERTAINTY FOR MUSICIANS
WRITERS AND CERTIFIED
TRANSLATORS PHOTOGRAPHERS
MULTIMEDIA PROFESSIONALS
PROFESSIONAL RISK MANAGEMENT
APPRAISAL SERVICES EXPERT
JUDGES WHO DETERMINE OUTCOMES
FOR COMPETITIONS SPECIAL
ARTISTS TO TEACH MATH THIS.
CONCEPT OF CRAP HE'S ENABLE
CLEAR PATIENTS FOR EACH
INDUSTRY HAS BEEN CONSISTENTLY
INFORMED BY THE PRINCIPLES
FOUND IN THE DYNAMICS CASE
ITSELF. INDIVIDUALS WITH
SIGNIFICANT ECONOMY IN PART HOW
ARE THE WHAT IFS INDIVIDUALS
WHO HOLD A PROFESSIONAL LICENSE
REGULAR BY STATE OR OTHERWISE
WORKING DISTRICT BY YOUR PEERS.
INDUSTRY WITHOUT PERMIT HISTORY
OF MISS CLASSIFICADOS. AGAINST
EXPLOITATION HOWEVER WE KNOW
THAT ALL INTO BEING A
CONTROVERSY NOT FALL INTO THIS
CATEGORY DATA FROM TWENTY
NINETEEN FROM THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD INDICATES IT NEARLY SIX
HUNDRED AND THEN INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS QUALIFY EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT WHICH IS
TAXPAYERS OVER A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTEEN DOLLARS THIS CALL FOR.
THESE IN A PANIC. WITH THE JUST
IN OF. THE TEAM THAT DOLLARS
THEY'RE NOT TRULY SELF EMPLOYED
BUSINESS. THEY ARE FACT THE
WORKING POOR TO AVOID
COMPROMISING PROTECTIONS UNDER
AB FIVE IMPOSING WEAKER
STANDARDS FOR WORKERS WHO
MISCLASSIFIED POOR DYNAMAX AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY TRIES TO STRIKE
A BALANCE THIS LEGISLATION
ENSURES WORKERS WERE SUBJECT TO
CONTROL DIRECT FROM EMPLOYER
RETAIN INTENTIONS AT ABC TEST
WHILE STILL CLEAR FIND THAT
INDIVIDUALS OPERATE IT'S TRUE
BUSINESSES ENTITIES GOVERNOR
THE- POSTING. AT FROM AFFECTED
STAKEHOLDER I AND TO WORK ON
BROUGHT THE DEBT IN. THEY DID
YOU TO DISTINGUISH THE BIZ
STRUCTURE THAT OF A BROKE.
CLARIFY THEM BY WHICH IN OR CAN
RELY ON CONTENT EXPERTS SPECIAL
PROJECTS CLARIFIED ABILITY FOR
PERFORMING PRESENT THEIR
ORIGINAL WORK WITHOUT
RESTRICTIONS MAKE CHANGES TO
LANGUAGE ON TRANSLATORS AND
LOOK AT APPROACH IS TO ADDRESS
SOME ISSUES RAISED BY AND
DRESSED ANY. REASONABLE COMPLY
BY HIRING BUSINESS. TODAY I'M
TO BE JOINED BY TWO WORKERS AS
WHO HOPEFULLY WILL BE ON THE
LINE. HIGHLIGHT SOME THAT AS WE
CONTINUE REASONABLE
CLARIFICATIONS TO THE LAW THREE
EIGHT E. FOR TRUE BUSINESS.
MESSAGE YOU NEED TO NOT JUST
CREDIT. BUSINESS CLASS WORKERS.
THREE THANKS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SOME ORGAN AND NOW WE HAVE
TO IN A EACH WITNESS HAS UP TO
TWO MINUTES AND- WILL START
WITH A JOB THE COLOR OF THE
FILIPINO WORKER CENTER PHONE.
GOOD MORNING. YEAH OF A
MYSTICAL WE CAN HEAR YOU. OKAY
YEAH- THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
THE FAR FAR ASSEMBLY WOMAN-
AROUND OF THE SALARY JEREMIAH
CHAIRMAN PRODUCT AROUND THAT
AND THAT SHOULD BE ABLE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. HELLO AND
GOOD MORNING TO ALL MY NAME
JOSEPHINE BECAUSE OUR MEMBER
OF. BEING A WORLD CENTER I AM A
CARE GIVER. WHAT A LOT AS A
CARE GIVER ASSEMBLY OF THE- I
WHAT THEY'RE GIVING AGENCY. OUR
I THANK INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR.
I ASKED ME TO BE GOOD W. TOO SO
THAT. I COULD HAVE SHOWN
SECURITY CONTRIBUTIONS THE
BIBLE DOES HAVE THE THAT I HAVE
IT BUT I COULD LATER USE. HI
BUT BY AGENTS HE- SELECT THE.
MY RESPONSIBILITY TO MY CLIENT.
I'LL NEVER MENTIONS THE ONES
BUT I AM. BUT. THAT I ASKED
FOR- FOR THAT- IS REACHING BILL.
THE W. TWO I KEEP CAROLINE
BECAUSE I NEEDED THE MONEY AND
THEY DID NOT BELONG TO LOSE MY
JOB. THAT I RECEIVED FROM THE
AGENCY THE HEALTH ALLIANCE AT
THE CARE GIVER OF. GETTING PAID
FOR ONLY A HUNDRED DOLLARS PER
DAY FOR TWENTY FOUR HOURS AND
THE WORK. THAT'S ONLY FOUR
DOLLARS AND FIFTY CENTS PER
HOUR. I ASK FOR A HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLARS PER DAY RACE BUT THEY
COULD NOT GIVE IT TO ME DURING
THAT TIME. I WORKED UNDER FOR
OUR STREETS SHE AND I WAS
FORCED TO FALSIFY. TIME SHEETS.
EIGHT HOURS A DAY SO THAT THEY
COULD NOT QUALIFY FOR OVERTIME.
THEY WOULD NOT EVEN GIVE ME A
COPY OF MY CONTRACT. LATER ON I%
FOUND OUT THAT THE FAMILY OF MY
PATIENT BUT ACTUALLY BEIJING
MAY APPROXIMATE THREE THREE
HUNDRED DOLLARS AND- THROUGH
HEALTH ALLIANCE AND THE HAND
HOME CARE PROVIDER. BUT THE
COMPANY NOT EVEN GIVE ME A
HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS A DAY
THAT I REQUEST THAT. BECAUSE OF
BEING MISCLASSIFIED AS AN
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR I
EXPERIENCED INCOME INEQUALITY
AND- EVEN WAIT STAFF. I WANTED
TO MY FAMILY OUR TWICE A WEEK I
WORK FIVE DAYS OR MORE A WEEK
SO THAT I AM ABLE TO EARN
ENOUGH TO SUPPORT MYSELF HERE
IN THE UNITED STATES AND MY
FAMILY BACK HOME. WELL BEING.
CHECKED ABOUT INSURANCE HE SAID
HE WOULD BE ALSO. WON BY AN
EXACT STREET I HAVE TO GO TO
THE DOCTOR AND TAKE A LOOK
PROTEIN CHECK OUT AND BEST. I
WAS TOLD THAT I NEEDED TO GET
AN EXTRA THREE MAMMOGRAM. YES
BUT- INSURANCE. BEST COST
HUNDREDS OF DOLLARS THAT I
CANNOT AFFORD TO PAY OUT OF
POCKET. BECAUSE I. THE FIGHT AS
AN INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR I WAS
NOT MAKING CONTRIBUTIONS TO MY
RETIREMENT AND PENSION AND
HEALTH CARE LESS I WRITE BUT
DID NOT HAVE. MISS BUTLER I
WANNA THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS AND- FOR SHARING I
BELIEVE THE EXPIRED ON YOUR
TIME SO WHEN I DO WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR PARTICIPATING IN A
CERTAINLY HAS IT. AND THEY CAN
ASK YOU WHEN THE TIME GAS THANK
YOU OPEN UP NEXT. VERY MUCH
EVERYONE HAVE A GOOD DAY AND
KEEP STATE THANK YOU. UP NEXT
LINDA SOLEMN MONET WHO WORKS
FOR UBER AND LEFT ALSO BY PHONE.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN POWER AND
THE NUMBER THAT THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- MY NAME IS LINDA FELL
MONEY I'M HERE TO TESTIFY TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY
BECAUSE IT MAINTAINS THE
CORPORATE ACTIONS OF AB FIVE.
WORKERS LIKE ME. I WOULD
PRIVILEGED INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTOR AS AN EMPLOYEE AND
IS IN THE CLASSIFIED WORKER SO
I MEAN HOW MUCH THESE
CATEGORIES IMPACT THE WAY THE
WORKERS ARE TREATED. LIKE SO
MANY. MULTIPLE JOB DRIVING
COMPANY. UBER AND LEFT FIRST
BACK YEARS AT THE ACT ADDING UP
BEYOND THE WHERE YOU CAN THE
WAY I'M REYES INTERACT WITH
CUSTOMERS AND COMP LIKE UBER
AND WHERE ALL OF THAT IS FREE
TO COME AND TRY COMPANIES.
THANKS THAT ON THE COMPANY. AND
THE RULES THE WORKERS HAVE TO
THE THEY DESERVE WHEN I TRY
DRIVERS DON'T MANY OF THAT
THEY'RE IN THE CARDS. WE ARE
NOT THE MINIMUM AGE FOR
OVERTIME. NO NOT REIMBURSE FOR
THE FIVE THAT MAINTAIN OUR
VEHICLES IT IS THAT OUR LIVES
ARE FAMILY DON'T MATTER. BUT
THAT RATHER SPEND MONEY TO TRY
TO GET. OUT OF THE STATE LABOR
LAWS THAN JUST PASSED FAIRLY
FOR THE WORK THAT WE DO. WITH
THE CAR BUYERS YOU SEE WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN A COMPANY DENIES
RESPONSIBILITY. WORKFORCE TO
PROVIDE PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT TO
KEEP US OR OUR PATH. THEY DID
NOT. WORKERS IN CASE THE
CONTRACT THE VIRUS. AND THEY
WON'T PROVIDE OUR WEIGHT
STATEMENT FOR THE STATE. STOP
IN LIMBO AN IMPLANT
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS. THAT'S
WHY I AM RIGHT NOW. ON THE
WORKERS THERE TO BE PUT
PROTECTED IN TIMES OF CRISIS%
AND THAT TOO MANY OF US ARE
GETTING. I WHEN OUR FAMILY OR
EVEN LIVING A- AFTER YOU OF
FIGHTING FOR BETTER. WE ARE NOT
ALL ON THE VERGE OF REALTORS.
THEY TURN JENNER. AND THREE
THIRTY ATTORNEY THAT TO GET
PUMP TRUMP AB FIVE DRIVERS MAY
FINALLY BE ARE LIKE CHANGE IN
WORKING CONDITIONS IMPROVE AT
THE FANCOURT AND ENSURE THE
FACTUAL PROTECTED UNDER EIGHT.
UNDER AB FIVE. AND FACT. I ASK
YOU TO PASS AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY
AND CONTINUE THE WORK OF USING
A BALANCED APPROACH TO CREATE
THIRTY IN WHERE NECESSARY WHAT
BACK DOWN ON THE MATH
CLASSIFICATION REYES AND BANNER
FOR THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY- AND
LET'S. START IN THE ROOM IS
THERE ANYONE HERE IN SUPPORT OF
SUPPORT POSITION FOR AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY. IF NOT THEN LET
ME ASK OUR MODERATOR NECK DO E
HAVE ANYONE IN SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE. IF YOU HOLD THE POSITION
OF SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL IN A
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE DO
HAVE SEVERAL IN Q. ALREADY WILL
GO FIRST THE LINE OF ONE NINETY
EIGHT ONE HUNDRED NINETY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
APOLOGIZE
FOR THE DELAY JUST A MOMENT
PLEASE. AM I ON YES YOUR LINE
IS OPEN OKAY A GOOD MORNING
SHOULD THAT BEHALF OF SAG AFTRA
THE TEAMSTERS THE AMALGAMATED
TRIPPY THE MACHINE AT NIGHT
HERE I AM THE LOCAL TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND UTILITY WORKERS
IN ALL REPORT. THANK YOU. LINE
ONE FORTY FIVE ONE FOUR FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU
FOR PATIENTS LINE ONE FORTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE ONE
ONE FORTY THREE ONE FOUR THREE
YOU MAY GIVE YOUR POSITION.
AFTER CARE MEMBER SERAPH LOCKED
FROM THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY. THANK YOU.
NINE ONE FORTY FIVE AGAIN ONE
FOUR FIVE PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION.
HELLO HE GAVE ME YES. GOOD
AFTERNOON SURE MEMBER BACK.
HERE ON BEHALF OF. LOCAL THIRTY
NINE THIRTY ON THE COURT THANK
YOU YOU. PINE ONE EIGHTY ONE
EIGHT ZERO. NAY BY ORDER WITH
THE AT THE ARE YOU CALIFORNIANS
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. FIND
ONE TEN ONE ONE ZERO. BETTER
TURN MEMBERS TAYLOR JACKSON
WITH THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIR THERE THERE ARE
MANY IN Q. WILL GO TO LINE ONE
SEVEN EIGHT ONE SEVEN EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M CALLING
ABOUT TWO TWO FIVE SEVEN I'LL
HOLD MY SUPPORT OF THE NEXT
SONG. THANK YOU THANK YOU BYE
AND ONE NINE SIX ONE NINE SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. STATIONUS
WW AND STRONG SUPPORT. OF AB
ONE EIGHTEEN FIFTY. THANK YOU.
FIND ONE OH FIVE ONE ZERO FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. REMEMBER TO
BROWN OF THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS AND
START SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE.
ONE THIRTY SEVEN ONE THREE
SEVEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON CARE
NUMBER GOOD MORNING THIS IS
JACKIE GREAT. OF THE WESTERN
STATES. THE PART. THANK YOU.
ONE EIGHTY FOUR ONE EIGHT FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MOMENT
PLEASE. YEP YOU WANT ONE ONE
EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. NO
RESPONSE AT THIS TIME WE'LL GO
TO LINE SEVEN ONE SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE MOMENT FIND
SEVEN. OF YES MY NAME IS
MADELINE NEWMAN. AND I AM A
CALIFORNIA AND IT WAS SORT
QUICK IT REPORTER AND ALSO A
TRANSLATOR THAT IS THE- CERTIFY
BY THE AMERICAN THAT STATUS
ASSOCIATION. AND I SUPPORT BUT
AS IT BE EXPANDED TO INCLUDE
ALL PROPERLY CREDENTIALED
THAT'S LATEST. THANK YOU. FIND
ONE FORTY ONE ONE FOUR ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK AT FOR
THAT NUMBER THREE PART. THANK
YOU. AND FORTY TWO FOUR TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH THIS IS
ALEX FOLLOW CERTAIN THE WESTERN
REGION DIRECTOR OF. I ATSC
LOCAL SIX HUNDRED I'M SPEAKING
ON BEHALF BURKE BY THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA MEMBERS IN SUPPORT
OF AB. EIGHTEEN THIRTY. FIND
THIRTY EIGHT THREE EIGHT. GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS CAITLYN HALEY
ON BEHALF OF THE SAN DIEGO AND
IMPERIAL COUNTY LABOR COUNCIL
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
NINE ONE ONE THREE ONE THIRD
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE ONE THREE
COULD YOU STATE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION. YES GILLIAN FROM
UFCW LOCAL FIVE. AND WE ARE IN
FULL SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE
ONE THIRTY ONE THREE ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN.
THREE ZERO ARE
YOU THERE. ONE THREE YES OF THE
TOM DAVIS IDEA TO WORK NUMBER
EIGHTY PRESIDENT OF THE-
COUNCIL CALIFORNIA. I MEAN
FORTY SIX THOUSAND MEMBERS IN
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. FIND ONE ALL ONE ONE
ZERO ONE ZERO AT. THIS IS DEREK
SMITH WITH UFCW LOCAL THREE
TWENTY FOUR IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. FIND THIRTY SEVEN
THREE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME IS OUR MIDDLE MINOR-
THE FUNDING I CAN IMAGINE
PROJECT CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY.
OKAY. STILL HAVE SEVERAL IN Q.
WE'LL GO TO LINE SEVENTY NINE
SEVEN NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES YES. MY NAME IS SHERRY
MURPHY I WORK BIRD WITH FULL
TIME I'M CALLING BECAUSE WE
NEED EIGHTY FIVE AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB EIGHT CONVICTED
THANK YOU THANK YOU. BY NINE
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS BILL BILL GLASSER ON
THE PRESIDENT AND FOUNDER OF
LANGUAGE WORLD SERVICES WE
EMPLOY TWO HUNDRED. HEALTH CARE
AND HUMAN SERVICE INTERPRETERS
AND WE ARE VERY VERY STRONGLY
IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE. AND ALL
BILLS TO PROTECT- INTERPRETERS
FROM EXPLOITATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ONE SIXTY SIX ZERO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
MARIE HOW ARE FUN I FOUND
EXACTLY WELL CALIFORNIA I AM
VERY. IN THE PARK AT EIGHTEEN
FIFTY AND I'VE MOLESTED UBER
DRIVER FOR THE LAST FIVE YEARS.
THANK YOU. FIND FOURTEEN ONE
FOR YOUR LINE OF WORK ON. GOOD
MORNING COMMITTEE THAT BURST MY
NAME IS CRYSTAL MONO AND I'M
THE ARTISTIC DIRECTOR OF THIS
YEAR ABOUT PLAYHOUSE IN SIERRA
MADRE CALIFORNIA. AND I ASK YOU
ALL TO SUPPORT THE LANGUAGE
BEING ADMITTED TO CARVE OUT
THEATERS WITH BUDGET SUB UNDER
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION FROM THE
CURRENT LABOR REGULATIONS.
SMALL PIERRE CIRCUS ON THE
OTHER ME SIR ON JUST HAVE YOUR
PERMISSION US. OR OPPOSE
APPRECIATE IT. WHEN YOU SUPPORT
WITH THE BAND BUT OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND PLEASE IF YOU
HAVE ANY FOR THE SENATE ARE
COMMITTEE OR TO A DOCTOR.
FOLLOW UP. I AM TO TWENTY NINE
TWO TWO NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YEAH HELLO MARK ALMOST GOT HIT
UP THE LOCAL PORT TWENTY EIGHT
PRESIDENT- FALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY
THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE ONE
SEVEN SIX ONE SEVENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS PAT THERE'S A LOT OF. KATIE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS AND I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
MORTGAGE BANKERS ASSOCIATION
BOARD SB EIGHT THAT. THANK YOU.
ONE SIXTY NINE ONE SIX NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING.
YES BUT THAT CAN YOU. I'M. MY
NAME IS DONNA KARAN AND I'M
WITH THE UNITED FOOD AND
COMMERCIAL WORKERS UNION LOCAL
ELEVEN SIXTY SIX AND WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN
FIFTY THANK YOU. LINE. TWO OH
TWO TWO ZERO TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I REMEMBER THE HEART
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LAWYER
ASSOCIATION AND THE COURT THANK
YOU. ONE EIGHT NINE ONE EIGHTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS BRIAN CHEN
WITH THE NATIONAL EMPLOYMENT
LAW PROJECT AND WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTEEN FIFTY. THANK YOU. LINE.
TWO HUNDRED TWO ZERO ZERO. ON
THE OTHER HALF OF THE COURT
ADVOCATE AND TRONG WHAT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ONE EIGHT ONE
ONE EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. CAPTIONBURGER RESIDENT
ABOUT EIGHT THIRTY IN NINETY
NINE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. TWO EIGHTEEN TWO ONE EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
RACHEL CHORUS WITH UFCW LOCAL
SEVEN SEVENTY AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. TWO ZERO
ONE TWO HUNDRED ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MR CHEN MEMBERS. AND
THEY GOT ON BEHALF OF THE
TRANSPORT WORKERS UNION OF
AMERICA IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. TWO TWENTY EIGHT TWO TWO
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI STORY
THANK YOU. MY NAME'S REX NOR A
MEMBER OF THE ACTORS EQUITY
ASSOCIATION AND A MEMBER OF THE
NATIONAL COUNCIL OF THAT THAT
COULD BE A REPRESENTING FIFTY
THOUSAND- OF PROFESSIONAL ACT.
WE'RE VERY IT SUPPORT OF THE
BILL AT WITHOUT. ANY CAR ABOUT.
FOR SMALL THEATRES OF ANY KIND
OF BUDGET BECAUSE IT WOULD MAKE
YOU ARE THE THANK YOU FOR ACT
RESTRICTED TO MAKE BOLD. THANK
YOU. THANK FIND TWO TO FOUR
AIRLINERS OPEN. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING MISTER. THIS IS TOM SHE
OUR BEHALF OF THE LANGUAGE
ACCESS PROFESSIONALS WHO ARE
AMERICAN SIGN LANGUAGE
INTERPRETERS AND REAL PINE
CAPTION OR THAT SERVE THE DEATH
AND HARD OF HEARING POPULATION.
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY. WITH THE BED
BUT THAT WOULD ADDS BY LANGUAGE
INTERPRETER THE REAL TIME
CAPTION EARTH INTO THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR THANK YOU. TWO THREE TWO
TWO HUNDRED THIRTY TO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS AMBER
BAUER EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
THE SB W. WESTERN STATE COUNCIL
AND SHAUN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NINE FIFTY FIFTY FIVE FIVE FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN NOW. HELLO MY
NAME IS NATASHA EMILY- BORROW
AND I'M FROM IT YEAH YOU UNITED
HEALTHCARE WORKERS WEST. I AM A
LICENSED VOCATIONAL NURSE. AND
I THOUGHT FOR A BI EIGHTEEN
FIFTY. THANK YOU. LINE THIRTY
THREE USER ALL YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS NICOLE MORE
AND I'M A MEMBER OF RIDE SHARE
DRIVERS UNITED IN A PART TIME
DRIVER FOR LEFT AND NOT GET
DRIVE. STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF
AB FIVE AND OF AB EIGHTEEN
FIFTY THANK YOU. ONE EIGHTY
EIGHT THEY'RE ALL YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS THAT ALLOW
THE FULL TIME DRIVER WITH OVER
LET'S SEND TO THE- TWENTY
THIRTEEN I'M PART TO FRY CHAIR
DRIVER UNITED CALIFORNIA I
SUPPORT A. B. BYE BYE AND I'M
STRONGLY SUPPORT A. B. E. T.
FIFTY. THANK YOU. LINE SIX
THREE SIXTY TWO YOUR LONG IS
OPEN. YEAH HELLO MY NAME IS
TYLER SAID I'M A BIT DRIVER AND
I'M ALSO WE RIGHT SHARE DRIVERS
YOU CAL. I LIKE TO CALL MY
ABSOLUTE SUPPORT OF AB FIVE AND
A. B. EIGHTEEN FIFTY. THANK YOU.
ONE FIFTY NINE FIVE NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
LABOR COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
KELLY GROUND AND A MEMBER OF
ACTORS EQUITY ASSOCIATION AND A
MEMBER OF THE NATIONAL
GOVERNING BOARD FROM CALIFORNIA
I'M HERE TO WHOLEHEARTEDLY
SUPPORT THE AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY
AND EIGHTY FIVE LEGISLATION AND
THANK YOU FOR CONTINUING TO
PROTECT ONSTAGE AND BACKSTAGE
WORKERS IN THE PERFORMING ARTS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT ON AND A YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. PUTTING THE- MEMBERS
ERIN DAVIS. A WEEKLY
CONTRIBUTOR TO THE SACRAMENTO
BEE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE
FORTY ONE FOR A LAWN NEAR LINE.
OKAY MY NAME IT BACK NUMBER
ABOUT WORKING UNIT OF. WITH
LOCAL A GREAT AND I HAD THE END
AND STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
EIGHT A FIFTY THANK YOU. ONE
FIVE FOUR ONE FIFTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF ROBERT
WILSON WITH A CALIFORNIA CREDIT
UNION LEAGUE IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY THANK YOU THANK
YOU. FIFTY ONE FIVE ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I GET MORNING
SURE MEMBERS- I'M HEARING WITH
A MAP FULL TIME- LIFT DRIVER
AND I WOULD WRITE YOUR DRIVER'S
UNITED AND I ARE STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB FIGHT AND EIGHTEEN
FIFTY. THANK YOU. IN TERMS. ONE
SEVENTY. HI MY NAME IS CARLA
CODA THE INTERNATIONAL
REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE EIGHTY
IS THE AND EMBER OF AYE
EIGHTEENTH HE LOCAL ONE TWENTY
TWO SAN DIEGO. I AM SPEAKING
AMPLE SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN
FIFTY THANK YOU THANK YOU. ONE
ZERO FOUR ONE FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS OF
STEPHANIE THINK JACK FROM A
MEMBER OF BRIGHT CHAIR DRIVERS
UNITED AND I AM A FULL TIME AND
WORK PART TIME WITH THE NEW
BURKE AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT AB
FIVE AND A. B. EIGHTEEN FIFTY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. FORTY SIX
FOUR SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS JOANNE DOES
MEN I'M WITH THE BUSINESS AGENT
WHAT I ATE YES THE LOCAL BEING
A- GO SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. THANK. EIGHTY TWO
EIGHT TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS ELECTED THEIR NECK
AND I'M- THE DRIVER- ANIMAL A
MEMBER OF OUR DO YOU. PROMOTE
THIRTY OF CALIFORNIANS SPEAKING
IN SUPPORT OF EIGHT EIGHT BE
EIGHTEEN FIFTY. THANK YOU. ONE
EIGHTY FIVE ONE A CAR ALARM
CLOCK. HI HOW YOU DOING MY NAME
IS ALEX REGULAR JUNIOR ON WITH
THE- AYE UNILINGUAL CULTURE
THAN TWENTY FOUR WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB. THANK YOU.
SEVENTY ONE SEVEN ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING THE MAN
OUT AT THE AFTER A FIFTY SEVEN
WE CARRY PRESIDENT. EXCEPT FOR
THE EIGHT THANK THANK YOU. ONE
THIRTY THREE ONE THREE THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CARE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
KATARINA BORKI I AM A FEDERALLY
AND STATE COURT CERTIFIED
INTERPRETER AND FREELANCE
TRANSLATOR I AM IN SUPPORT OF
AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY- WITH THE
COPY OUT THAT IT BE AMENDED TO
ARE ALL LANGUAGE PROFESSIONAL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
SEVENTY EIGHT SEVEN EIGHT
AIRLINERS OPEN. ERIC BUT- MANY
VETS- COME A GHETTO I AM A LIFT
DRIVER THREE YEAR AND VOLUNTEER
ORGANIZER WITH RIDE SHARE
DRIVERS UNITED I AM CALLING IN
FULL SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN
FIFTY AND EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU.
EIGHTY SIX EIGHT SIX ALIGN OF
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS ALBERT
ALIGNMENT I WORK FOR LIFT AND
WE'RE I'M ALSO A MEMBER RIGHT
SHOULD PRIVATE UNITE A AND I
HAVE STRONGLY SO FOR A. B.
EIGHTEEN FIFTY. THANK YOU.
EIGHTY ONE EIGHT ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI THIS IS MELVIN IN
MEN I AM. FORMER LIFT DRIVER
FROM LOS ANGELES CURRENTLY AND
HOME CARE WORKER AND HE I YOU I
AM DEFINITELY IN SUPPORT OF. AB
FIVE IN CERTAINLY EIGHTEEN
FIFTY. THANK YOU. NINETY FOUR
NINE FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS DOT. HI MY NAME IS
JOHN LOOTING AND I'M SUPPORT AB
FIVE. ALSO EIGHT EIGHT FIFTY
THANK YOU. TWO ONE TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
ALEXANDER KENTUCKY I AM A
BELIEVE PANEL BUT DRIVER AND
MEMBER OF FRIGHT CHAIR NINE
WEST UNITED YOU HAVE OVER
FIFTEEN THOUSAND FIVE OR TEN
CALIFORNIA. NEEDS SUPPORT
EIGHTY FIVE THEN HE CAN FIFTEEN
THANK YOU. LINE FIFTY SEVEN
FIVE SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS MOHAMMED RAZA AND I
AND THE- RIGHT SURE DRIVER AND
A PART OF RIGHT YOU'RE VERY
UNITED I WOULD LIKE VOICE MY
SUPPORT FOR A BI FIVE ANY
EIGHTEEN FIFTY THANK YOU THANK
YOU. I NINETY FIVE NINE FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN OF MY NAME IS ELAINE
ARE MERITS ON THAT. I SEE ARE
YOU REMEMBER AND I ACTUALLY
SUPPORT THE. EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY
EIGHTEEN FIFTY. THANK YOU. LINE
TWO THIRTY TWO THREE ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI LINE THIRTY
AND YOU'RE LOCKED YOUR LINE
OPEN. WE'LL GO TO LINE NINE TWO
NINE TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN MY NAME
IS MICHAEL FRAZIER- STRONGLY
SUPPORT- EIGHTY FIVE- AB FIVE
AND EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT AND I REPRESENT RUSSIAN
DRIVING NINE IT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. LINE ONE TWENTY ONE
TWO ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR THE
CULTURE HERE RIGHT- POLITICAL
DIRECTOR FOR THE UNITED FOOD
AND COMMERCIAL WORKERS LOCAL
EIGHT AND PRINCIPAL OFFICER OF
THE NORTH VALLEY LABOR
FEDERATION. BOTH ORGANIZATIONS
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY AND EIGHTY FIVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. FIFTY SIX
LINE FIVE SIX WE'LL GO AHEAD.
HELLO GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
HOME WHERE YOU GET YOUR- MEMBER
ALL RIGHT SHARE DRIVE FOR
UNITED AT A LOCAL LIFT DRIVER
FOR THE PAST TWO YEARS STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB FIVE AN A. B. A. B.
EIGHTEEN FIFTY. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. BY NINETY EIGHT NINE EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M IN
NUMBER. WHAT ABOUT ON METAL.
OPEN THE BOOK THE OLDER IF IN
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE MORE THANK.
LIVE A THINK BALL. I HAVE BEEN
BUT WHAT THAT THAT THIS PROCESS.
ONE SIXTY TWO SIX TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ONE OF THE YEAR THE
NUMBER. HE FIND OUT WHAT WILL
PROVIDE. INTEREST ON YOUR YOUR-
YOUR BLOOD ON THE- POP STAR WE
ARE NOT ALLOWED TO GO. IF YOUR
CHILDREN GO THAT. THIS IS. NINE
FORTY FIVE FOUR FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. AND GOOD MORNING. YEAH
YEAH I MEAN. IF YOU KNOW HOW
HOW ARE ONE AND I'M AP. THANK
YOU. I AM ONE THIRTY NINE ONE
THREE NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS MICHAEL SO
THAT WITH THE NATIONAL UNION OF
HEALTHCARE WORKERS CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. LINE TWO OH NINE TWO ZERO
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THE BLOCK WITH
TEAMSTERS JOINT COUNCIL SEVEN
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB. FIFTY
AND EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU. LINE
ONE SIXTY ONE SIX ZERO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BUT YOU CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CLICK COST ON BEHALF OF
THE APPRAISAL INSTITUTE THE
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
COMMITTEE AND I WANNA THANK-
THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING WITH
MIKE BELOW ARE THE APPRAISAL OF
THE NEXT AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. LINE ONE THIRTY ONE
ONE THREE IT'LL ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS SAM SAM YOU'RE WELL AND I
HAVE A LONG TIME MEMBER OF SB
YEAH YOU INVITED HEALTHCARE
WORKERS BLACK I AM A MEDICAL
ASSISTANT AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB ONE EIGHT FIVE
ZERO. THANK YOU. LINE THIRTY
FOUR THREE FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES I DID ADD THAT THE I'M VICE
PRESIDENT OF TEAMSTERS LOCAL
THREE NINETY NINE WHICH OF THE
ENTERTAINMENT DIVISION AND WE
AREN'T STRONG SUPPORT AT A. B.
EIGHTEEN FIFTY SB FIVE. THANK
YOU. LINE TWO SIXTY FIVE TWO
SIX FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY NAME IN AN INSTANT PART
SHOPPER AND CO FOUNDER
EQUIPMENT COLLECTIVE I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
FIVE AND MAYBE EIGHT. THANK YOU.
ONE ONE EIGHT SEVEN ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE ONE
EIGHT SEVEN ARE YOU ON ME. WELL
SORRY I AM STILL ON ON BEHALF
OF ASSOCIATED BUILDERS AND
CONTRACTORS OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. LINE TEN ONE ZERO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING TO THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS PERRY
LAMBERT AND I'M AN ACTOR AND A
MEMBER OF ACTORS EQUITY FLAG
AFTER AN AGATHA BUT I'M FALLING
IN WITH. AB FIFTY EIGHTEEN
FIFTY AND TO BE. WHAT PROVIDES
TO THEATRICAL. AND I THINK THEY
CAN FOR TIME LIMITS WHICH.
THANK YOU BLIND SEVEN TWO TO
SET TWO GO A- HELLO YES
JENNIFER WALKMAN ON BEHALF OF
IBEW LOCAL BY SIX NINE THREE
FOUR HUNDRED UNION ELECTRICIANS
OF SAN DIEGO AND IMPERIAL
COUNTIES AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NINE THIRTY SIX
THREE SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING TO THE CHAIR AND
TO THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
KYLE NEW GO AND FOR THE LAST
TWENTY THREE YEARS I HAVE BASED
MY PRACTICE OF THE PROFESSIONAL
PRODUCER AND PERFORMER OUT OF
LOS ANGELES. I'M CREATIVE
DIRECTOR OF IT SO FACTOR
THEATRICAL NINE IN CROWD
SUPPORT OF A STRONG A. B. FIVE
A. B. EIGHTEEN FIFTY STRONG
ENFORCEMENT OF WAGE LAW AND THE
A. B. C. DEFINITIONS. BUT IN
END TO WAGE THAT AND CAL BE
AFTER WORK. THANK YOU. THANK.
ONE SIX TWO ONE ONE SIXTY TO
YOUR LINE OF THE. AND ONE SIXTY
TWO OR YOU WANT ME. ONE FORM OF
ON LINE THIRTY TWO ONE THREE
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS HEATHER
RIGHT AND I'M A MEMBER OF AT
THE ARE YOU UNITED HEALTHCARE
WORKERS WHAT AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LINE ONE
THIRTY ONE THREE THEY'RE ALL
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE THIRTY
ARE YOU ABLE. ARE YOUR LINE
OPEN. HELLO KATHY GARMENT HE
SPEAKING FOR THE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND MEMBERS OF THE
ENTERTAINMENT UNION COALITION
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LINE NINETY THREE NINE THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS LISA VAN BEVERN I AM
A MEMBER OF IT YEAH YOU UNITED
HEALTH WORKERS PLAN. LET THE
HEALTHCARE PROFESSION WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT A. B. EIGHTEEN
FIFTY THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE
TWO EIGHTY SIX TWO EIGHT SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE TWO
EIGHTY SIX IS YOUR PHONE ON
MUTE. HELLO YEAH I'M SORRY I
CAN HEAR DISMEMBER MCKENZIE
WITH UNITED FOOD AND COMMERCIAL
WORKERS LOCAL ONE THIRTY FIVE
ECHO CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE
A. B. THE- GIVE. FIND TWO
SEVENTY ONE TWO SEVEN ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MEMBERS GREG
COOK QUICKLY TO THE GREATER
CALIFORNIA LIVERY ASSOCIATION
PROFESSIONAL ORGANIZATION OF
SIX THOUSAND LIVES IN OPERATORS
IN CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF. AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY AND CONTINUED
IMPLEMENTATION AND ENFORCEMENT
OF AB FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I AM TWENTY TWO TWO TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS PAUL CHILDREN WITH SCA
UNITED HEALTHCARE WORKERS WEST
AND I'M STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY. THANK YOU. LINE
ONE SEVENTY THREE ONE SEVEN
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING OUT MR REMEMBER THE
JOHN NOR WILL IT TAKES SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF THE INSURANCE
FIELD SERVICES ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ONE SEVENTEEN ONE SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
EVERYBODY MY NAME IS RICHARD
CASTLE GRANDE I'M ON BOARD OF
THE THEATRICAL PRODUCERS MAKE
OF LOS ANGELES I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WORK WITH THE POOR
EIGHTEEN FIFTY WITH AN
AMENDMENT FOR SMALL NONPROFIT
THEATERS. THANK YOU. NINE TWO
NINE EIGHT TWO NINE EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN KALRA COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MICHAEL
JOHNSON I AM THE PRESIDENT OF
THE THEATRICAL PRODUCERS LEAGUE
OF LOS ANGELES. WE SUPPORT A.
B. EIGHTEEN FIFTY WITH AN
AMENDMENT. OUR ASSOCIATION IS
SEEKING A LIMITED EXEMPTION
FROM EIGHTY FIVE NARROWLY
DRAFTED TO PROTECT OUR SMALL
COMMUNITY BASED THEATERS THAT
CANNOT AFFORD TO HIRE WORKERS
IN PRODUCTION RELATED POSITIONS
AS NON EXEMPT EMPLOYEES. A
PROPOSED LANGUAGE THAT ALLOWS
ORGANIZATIONS THE TOP SENT TO
NEGOTIATE EMPLOYMENT TRACKS.
THANK YOU. NINE TO NINETY ONE
TWO NINE LAW IN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS MISTER WARREN TOWARD THAT I
AM A MEMBER OF THE U. H. W. AT
THE ARE YOU YOU AGE W. WHERE WE
ARE IT'S STRONG SUPPORT OF A.
B. EIGHTEEN FIFTY. THANK YOU.
THREE ZERO TWO THREE OH TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS WHAT
WE NOW WITH THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY FEDERATION OF LABOR IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN
FIFTY THANK YOU. LINE SEVENTY
THREE SEVEN THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS MICHAEL BOARD. I WORK FOR
UBER AND THAT FULL TIME. AND
I'M A MEMBER OF RICHARD GRANT
UNITED. I'M CALLING BECAUSE I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB EIGHTEEN
FIFTY. AND EIGHTY FIVE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THREE ELEVEN
THREE ONE ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MELANIE QUIT AS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA BANKERS ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN THE PART IN HERE THANK
YOU. LINE THREE OF THREE
HUNDRED THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WELL HELLO THERE. AFTER BEING
ALL ON THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA HASTINGS AND I AM
CALLING TO FULLY SUPPORT AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY THREE AND EIGHTY
FIVE. THANK YOU. PINE THREE
THIRTEEN THREE ONE THREE IN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HIS FIRST
WROTE. UNDERSECRETARY TREASURER
OF FIVE COUNTY CENTRAL LABOR
COUNCIL REPRESENTING NINE
THOUSAND ORGANIZED WORKERS IN
MODOC SHASTA AND SISKIYOU DAMON
TRINITY COUNTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY.
THANK YOU. NINE TWO EIGHT SEVEN
TWO EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MARK PERHAPS BUT THE-
INTERNATIONAL STUDENTS. BUT THE
REASON AMEND BURT WARD THE
LARGEST. SB THIRTY. THANK YOU.
PINE THREE TWENTY TWO THREE TWO
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
EVENING THIS IS CUT YOUR FROM
ORANGE COUNTY MAYOR FEDERATION
CALLING ON- AND SUPPORT OFF A.
B. EIGHTEEN FIFTY. I AM THREE
TWENTY FIVE THREE TWO FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS A LITTLE BETTER BUT
THEN WHEN EMPIRE LABOR COUNCIL
CALLING DRIVING IN THE- OF AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY. THANK YOU.
THREE TWENTY SEVEN THREE TWO
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
THREE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR PHONE
MAY BE ON MUTE. GO ON THE LINE
FORTY THREE FOUR THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS MARIO
BAR I'M A CONTRACT SPECIALIST
FOR FBI YOU. UNITED HEALTHCARE
WORKERS WHAT ON MY RETURN TO
CARE ASSISTANT AND I AM SUPPORT
OF AB. ONE EIGHT FIVE ZERO.
THANK YOU. NINE THREE ZERO
SEVEN THREE OH SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS KIM ROBERTSON
DETECTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE NORTH
ABOUT LABOR FEDERATION CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTEEN AB FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THREE FOUR ONE NINE
THREE FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MORNING. HELLO YES. THE HEAD MY
NAME IS CHRISTOPHER CARUTHERS
HELLO YES GO AHEAD PLEASE MY
NAME IS. MY NAME IS CHRISTOPHER
CREDIT ON THE LIFELINE A
RESIDENT OF LOS ANGELES A
PROFESSIONAL ACTOR IN THAT FILM
TELEVISION AND THEATER AND I'M
CALLING STOCKS BUT EIGHTEEN
FIFTEEN EIGHTY FIVE WITH NO
CARD OUT. FOR ACTORS. LEADERS
AND WHAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. PINE THREE ZERO SIX
THREE ZERO SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES JOHN REILLY DIRECTOR OF THE
NAPA SOLANO CENTER LABOR
COUNCIL IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
BABY. THANK YOU. LINE SIXTY ONE
SIX ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI I'M
A FULL TIME LIFT DRIVER FOR
FIVE YEARS MY NAME IS PLEASED
TO OFFER. I'M AN ACTIVE MEMBER
OF RIDE SHARE DRIVERS UNITED- I
AM STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
FIVE IT'S CRITICAL TO OUR
PROFESSION WITHOUT IT WE HAVE
NO RIGHT- I ANY UNEMPLOYMENT SO
WE NEED TO FIX THE SYSTEM AND I
AM STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF. THE
EIGHTEEN. YEAH THANK YOU SO
MUCH. AND TWO EIGHTY NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS TIFFANY SEAN BUT I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF BOTH THE-
THE BILL ON THE AMENDMENT- I'M-
SORRY NERVOUS UP BUT I'M
CALLING BECAUSE I HAVE AN
INVOLVED OR HAVE BEEN WORKING
FOR SEVERAL ABUSIVE. SAYS I'VE
BEEN A BETTER PERFORMER NOT.AND SUFFERING THEY AFTER THAT-
A BALLET TEACHER AND A LOT OF
THE FUTURE AND- MOST RECENTLY
BEEN OPPOSED TO ME AND THEY ARE
ALL. OF YOU OF WHICH THAT. YEAH
THANK YOU. PINE THREE FIFTY
SEVEN THREE FIVE SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES HELLO YES. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
LABOR COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
THAT BUT IF MARKETS- AT BEEN AN
INTERPRETER A TRANSLATOR AT AND
THE AND INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA FOR THE
LAST. TWENTY PLUS YEARS. AND
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
COALITION OF PRACTICING
TRANSLATORS AND INTERPRETERS OF
CALIFORNIA. FOUR OF EIGHTEEN
FIFTY AS LONG AS IT IS AMENDED
TO INCLUDE INTERPRETERS CAPS
NURSING TRANSCRIBERS THAN NOT
IMPOSING IN THE LAW. THE
REQUIREMENT OF CERTIFICATION.
AND LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR N ORDER TO
REACH OUTCOMES THAT BENEFITS
SPENDING ALL OF. IT VERY
IMPORTANT MATTER. ALL FIND
THREE SEVENTY THREE SEVEN ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. HELLO YES.
GOOD MY NAME IS MIKE EIGHT YES
MY NAME IS MIKE TIVO AND I'M
WITH THE NAPA SOLANO CENTRAL
LABOR COUNCIL AND- WE'RE
STRONGLY IN FAVOR OF AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY THANK YOU. I AM
FORTY FOUR ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS TAMMY JANE CAN
YOU GIVE ME YES. YEAH YES WE
CAN HEAR YOU AND- OKAY. MY NAME
IS A REGIONAL A AND I'VE BEEN A
RIDE CHER DRIVER WITH UBER AND
LIFT THE FOUR YEAR AND- A
NUMBER OF RIDESHARE DRIVERS
UNITED AND THEN CALL IMPORTED
AB FIVE AND JACKSON. EIGHTEEN
THE THANK YOU VERY MUCH HAVE
THANK YOU. FIND TO FORTY TWO
TWO FOUR TWO YOUR LINE OF THE-
YEAH HI THIS IS JIM SMITH FROM
TEAMSTERS LOCAL THREE NINETY
SIX IN SUPPORT OF AB FIFTY AND
EIGHTY FIVE. THANK YOU. NINE
THREE SEVENTY SEVEN THREE SEVEN
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS DOUG BERNIE I'M THE
BUSINESS REPRESENTATIVE OF I
EIGHT YEARS HE LOCAL EIGHT
EIGHT FOUR IN LOS ANGELES. AND
I SUPPORT A. B. IN FIFTY THANK
YOU THANK YOU. LINE THREE
EIGHTY FIVE THREE EIGHT FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
TAMMY DREAMER SACRAMENTO
CENTRAL LABOR COUNCIL
REPRESENTING A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY SIX THOUSAND WORKERS IN
THE COUNTY AREA IN SUPPORT AT
EIGHT EIGHT. THANK YOU. NINE
THREE NINETY ONE THREE NINE ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
THIS IS YOUR MOVEMENT ON BEHALF
OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
ALSO SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE
TWO ZERO SEVEN TWO OH SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MORNING LINE
TWO OH SEVEN ARE YOU ON MUTE. I
AM HERE BECAUSE FROM THE UCLA
LABOR CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GET THIS
TIME THEY'RE NOT FOR THE
ALLIANCE IN Q. THANK YOU SO
MUCH OF THE WERE FOLKS OVER
TRYING TO GET IN I KNOW THAT
SOME OF THE- LINES GET JAMMED
UP. OUR WEBSITE AS WELL AND YOU
CAN REGISTER SUPER SESSION ONE
OF SHE MAY HAVE. L. R. DOT
ASSEMBLY DOT CA. DOT G. O. V.
AGAIN A. L. B. R. DOT. ASSEMBLY
DOT CA DOT G. O. V. AND SO WHAT
IF YOU WERE ABLE TO GET AN-
APOLOGY IS- BUT- WE APPRECIATE.
BUDGET ALMOST DOES. STATE ANA
THE TASK OF NAME ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION OF THE US THAT FOR
THE REST THE HEARING HOPEFULLY
FOLKS CAN CONTINUE. TO DO THAT-
AS WELL. ALL RIGHT SO NOW WE
WILL GO TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IS TWO MINUTES EACH
AND IN OPPOSITION WE HAVE. BOTH
ON THE PHONE LINES A MICKEY OUR
STRIKER OF THE NATIONAL. AS FOR
THE DIFFERENCES. AND BUILD TOBY
AFTER THAT AND THE AMERICAN
SOCIETY OF JOURNAL. HELLO
MISTER. OSTROM PLEASE. GOD
MORNING MY NAME IS NIKKI ALL
STRIKER I AM THE GENERAL
COUNSEL THE NATIONAL PRESS
PHOTOGRAPHERS ASSOCIATION VOICE
OF VISUAL JOURNALISTS SINCE
NINETEEN FORTY SIX. THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY
REGARDING OUR OPPOSITION TO AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY AND TWENTY TWO
FIFTY SEVEN UNLESS AMEND THAT
FULL DISCLOSURE AND PPA ALONG
WITH THE AMERICAN SOCIETY OF
JOURNALISTS AND AUTHORS ARE
PLAYING. CHAU JING AB I'VE AS A
GROUP OUR RIGHTS UNDER THE
FIRST FOURTEENTH MAN. WE DON'T.
THE PROPOSAL OF THE FIVE TO
LIMIT ON STARLESS AND COMMAND
THE MOST RECENT AGREE BUT
BILL'S AUTHOR TO REMOVE THE IN
ADVANCE AND INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY THANKS WHICH THE BILL.
CONTAINING SUCH TERMS AS
BROADCAST NEWS TELEVISION LIVE
SHOWS AND INTERNET STREAMING
FOR ANY DEVICE WHICH COULD HAVE
BRIDGE TRADITIONAL JOURNALISTIC
ACTIVITIES. AND PTA PURCHASE
THE LEGISLATURE TO REVIVE THAT
LANGUAGE WELL LIMóN NAY THE
CONFUSION BY SUCH A OVERLY
BROAD AND VAGUE DEFINITIONS AND
LEFT BE UNINTENDED CAN. ON OUR
ABILITY TO FREELANCE. THE
IMPOSITION OF CONCERTS. AND ON
EIGHT CONTENT BASED RESTRICTION.
ON FREE LINE JOURNAL. ALONG
DEPUTY CHAIR COUNSEL OF THE CAL.
WE HAVE TO MORE COPPER WRITTEN
COMMON AND WILLOW FOR HERE
WHICH WE HOPE YOU WILL REVIEW
AND ADOPT YEAH THANKS THE
BILL'S AUTHOR FOR WORKING WITH
US ON THE LATEST LANGUAGE
REVISIONS THANKS. FOR ACCEPTING
TESTED REGARDING THE REMAINING
LANGUAGE OBJECTIONS WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST BUT THERE
AMENDMENT OF THESE BILLS
RECOMMEND. AND LOOK FOR TO WORK
IF YOU. AND I REMAIN AVAILABLE
TO QUESTION. VERY MUCH THANK
YOU ANYTHING PER OF THE RED OUR
OUR OUR THEY BETWEEN SOUTH WILL
SURE THAT AS OF THE MOVES FOR
ON NEXT YEAR MIL TOBY
REPRESENTED SOCIETY OF JOURNAL
BY PHONE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
COMMITTEE WE- TAKE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY IS AS I SAID MY NAME IS
MILK TOBY PRESENT. OF THE- SO.
OF AND ALL. FOR MORE THAN THE
YEARS THAT I J. RECORDS. IN THE-
RAW OF NON. OUR MEMBERS THINK
SUCCESS GEORGE. BUT AUTHORS CON
MARKER WHO IT CHOSEN. AND
THAT'S THE OPERATIVE WORD HERE
TO THOUSAND PURSUE. CAREERS
THEIR SUCCESSFUL SMALL. OWNERS
IN EVERY SENSE OF WORD. MEMBERS
ALONG WITH. WRITER HELLO HAVE
SUFFERED FINANCE HARM TO THE
PASSAGE OF THE BILL FIVE THIS
SUPPLY BEGIN DROPPING THEIR PRE
LAW THE BEFORE B. FIVE WENT
INTO FIVE MONTHS AGO AND
POTENTIAL CLIENTS MORE MORE FOR
LUCK. TO TELL RIDERS NUTRITION
PLANS RIGHT A LOT NO SIGN OF
LETTING UP. IF YOU WISH TO IN
TEN WE GRAY APPRECIATE EFFORTS
OF THE COMMITTEE TO RESOLVE OF
THE WITH A. B. THROUGH THE
AMENDMENTS GROUP. IN BILL
EIGHTEEN FIFTY ASSEMBLY BILL.
TWENTY TWO FIFTY. ONE OF THE
MOST OWNER. THE BABY IS A
THIRTY FIVE SUBMIT WRIST AND ON.
WRITER WHO WISH TO MAINTAIN
THEIR CHOSE SET WITHIN THE
PENTAGON. WITH THE REMOVAL
THIRTY SUBMIT CAP IS REPORT IN
BOTH OF THE GROUP BILL BEING.
THE IT ALSO IS ARE UNDER THAT
IN AGREEMENT BEEN TO DELETE LET
GROUP TO COUNTRY SIX. A ADVANCE
THAT MUCH LECTURE PROPER RIGHTS
BOTH OF THE PROPOSED. WE
REQUESTED THESE DELETION AND
WRITTEN. TO THE WE SO THIS
BECAUSE SO. THE CARD CZAR. IN
THE HEART THE WILL CONTINUE IN
THE ISSUES BABY HAVE BEEN
RESULT CANNOT BE UNDONE. THE
BEST WE CAN DO THIS POINT IS TO
MOVE FORWARD THEM PEARL OF LAW
WE SERVE THIS THAT SINCE
SECTION. I ALSO VITAL IF THERE
ANY. FROM THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU BOTH AND SO NOW
WE WILL. TO THOSE AN OPERA WHO
ARE IN THE- THAT IS A AT
OPPOSITION THAT'S IN THE ROOM.
THAT WOULD LIKE TO STATE THE
POSITION. NOT SEEING ANYONE
RISING OR RAISING THEIR HAND. I
WILL MOVE ON TO THE MODERATOR
OF DO WE HAVE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION THAT'S ON THE PHONE
LINES. THANK YOU FOR THE
POSITION OF OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILLING ME PRESS ONE THAN
LITERAL AND ALL START WITH LINE
EIGHT NINE EIGHT NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. LINE EIGHTY NINE IS
YOUR PHONE ON MUTE. WILL MOVE
ON TO LINE FOUR ZERO EIGHT FOUR
OH EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING GO THIRTY YES AND
I AM REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA MUSIC EDUCATORS
ASSOCIATION WITH AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION OR THE
REASONS PROVIDED IN OUR MAY
EIGHTEENTH LETTER WE WILL. WITH
THE AUTHOR ON OUR QUEST
EXEMPTION THANK YOU THANK YOU A
YES LETTER IS IN THE RECORD
THANK YOU. LINE ONE SIX TWO ONE
SIX TWO YOU MAY GO AHEAD. LINE
ONE SIXTY TWO IS YOUR PHONE ON
ME. BERMAN BONTA LINED TWO
TWENTY TWO TWO TWO TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES. CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN
HEAR YOU I THOUGHT BERMAN.
WONDERFUL HI MY NAME IS JOHN
BYRNE I REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIAN MUSIC EDUCATORS
ASSOCIATION. AND WE OPPOSE AND
LEFT AMENDED WE HAVE A SMALL
AMENDMENT THAT WE HAVE. ARE
SENT TO ASSEMBLYMAN. THANK YOU.
LINE TWO FOURTEEN TWO ONE FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS BRANDON WATERSON AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB FIVE AS WELL
AS THE BILL THE OPPOSED- GIVEN
RIGHT NOW IT IS. COMPLETELY
TAKING FREEDOM AWAY FROM ALL
THE PEOPLE THAT I REPRESENT AND
THE DJ FIELD AS WELL AS THE
PRODUCERS. THANK YOU. LINE ONE
FORTY NINE ONE FOUR NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS LISA
WALKING BACK THEN I'M
CALIFORNIA S. CORCORAN
FREELANCING IN BUT WRITER
CARTOONIST I REPRESENT THE
LOWLY GUILD IS DIFFERENT
CALIFORNIA FREELANCERS. BUT
EIGHTY FIVE FIFTY SIX ONE THERE
THEY'RE STILL MANY MOVED. HELLO
HELLO AMENDED AS THE AS REGARDS
I CAN. BLANK BUT AND BUSINESS
CONSULTANT NAME JUST FEW THANK
THANK YOU. LINE THREE EIGHT
THREE EIGHTY IT'S GOING. WHAT
THANK YOU FOR BEING THERE I'M
CAP SO I I'M WITH THE ON THE.
OR A BIRD THE HOT HELLO MY
FATHER SEVEN CURRENT INTO YOUR
NINE ONE ONE WHAT WILL WE DO
WITH WILL LABOR SITUATIONS THAT
CALL FOR HER PER IN THE MOMENT.
POLICE EVERYTHING THAT CAN
IMAGINE A BURDEN THE- ON
REQUIRED IN ORDER THINKING HE-
IMPROPERLY THANK YOU SIR. LINE
FOUR OH SIX FOUR ZERO SIX
HUMANE. HELLO MY NAME IS
PATRICIA SECRETARY I'M
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR THAT'S
COMMUNITY SERVICES IN SAN DIEGO
BUT I'M CALLING REPRESENTING
OUR DEATH CONSUMERS IN
CALIFORNIA. FINANCING LANGUAGE
INTERPRETERS FOR THEIR DAILY
LIVING WE ARE HOPING THE BILL
UNLESS IT'S AMENDED TO INCLUDE
SIGN LANGUAGE INTERPRETERS AND
REAL CRAP HAVE YOURS THANK YOU
THANK YOU. LINE ONE TWENTY FOUR
ONE FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY AT LAKE A RETIRED
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR AND
SILICON VALLEY AND A NEW WAS
KILLED IN CALIFORNIA LANCE
WRITER SHE KNIGHTED NUMBER.
SOME OF MY OLD POSTS TO
EIGHTEEN FIFTY BECAUSE OF
ELIMINATES CONTRACTORS INSTEAD
OF IMPROVE PROTECTION FOR THE-
THANK YOU. TWO THIRTEEN TWO ONE
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT NAME
IS LANCE CRAMER ABOUT LIFTED
UBER DRIVER AND POSSIBLY IN THE
CART IF FIVE EIGHTY FIVE IS.
NOT ALLOWED TO GO THROUGH I
LOVE MY FREEDOM AND FLEXIBILITY
THAT WILL ALL BE TAKEN AWAY.
AND CALIFORNIA WILL BECOME
DISPUTE BUT THE PUBLIC. THANK
YOU. AND FOUR HUNDRED FOUR ZERO
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. FOUR
HUNDRED IS YOUR PHONE ON MUTE.
WILL MOVE THE LINE ONE FORTY
SEVEN ONE FOUR SEVENPLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS JENNIFER
WALKING CAN HEAR ME. YES. OKAY
MY NAME IS JENNIFER WALTON I
REPRESENT THE FIVE MILLION
FREELANCE WORKERS IN OUR STATE
OF THE SAFETY NET DESCRIBED BY
LEARNING INVOLVED TO PROTECT
SOME WORKERS HAVE A HOLE IN IT
LARGE ENOUGH FOR FIVE MILLION
POIGNANT. I'M HE DOES NOT HAVE
THE RIGHT TO TELL WORKING YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE. EIGHT LINE
FOURTEEN FOUR ONE THREE RATHER
LINE ONE. FOUR ONE THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH HELLO MY NAME IS
ZACHARY SMITH I'M OWNERS HE'S
MISINTERPRETING AND A MEMBER OF
THE NATIONAL REGISTRY OF
INTERPRETERS FOR THE DEAF I AM
IN EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN HE HAS
WRITTEN AND AMENDED TO INCLUDE
TIME WHICH INTERPRETERS
LANGUAGE PERFECT. THE BILL
PASSED. IN GRABBERS THANK YOU
FOR. THANK YOU. WE DO HAVE AN
ADDITIONAL LINE AT THE
MICROPHONE ONE MOMENT. LINE FOR
TWENTY ONE FOUR TO ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MATT GRAY ON
BEHALF OF CAL SMALL BUSINESS IN
OPPOSITION TO THE ARBITRARY
CHOOSING OF WINNERS AND LOSERS
AB FIVE AND ALSO A. B.
LEGISLATION. WE ASK FOR
PROPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WE HAVE ANOTHER LINE IN Q. LINE
FOR TWENTY THREE. OR TWENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS LEONARD LEADING AND-
I'M A FREELANCE VIDEOGRAPHER IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA EVERYONE I
KNOW QUIRK SHOULD FREELANCED
INCLUDING PRODUCERS AS OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL IT CREATES ONEROUS
RESTRICTIONS ONE PRODUCER AND
THANK YOU SIR OF LIMITS. LINE
FOR TEN LINE FOR ONE ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GET WE FEED
THEM WITH EASTERN INTERPRETING
AND A MEMBER OF THE REGISTRY OF
INTERPRETERS FOR THE DEAF AND
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF SIGN
LANGUAGE INTERPRETERS IN REAL
TIME CAPTION. I'M AYE OPPOSED
EIGHTEEN FIFTY UNLESS AMENDED
TO INCLUDE PROFESSIONAL SERVICE
EXEMPTION FOR SIGN LANGUAGE
INTERPRETERS IN REAL TIME
CAPTURE. EXCLUDING THE LANGUAGE
REQUIRING CERTIFICATION OF A
VERY COMPLEX IN OUR INDUSTRY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR NO
FURTHER LINES IN Q. THANK YOU
AND- ONCE AGAIN OF THE WEBSITE
IS A L. B. R. DOT ASSEMBLY DOT
CA DOT GOBBLED PIZZA DURING THE
COURSE THE HEARING. FOR SOME
WAS ABLE IN TIME FOR THE REST
OF THE PHONE LINES THEY CAN
EMAIL OR OR SUBMIT TO THE- ANY
COM. OR SUPPORTER OPPOSED
POSITIONS FOR ANY OF THE BILLS.
US IS THE FIRST ONE IS GOING TO
MAKE THAT VERY CLEAR TO FOLKS.
OTHERS BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WITH ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS MOTIONS. YES BY A VICE
CHAIR FOR. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR ASSEMBLY WOMAN. OBVIOUSLY
WE'RE WE'RE DEALING WITH AB
FIVE AGAIN AND I THINK WE'RE
GOING TO DEAL WITH THE FOR A
LITTLE WHILE- AS WE WORK
THROUGH SOME OF THESE
EXEMPTIONS BUT- I DO WANT TO
DRESS. I LOOKED A LITTLE
INTERESTING THEN. LOT OF BILLS
THAT DEALT WITH AB FIVE I THINK
FIFTEEN TO BE EXACT THAT WERE
NOT SET THROUGH THIS COMMITTEE-
ON THE REPUBLICAN SIDE OF THE
AISLE BUT ONE IN PARTICULAR I
BRING IT UP BECAUSE- ABOUT IT
TODAY. INTERPRETERS WITH
TRANCE. IT WAS AB TWENTY NINE
SEVENTY NINE VOTE THAT WOULD
DEAL WITH THIS ISSUE SITE AS
FOR MY PERSPECTIVE. MOVE FOR
WITH DEALING WITH. WHAT IS THE
WAY TO WORK WITH YOU THIRTY
FIVE. THE LABOR COMMITTEE- AS A
WHOLE TO TRY TO YES SOME OF
THESE. NEW ONES BUSINESSES THAT
HAVE BEEN SUCKED INTO AB FIVE
THAT I DON'T THINK THAT YOU ARE
KNOWINGLY OR WHAT WANTING TO
HURT RIGHT TIME I TRUST THAT.
BUT THERE IS A LOT OF JUST.
BUSINESSES THE GET PULLED THAT
WE KIND OF SUCKED INTO THIS
VORTEX THAT IS AB FIVE AND WE
NEED TO NOT WORK THROUGH THAT
AND YOU STATED THAT A NUMBER OF
TIMES LIKE WE'RE WORKING
THROUGH THIS THERE IS GOING TO
BE FIXES BUT IT TURNED A LITTLE
BIT BECAUSE WE SIGNIFICANT.
AMOUNT OF. BILLS THAT DEALT
WITH EXEMPTIONS THAT WERE
IMPORTANT. TO OUR DISTRICTS.
THAT ART CONSTITUENTS ASKED US.
TO WORK WITH. INCLUDING ONE
ADULT WITH INTERPRETERS AND
TRANSLATORS. SO I GUESS MIGHT
WITH MORE OF A STATEMENT AN
ENGINE LINE WE WOULD MEAN TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY. THAT WHETHER
IT BE THE AYE COMMUNITY.
WHETHER IT BE INTERPRETERS THE
QUITE FRANKLY I DON'T KNOW A
LOT ABOUT WAS NOT MY INDUSTRY
BUT I'D VERY SYMPATHETIC AND
I'M GLAD YOU'RE ALL HERE TODAY.
WORK THROUGH THIS PROCESS. THAT
COME TO YOU WITH THESE IDEAS
FIRST. AND FOR WHAT LENDS ARE
WE PICKING AND I AND I KNOW THE
TERM WINNERS AND LOSERS HAS
COME UP A LOT AND I THINK
THAT'S A LITTLE BIT HARSH TO BE
QUITE HONEST WITH YOU BECAUSE I
DON'T THINK THAT THAT'S GOING
TO. PICK IN WHAT YOU IN THE
BUSINESS. AS IT RELATES TO SOME
OF THESE INDUSTRIES THAT HAVE
BEEN SUCKED INTO A LAMP TURNED
THAT WITH OPENING UP. OUR BIT
IN THE FOR LIVING. ALONE AT THE
END DO NOT LEGISLATION SO I
GUESS THAT'S MY CAN IN JUST
DEAL WITH NOT. SO I WILL. SAY
TO YOU WHAT I HAVE SAID AND I
CAN PEOPLE ON EVEN REPUBLICANS
ON THIS COMMITTEE HAVE COME TO
MY OFFICE MULTIPLE TIMES WITH
THESE ISSUES OUT OF THE YOU
KNOW WORK WITH THEIR
CONSTITUENTS. ANYONE WHO HAS
COME. EXT IT. SHOWS. I'VE BEEN
VERY. ABOUT HOW WE LOOK AT ALL
THESE BEST SO WHEN YOU SAY
WINNERS AND LOSERS SOMETIMES IT
FOR PICK EIGHTEEN IF YOU CUT
CONSIDER BUSINESS THE WINNER.
THEN THE WORKERS ARE LOSERS. WE
HAVE TO BE VERY CAREFUL HOW
PROCESS INTERPRETERS AND
TRANSLATORS HAVE BEEN SOME OF
THE MOST DIFFICULT TO DEAL WITH
AND I'LL EXPLAIN WHY. WE DO
THIS LATER- THAT WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO GET INTO THE BILL
NOW. WE HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
CERTIFICATION WE HAVE THE
DYNAMICS DECISION THAT LAYS OUT
CLEARLY THE TYPES OF THINGS WE
NEED TO LOOK AT TO AVOID
EXPLOITATION. WE LOOK AT
THROUGH THAT IS. I'LL BUT DO
WHEN THINGS WE IS WE CHECK WITH
THE D. ON PASS MISS CLASS. FOR
THOU ONE AND A LOT AND IN
OTHERS HAVE BEEN ON DEEMED
MISCLASSIFIED IN THE LAST FIVE
YEARS FOUR THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED
AND- TEN PEOPLE. THE VISUALS.
TO THE EIGHTY PART. IN AT.
RIGHT BRELO. INTO ONE OF THE
FACTORS WE LOOK AT IT'S REALLY
HARD TO SAY UP YOUR YOUR ALL
ALL. YOU'RE STILL UNDER BURKE
INSIDE YOU STILL HAVE GO
THROUGH ALL THE- OR DO WE LOOK
AT AND SAY. OKAY HOUSING THAT'S
WHAT WHAT'S CAUSING THIS COMP
FOR SOME IN WANT TO BE IN A
CONTRACTOR SOME DO. WHY ARE
SOME COMPANIES REQUIRED TO MEET
THEM EMPLOYEES BY EDIE AN AUDIT
AND OTHERS ARE NOT DOING THAT.
LEADERS WHICH DO WRITTEN
DOCUMENTATION. FINEST
CLASSIFICATIONS IT'S AGAIN SO
WE WERE TRYING TO PUT IT INTO
THE BILL. NOW WE WANTED A
CERTIFICATION THAT IF IT THE
OTHER THINGS WE TALKED ABOUT
YOU KNOW IF YOUR TRANSLATOR
WHAT MAKES THAT. HI XIN. IN
SOME TRAP. ASKED US FOR THAT
WELL THEN WE FIND OUT THAT THE
SAID THERE IS NO CERTIFICATION
EXCEPT BY ONE. AND IT'S ONLY
FOR SPANISH IN SO WE'RE LEAVING
OUT A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT WE AT
ME TO LEAVE OUT. CREATE ANOTHER.
WE ALLOW PEOPLE TO. JUST
BECAUSE- THEY SPEAKING LANGUAGE
IN IN SO THE BARRIER TO ENTRY
BECOMES VERY LOW ESPECIALLY IN
A STATE LIKE HELP WE HAVE A LOT
OF MULTI LINGUAL PEOPLE ININ
IN SO IT'S RIGHT FOR ITS WHAT
YOU WERE WORK TRANSLATE THAT'S
IT THERE'S CONTROL YOU DO.
THOSE THINGS RIGHT INTO. OUR
SOLE. WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW DO WE STATE. TRUE TO
THE DYNAMICS RULING AND WE HAVE
DONE THAT I APPRECIATE PEOPLE
SAY THE WINNERS AND LOSERS AND
RANDOM EXEMPTIONS AND THAT THAT
TO ME I GOT IT IF YOU HAVEN'T
SPENT I GUESS LAST THREE YEARS
LOOKING AT CASE. THAT ALL ALL.
ASIAN LOOKING AT EIGHT SEEMS
MATH CLASS OKAY SUITS AND BRAWL
OF. ASKING TO ALL OF THESE WORK
THAN IT DOES LOOK LIKE AND I'M
THERE WAS NO RAN ABOUT THE
THING SELECTED WE HAVE BEEN.
SYSTEMATICALLY GOING THROUGH
THEM AND TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WITH INTERPRETERS WERE STILL
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW CAN
INTERPRETER'S WORK UNDER PEARL
AGENCY. OR REFERRAL AGENCY AND
NOT A BROKER. OF RECORD THAT
SEEMS TO BE THE DIFFERENCE
RIGHT HOW MUCH LEVEL. YOU TO DO
YOUR WORK. WE AN INDEPENDENT
YOUR OWN SMALL. AND I WANNA
REMIND PEOPLE ONE OF THE THINGS
WE DID IN THIS BILL IS WE TOOK
THE BUSINESS TO BUSINESS
EXEMPTION PUT IT AT THE TOP
COULD BECAUSE THAT'S THE FIRST
THING PEOPLE SHOULD ACT AND
THAT IS VERY. YOU CAN BE A SOUL
ARE YOU AND- HE HE AT. AT AND
YOU CAN BE AND IF YOU BUY THOSE
TERMS WERE YOU ARE ACTING AS- A
LOT. TRAIN RIGHT NOW. SOME
INTERPRETERS. HUNDRED
CONDITIONS. THE FIRST THING
THAT YOU MIGHT NOT EVEN NEED AN
EXEMPTION. BUT WITH WITH C.
INTERPRETERS WERE CONTINUING TO
TRY TO HAVE THESE CONVERSATIONS
IS OUR STANDARD IS THERE THE
CERTIFIED INTERPRETERS IS THAT
DIFFERENT BECAUSE THEY HAVE A
DIFFERENT ABILITY AND-
COMMUNITY I CAN DEAL. I THINK
WE USE LOT OF INTER MEANS YOU
CAN IMAGINE THERE THAT OF
INTERPRETERS WHO WORKS NOT ONLY
IS INTERPRETERS BUT THEY'RE
ALSO OUT. IN OTHER INTERPRETER.
A HIERARCHY SO IF YOU GET TO
ENTER THE HOT TEA THE LAST AND
TIRED YOU KNOW. BROKER AND
HIRED YOUR FIRST THEY'RE
GETTING VERY LITTLE MY FOR WHAT.
AND THOSE THE INTERPRETER CAME
TO ME IN PLEASE EXEMPTS
INTERPRET. SO IT'S A BALANCE
AND WE'RE TRYING TO GET THERE
WE'RE GOING TO THERE SOME.
SUGGEST SOMEBODY WHO'S HEARD
FROM THIS ENTRY. ONE OF THEM
XIN YOU KNOW. I DID KIND OF
FIND OUT AND BECAUSE I HAVE
BEEN WORK LISTEN I KNOW HOW TO
READ CAN I KNOW. A LOOK THAT'S
RIDICULOUS SOME PEOPLE WHO
DIDN'T GET EXEMPTION VERY GOOD
LOBBYIST SOME PEOPLE WHO GOT
EXEMPTION FOR HAD NO LOBBYIST
YOU KNOW WE ACTUALLY TRIED.
YOUR IN WERE CONTINUE. BY
LOOKING TO KATE ARE LOOKING HAS
PER. IN AN A- AND- YOU KNOW
MISS CLARK. HELLO A WORKER
SHOULD NOW HAVE TO GO THROUGH
HOOPS AND HOPES HOOPS TO
CLASSIFICATION WE THEY'RE
CLEARLY CLASSIFY. THAT WHAT
THIS BILL IS SUPPOSED DO AT THE
SAME TIME PEOPLE ARE TRULY
THERE OWN BUSINESS WE'RE TRYING
TO TAKE CARE OF ME TO CONTINUE
WORK. THERE'S A PARTICULAR
ISSUE ANY MEMBER EVEN. YEAH AS
I'VE NEVER DENY FOR A MEETING
NUMBER OF AND SOME YOU KNOW WE
AS WELL AS THEM HAVE COME IN
BEEN A LOT OF TIME WITH ME ON
THESE SO I WELCOME YOU I WILL
ANYONEHAS THESE AND I JUST ASK
YOU YOU WALK THROUGH THE DESIGN
PORT WITH ME I ASK THAT YOU. IS
SEEN L. A. THAT'S WHAT. RELEASE
THIS WORK OUT THERE FOR LOSERS
WHEN PRESSED TO MAKE THEM I
APPRECIATE THAT AND I YOU KNOW
MY CONCERN IS YOU CAN'T ON A
YOUR YOU YOU MADE A STATEMENT
THAT YOU GOING THROUGH THE
SYSTEM. OF WHAT IS THAT
SYSTEMATIC APPROACH THAT WE'RE
GOING THROUGH RIGHT AND BECAUSE
I DO THINK THAT WHILE WHILE
WE'RE DEALING WITH THESE ISSUES
THERE MAY BE INDUSTRIES OUT
HERE THAT ARE JUST LEFT OUT
HERE FIGHTING SHORT DOT. THE
WHAT WE WANT TO BE. NOT ON WHAT
YOU'RE DOING WITH ME. ASIAN AND
I AM. BILL TODAY- BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE GO
THROUGH EIGHTY FIVE AS YOU KNOW
PUTTING THE PIECES BACK
TOGETHER AGAIN UNDER YOU KNOW
NOT WORTH PROTECTING EMPLOYEES
AS WELL SO ANYWAYS CHAIR CHURCH.
IS FOR AN ABBREVIATED KNOW WHAT
PEOPLE WATCHING US THEY DON'T
AND- THE RATIONALE THAT THEY
USE. ABOUT THE INTO A FIELD SO
WE TALKED A LOT ABOUT THAT YOU
KNOW DO YOU NEED A SPECIALIZED
DEGREE DO WE NEED A SPECIALIZED
CERTIFICATION BECAUSE WHEN YOU
ADD THOSE UP ON TOP OF. I'M
JUST BEING A VIGIL YOUR LETTER
LIKELY POINTED BECAUSE- IT'S
HARD TO GET INTO FOR EXAMPLE
DOCTORS LAWYERS EVERY SAID WELL
WHY DID YOU EXAMPLE I'M- WELL.
IT'S STORE NO YOU CAN'T. SO WE-
NEGOTIATE FOR THEM CONTROL OVER
THEIR OWN- ABILITY TO NEGOTIATE
DOWN TO THEIR OWN WORK THAT
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT FEATURE WAS
IN PART BE HELLO HOW ALL OF JOB
YOUR- RIDLEY THAT'S WHAT IT
WAS. WE WILL HAVE ORDERS RIGHT
TO THEIR EXISTING WHICH IS THAT
HAVE EXEMPTIONS FOR FOLKS
THAT'S HOW WE GOT MORE. THAN I
MEAN WHERE WOULD I COME UP WITH
COMMERCIAL FISHERMEN IT'S BEEN
A LOT FOR YOU KNOW SINCE YEARS
AT THE ORDER. ALL OF THE FIRST
TO SAY WHAT ARE GONE AND WHAT.
SIR THIS DAY IN THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF THERE'S A THAT WE
TRIED TO LINE UP THE BILL WITH
AND THEN WE WENT THROUGH PASSED
CLASS OF KITCHEN PEOPLE
HISTORICALLY BEEN EMPLOYED AND
THE BILL NOW JUST MAKING THEM
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS IN LIEU
RIGHT KIND OF FOR. AS WE- ALL
THRILLED. MOST FOLKS YOU CAN
KIND OF WHEN YOU GO THROUGH HE
GETS RIGHT LIKE THAT'S WHY I
SAID WE I WHEN I TOLD LAST
NIGHT LIKE HATE I INSIST ON
MAKE SPLIT CATION FOR
TRANSLATORS. OKAY THAT'S- RIGHT
BECAUSE WE WANT TO TRY TO GET
TRANSLATOR TO ACT INDEPENDENTLY
THE ABILITY DO THAT BUT
CERTAINLY TELL ME THERE'S NO
BARRIER TO ENTRY BUT IS THAT
BERRIER THEN CAN ANY.
TRANSLATOR BECAUSE OF. YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE A LATE WELL THAT'S
EXTREMELY LARGE AND THAT'S-
VULNERABLE TEXT TATIAN IT. SO I
WORK. I'M TRYING I DON'T WANT
ANYONE TO LOSE MONEY I DON'T
WANT ANYONE TO LOSE THEIR
WAGES- I DON'T WANT TO MESS UP
ANYBODY'S. BUSINESS BUT WE ALSO
HAVE TO INSURE. FOR THAT. YOUR
DECISION. YOU KNOW THAT MISTER
OF. CAN YOU IT TOOK A LOT TIME
TO GET TO MUSIC AT WHAT'S ONE
OF THESE THAT THAT TOOK THE
UNIONS THE INDEPENDENT ARTISTS
THE- RECORD INDUSTRY IN WAS A
LOT BUT WERE COMMITTED TO WE
NOW WORK I THINK PICKING
EXEMPTION AND JUST THROWING
AMOUNT IS NOT THE WAY TELL A WE
TO ON. WE AS WE HAVE AND I JUST
WANT THAT BECAUSE- OF HER AND
AN JOURNAL SAID YOU KNOW THEY
HAVE AS A LAWSUIT. WITH LAWSUIT
THROWN OUT BY THE COURTS AS-
LAWSUIT. CHALLENGE THE FIVE
EIGHT RECORDS WITH THE PROGRAM
SUIT YEAH IN SO THAT'S WHY ON A
P. YOU'RE THE ONE. BECAUSE THE
JUDGE. I'M SAYS. DIRECTLY LATER
PROHIBITS THAT REGULATES THE IN
READ IN IT THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION US CONSTITUTION SO.
BUT WE WANT TO NOT BE RANDOM
AND GIVE RANDOM EXEMPTIONS AND
SO THAT'S WHY WE GO THROUGH
THIS PROCESS AND I THINK IT WAS
A LITTLE OFFENSIVE REPEAT THE
INTERVIEW SOME BILLS WITHOUT
GOING THROUGH THE SAME PROCESS
THE QUOTE. THAT OUR SYSTEM THE
EIGHT SEIZE THOSE AND THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS ALREADY TO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. SOME
MADONNA. YEAH THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER CAIR HI I TO-
INTEND ON VOTING FOR AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY TODAY- AND- I
ALSO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ. SHE
WAS ABLE TO ME IN MY OFFICE
EVERY TIME WE WANT TO CONVEY A
WHAT WE HER FROM- FROM ORANGE
COUNTY FROM THE DISTRICT. A
GROUP THAT APPROACH I OFFICE
LAST YEAR. IN SEARCH OF HELP A
WITH THE FIVE A WAS THE- A
PHYSICIAN GROUP. AND THE
INSTRUCTORS THE LAST. I'M I'M
HAPPY TO SEE THAT OF BOTH OF
WERE ABLE TO GROUP SUCCESS WITH
MEDICAL DOLLARS OFFICE IN A
REACHING SOME THAT THEY BELIEVE
THAT THEY THEY CAN LIVE WITH
ESPECIALLY LATE IN THE- ON THE
AMOUNT OF PARTICLE THE- EACH
YEAR OF FOUR DIFFERENT
PUBLICATIONS- I KNOW THAT-
EIGHTEEN FIFTY. AM THE NEXT.
WON'T MAKE EVERYBODY HAPPY IT
CERTAINLY WILL MAKE EVERYBODY-
IN THE- TWO GROUPS HAPPY
BECAUSE DIFFERENT PEOPLE JUST
HAVE DIFFERENT. OF BUT BUT
OVERALL- I DO WANT TO THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ FOR A-
LISTENING TO DROP CONCERN AND
I'M SURE THAT IN THE THERE BE
OTHER SIMILAR FIXES TO. OF AB
FIVE. THANK YOU MISTER. THE
MEMBERS. WELL IS THERE A MOTION.
POST A MOTION FOR SUMMARY
CARILLO SECOND ADVICE OVER
RIVAS AND I'LL JUST SAY. I AM
I'M REALLY GRATEFUL TO THE AND
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE UP
FOR WHO. NOT ON THESE ISSUES
WITH OUR COMMITTEE WITH ME AND
TING OF REALLY IS AN- FOR
YEARS. THE OF A TRIAL. I WORK
THAT SHE AND HER STAFF HAVE PUT
IN AT THE INTO SEPTEMBER DEEP
POINT- IF YOU GO. OTHER AT
ACTUALLY PASSED. LAST THIRTY-
SHE'S MORE THAN WILLING TO DO
THAT I MIGHT MY TEAM AND MY
LABOR COMMITTEE STAFF AS BEEN
THE SAME AND- I'LL JUST SAY
THAT YOU KNOW WE HAD OVER TWO
BILLS REFERRED TO LABOR. AT
TOLD US HOW HE GOT AWAY. BUT
I'LL I DON'T THINK PERSONALLY
IT MAKES SENSE BECAUSE IT
SHOULD HAVE TEN FIFTEEN
DIFFERENT BILLS. I'M AND LAST
YEAR AB FIVE ALTHOUGH IT WASN'T
PERFECT AND WE KNEW THAT WE
WERE GONNA HAVE TO HELP ALL BUT
JUST LAY SO MUCH A SUMMER
GONZALEZ- INTRODUCED EARLY THIS
YEAR AND SHE- AT. AND THAT WE
HAVE BEFORE. A I'M- THE LAW
SURE I THINK WHAT PRETTY WELL
IF YOU LOOK AT THE BEGINNING TO
THE END. AND HOW. DROPPED OFF
BECAUSE OF THEIR WORK WITH US A
MEMBER GONZALEZ NOT JUST
BECAUSE- IS INCOME AND THAT.
YOU KNOW NOT. THE ENGAGEMENT IS
CRITICAL AND I WILL SAY THAT WE
HAD NUMEROUS BILLS RELATED AB
FIVE. OTHER DRUG NEED BOTH OF
AGAIN AND DEMOCRATS. NOT HERE-
PARTIALLY SOME OF THEM. JUST
LET'S GET READY FIVE WERE
REALLY WIDE EXEMPTIONS THAT
COVERED WIDE MISS
CLASSIFICATION- BUT I ALSO- BUT
WILL SAY THOSE THAT DID REACH
OUT TO US THAT AND WORK WITH
STAFF WORKING FAMILIES ALL
STAFF INCLUDE ABOUT DEMOCRATS
DID HAVE ALLEN BILLS. THAT RING.
THE SENATE IS ALL IS DOING. I
AM. WE DIDN'T I DID NOT RECEIVE
OF FROM OF. THE LAW RANGE OF
THOSE REPUBLICAN REFERRED I DID
WAS A PHONE CALL OR- YOU KNOW
CONVERSATION ON ANY OF THEM.
INCLUDING FOR FRIENDS OR VOEPEL
WHAT A GREAT ADMIRATION. I'M
SURE IF YOU HAVE SHALL WE WOULD
HAVE WORKED TOM AND HIS SOME OF
HIS ALSO TO WORK WITH THEM TO
LET HIM KNOW WHERE WE ARE AND
HOW WE GOT. WHAT PASSED FOR. A.
B. AND SO OF THE OF THE-
THERE'S A BIG. BETWEEN BUT I'LL
IN THE PUBLIC REALM AND THE
PROCESS OF MAKING LAWS. AND
MOST CONSTRUCTIVELY AND I THINK
IT'S ALREADY OF DEEP JUST.
REFERRED TO THE FACT NUMEROUS
TOP. BECAUSE YOU CAN SEE IS THE
INSECT. AND DOZENS RAGE BECAUSE
IS ALWAYS AND SUMMER DEEP SAT
DOWN WORK THROUGH THEM. AND SO
I MENTION THAT BECAUSE IT'S NOT
YOU KNOW IT'S NOT DIFFICULT AND
IT IS A BILL. OKAY BILL
ACTUALLY. DESTRUCTIVE DONE. I'M
A IS ALSO DONE TEN FOLD IN
TRYING TO REALLY ADDRESS SO
MANY THEIR CONCERNS BUT BASS
DOES THAT AND I CAN ATTEST
BECAUSE CHECK IN WITH MY- OUR
LABOR CAN. HAVE FOLKS WE SHOT
HIS BILL WHEN YOU WILL ARE THEY
ARE THEY BE OUT TO SOME ORGAN
ALSO JUST TO MAKE SURE. THAT
HER OFFICE IS A GROUP SO THAT
EIGHTEEN FIFTY IN THE
SUBSEQUENT BILL WILL BE HEARING.
HOPEFULLY MOVE FORWARD. THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE SURE THAT
ALL FEEDBACK CONSIDERED ALL
CONVERSATIONS THAT DOESN'T MEAN
THAT EVERYONE'S GOING TO BE
HAPPY IF YOU BUT NO ONE. HEARD
AND I CERTAIN OF THAT. AND SO
BUT THAT I DO WANT TO THANK OF
THE AUTHOR AND ASK THE OTHER
HASN'T CALLED CLOSING COMMENTS.
NO I WOULDN'T THINK ILL AND I
WOULD THINK. WHO I KNOW HAVE
WORKED- PROBABLY NEXT TO MY
STAFF HAD. AND TOLD OUR UNLESS
I'M WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO
WORK ON IT AND I WON ENCOURAGE
ANYONE WHO HAS A SPECIFIC ISSUE
TO REACH OUT TO ME I MEAN YOU
BROUGHT UP PHOTOGRAPHERS NO
MUSICIAN. IN THIS. BUT EVEN
BEFORE IT HI PAT. WHEN I WORKED
HARD ON THE NIELSEN ON A SHOW
IT AND THAT WAS. SO IT'S STILL
A WORK IN PROGRESS YOU KNOW AND
SO I DO APPRECIATE WHEN PEOPLE
READ BUT EITHER BIRDS OR-
INTEREST GROUPS OR VISUAL
CONSTITUENTS- YOU KNOW. I THINK
THERE ARE WHO HAD A VERY. BILL
ABOUT LIFESTYLE JUDGING WHAT WE
HAD HAD PEOPLE REACH OUT ABOUT
YOUR BADGES SO WE'RE LIKE WE
COMBINE THE- WHO ARE. THEY
SHOULD THE ACTING NO WE'RE NOT
IT'S NOT GET OUT ANY A TIME JOB
AND THAT'S HOW WE MET WITH YOU
KNOW JUDGING AND IN THIS SO WE
ARE TRYING TO WORK IN AND MAKE
SURE THAT IF THESE THINGS MAKES
SENSE OKAY NEED AN EXCEPTIONAL.
MEETINGS HE READ. WHICH HE
PEOPLE READ OUT BECAUSE THEY'RE
LAW IN THEY ARE WHY FOR
SOMEBODY THE GORGEOUS FEEL
BETTER IF THEY GET AN EXEMPTION
AND IF YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT GOING
TO DO THAT SO I ENCOURAGE
PEOPLE TO READ THROUGH BILL
FIRST LOOK AT THE CEILING DID
NOT OUT A LOT- I'M A CONTRACTOR
THERE IS NOTHING SAYS IF I.
RHETORIC AROUND THE BILL ON
BOTH SIDES THAT WE HAVE TO TAKE
A STEP BACK IN LIKE READ
THROUGH IT AND SAY WHAT IT WHAT
IS REALITY AND WHAT. IN HERE. I
HURT ME WONDERING. RESPECT ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE ON THE BILL
THANK YOU SUMMER DOES FUNERAL
HOME WAS. AN EMOTIONAL DO
PASSED TO PROBE. TO PASS
APPROPRIATE I KALRA HI CALL HI
FLORA FLORA I CARILLO. CORREO I
DEEP BY DEEP I GONZALEZ. I AND
FIGHT TO SAWYER ON SAWYER HI
RIVAS RIVAS I. THANK YOU THAT
PASADENA OF TO APPROPRIATE NOW
LET'S MOVE ON TO A TWENTY TWO
FIFTY SEVEN FROM A SUMMER THIS
THING YOU AND ALL NOTE THESE
BILL EVERYTHING THAT'S IN AB
TWENTY SEVEN A ALSO IN A FIFTH
AND JUST SO PEOPLE UNDER WHY WE
QUITE AND THAT'S WE WILL GET
THE NECK. WORK ON SOME OF THESE
HEART QUESTIONS. THE THINGS
THAT A DONE IT'S GOOD VERY
CLOSE TO THE SO THAT WE CAN
HOPE FOR GET IN GET PASSED BY
TWO THIRDS AND GET IT IN
IMMEDIATELY THAT WILL. A. THEY
CAN FILL THEIR- THEIR SITUATION
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE THE
MUSICIANS TO WORK SO HARD YOU
KNOW IF THINGS OPEN UP RIGHT
NOW THEY CAN'T PERFORM ANYWAY
BUT YOU KNOW WE TENDED FOR A-
TO BE NOT AN MEMBERS EMPLOYEE
IF THERE ARE YOU KNOW IF.
YOU'RE JUST. PLANO THE WEEK.
HERE IN THEIR UNIT WE ARE
WORKING THROUGH THESE SO.
EVERYTHING THAT WAS IN EIGHTEEN
FIFTY IS IN. EVERYTHING IN
TWENTY FIFTY SEVEN WITH IT
NATURE THERE MIGHT BE SOME
SPECIFIC THINGS FOR STILL
WORKING WITH- FIT FOR WHO WILL
PROBABLY HEAR FROM. UNLESS I'M
THE PHOTOGRAPHERS AND- TO GET
OUT WHAT AND SO EASY YOU WERE
ASKED TO PUT. PRETTY THE
LANGUAGE ABOUT A CONTRACT.
AFTER OKAY DIFFERENT GROUPS
HAVE DIFFERENT FEELINGS ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT- BECAUSE IT
WITHOUT IT BEING IN THERE THEY
STILL MEET THEIR INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY RIGHTS AND I THINK IF
WE TALK ABOUT HELP THE BILL
THAT A OKAY TRYING RIGHT NOW
WE'RE TAKING OUT WORD ANSWER.
ON HAS TO BE IN BUT THAT
ADVANCES. PICK ANY IS COULD
SELL THEIR WORK. WE HOPE THAT
WE'LL BE ABLE TO MOVE THIS
QUICKLY AND I HOPE THAT ALL
THOSE WONDERFUL PEOPLE THAT
CALLED IN AND WE WILL ASSUME
YOU'RE BRINGING A STILL IMAGE.
WE THINK HIS I KNOW CALL. I
LOVE YOU BUT WE DON'T NEED TO
HEAR AGAINST AT AM. THAT THANK
YOU SIR RIGGAN'S DO YOU HAVE.
IS SUPPORT AGAIN EACH MEMBER
WILL HAVE UP TO TWO MINUTES SO
PLEASE TRY YOUR BEST TO MAKE
SURE YOU STAY IN THAT TIMELINES
ARE NOT TO CUT YOU OFF FOR
THOSE PLANS PLUS WE DO. HELLO
PLEASE CORRECT MY PLAN SEE OF
GETTY IMAGE BY FOR AND AFTER
THAT BROMLEY A THE MUSIC OUR TO
COALITION. MORNING NUMBER I'M
HEALTHY HELLO SENIOR VICE
PRESIDENT AND GENERAL COUNSEL
GETTY IMAGES. APPLE GETTY
IMAGES AND SHUTTERSTOCK CLEAR
TESTIFYING TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY SEVEN.
SHUTTERSTOCK OUR GLOBAL LEADER
IN VISUAL CONTENT USING
TECHNOLOGY TO CONNECT MEDIA
OUTLET ADVERTISING AGENCIES AND
BUSINESSES WITH THE LATEST
GLOBAL NEWS SPORTS
ENTERTAINMENT. AS WELL OKAY SO
CREATE CONTENT. WE REPRESENT
THE WORK OF. VIDEO AT AND LIKE
YOU THEY'RE CAUGHT YOUR WORK
AND USERS ARE THE WORLD. WE
WOULD LIKE THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CAN BALLOT STAFF AND
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS ON THE WORK.
AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY SEVEN AS IT
PERTAINS TO DIGITAL CONTENT
AGGREGATORS. AB TWENTY TWO
FIFTY SEVEN IS AN IMPORTANT
STEP FORWARD AND PROTECTING THE
RIGHTS OF INDEPENDENT
PHOTOGRAPHERS VIDEOGRAPHERS AND
EDITORS FOR TWO REASONS. FIRST
IT RECTIFIED THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCE OF EIGHTY FIVE THAT
BEING AN AUTOMATIC SHIFT
COPYRIGHT OWNERSHIP ON THE
CREATE. AND SECOND AB FIFTY.
RECOGNIZED AS THAT WORKERS TO
PROVIDE THEIR DIGIT CONTENT TO
CONTACT EXHIBITORS SUCH AS
GETTY IMAGES A SHUTTERSTOCK.
FOR THE PURPOSE OF PUBLIC THAT
CONTENT AND USER ARE SUBJECT TO
THE BALLOT. THE CLARITY BROUGHT
BY TWENTY TWO FIFTY WILL
FREELANCE BUT- VIDEOGRAPHERS AN
EDITOR TO PROTECT THEIR
COPYRIGHT. AND TO BRING THE
NEWS FOURTH NAKED PAYMENT
COVERAGE OF CALIFORNIA THEN.
WELL AS THEIR CREATIVE CONTENT
TO A GLOBAL AUDIENCE YOUR
DIGITAL CONTENT AGGREGATORS.
THANK THANK YOU. UP NEXT JORDAN
BROMLEY OF THE MUSIC ARTISTS
COALITION BY PHONE. CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES. RIGHT GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JORDAN
BROMLEY I AM AN ATTORNEY LOS
ANGELES THAT MEN AT WELL. RIGHT
OFF A BOARD MEMBER OF THE MUSIC
ARTISTS BUT SHOULD. MY COMMENT
TODAY A REP ARE REPRESENTATIVE.
PUT UP THE WRECKED REFLECTING
THE LARGER COALITION THE WORK
ON THE LEGISLATION AND THAT ARE
REPRESENTED ON OUR JOINT
SUPPORT LETTER. INCLUDING THE
AFM. THE RECORDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA. ECONOMY
I ATTY INDEPENDENT MUSIC
PROFESSIONALS UNITED THANK
AFTER CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION AMERICAN ASSOCIATION
OF INDEPENDENT MUSIC SONGWRITER
NORTH AMERICA NATIONAL MUSIC
PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION THE
TARGET THE COMPOSERS AND WHERE
THAT. THE ALLIANCE FOR WOMEN
FILL COMPOSERS. LIKE TO START
WITH THE ALL GONZALEZ WITH THEM
MEMBER INCOME. MANY AND MANY OF
HELPING US OVER THE PLACE WE
ARE TODAY AND OF THE BUDGET. I
AGREE. BETWEEN LABOR
REPRESENTATIVE. IN MANY
DIFFERENT PART THE LEVELS OF
MUSIC INDUSTRY. YOU'RE GONNA
TAKE THE FINAL OR LETTER OF
SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY
STEP STRAIGHT THE BRAT OF THE
INVOLVED IN REACHING THE FEEL.
THE AGREEMENT REACHED
LEGISLATION RECOGNIZES THE
INDEPENDENT NATURE OF VARIETY
OF THE RELATIONSHIP THAT
EXISTS. IN BRINGING GREAT
MUSICAL LIFE. IT RECOGNIZES THE
IMPORTANCE OF LABOR AGREEMENT.
BOTH CURRENT AND FUTURE
INAPPROPRIATE PART THE MYSTERY
ALSO PRESERVING THE
INDEPENDENCE THE CREATIVITY
THAT THIRTY TO BRING GREAT
MUSIC ARE FOR LIFE. AND ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU IF THE BILL
LANGUAGE AND MOST OF ALL- YOUR
AYE VOTE MOST IMPORTANT MEASURE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU. BUT IS
THERE ANYONE IS. A IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY FIFTY SEVEN. IF
NOT IF WE CAN SEE THERE'S A ONE
ON THE PHONE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY TWO FIFTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU IF YOU'D LIKE TO SHARE YOUR
POSITION IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL IN A PRESS ONE THEN. WELL
TO LINE ONE SIXTY TWO ONE SIX
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO YES
YES NINE ONE SIX TO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I'M SORRY ONE SIXTY
TWO WOULD YOU LIKE TO SHARE
YOUR POSITION. HELLO CAN IN
THAT AREA YES. GO AHEAD. OKAY
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS. FIVE MILLION
AS HIGH ROOM I'M A MEMBER WITH
DRIVERS UNITED DOT FOR I MEAN
IS THERE AND LET THE DRIVER
FROM LOS ANGELES AND I SUPPORT
EIGHTY FIVE AND AS A BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. FIND SIX
SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THIS IS CARL LUNDEN-
REPRESENTING THE RECORDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA
THE TRADE ORGANIZATION THAT
SUPPORTS AND PROMOTES. THE TOP
OF THE MAJOR MUSIC COMPANIES
INCREASES NEARLY 85% OF ALL THE
TO RECORDED MUSIC. THE UNITED
STATES I JUST WANT TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS PROBLEM SUPPORT THE
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE ONE NINETY FIVE ONE
NINE FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MICHAEL LIVING WITH THE
RECORDING ACADEMY. OF OUR OUR
CHAPTERS AND CHAPTERS GOING OFF
ANGEL IF WE SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. NINE FOUR SIX FIVE
FOUR SIXTY FIVE REMAIN STATE
YOUR POSITION. HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES. OKAY MY NAME IS
KAREN GERRITY I'M WITH
INDEPENDENT MUSIC PROFESSIONAL
UNITED AND WE FULLY SUPPORT AB
TWENTY TWO FIFTY SEVEN THANK
YOU THANK YOU. LINE TWO SEVEN
FOUR SIX SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS. THE
PROFESSIONAL I DID I'M OPEN
INDEPENDENT MUSICIAN AND
SONGWRITER AND COMPOSER AND WE
FULLY SUPPORT TWO TWO FIVE
SEVEN. THANK YOU. DO YOU LINE
FOR SIXTY EIGHT FOUR SIX EIGHT
YOUR LINE OF THE- IS ACTUALLY-
WHEN I AM PRESIDENT OF THE
SOCIETY COMPOSED LITTLE SINCE
WE CHAPTERS IN LOS ANGELES AND
NEW YORK. AT WE REPRESENT. IN
YOUR MEDIA COMPOSERS AND
SONGWRITERS SUCH AND WE FULLY
SUPPORT TWENTY TWO FIFTY SEVEN
THANK YOU. NINE NINE ONE NINETY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
DENNIS I'M A LONG TIME
FREELANCE WRITER AND CO LEADER
OF CALIFORNIA FREELANCE WRITERS
UNITED AND OUR OFFICIAL
POSITION IS IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO TWO FIVE. FOR HEARING US
AND WORKING WITH US. CHANGES
THANK YOU. NINE FOUR SIX SIX
FOUR SIX TWO SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. IT CAN'T BE GONE. THE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MEMBERS OF
THE ENTERTAINMENT UNION
COALITION ALSO THE CALIFORNIA
ACT THE COUNCIL IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK. ONE ONE FOUR
SEVEN ONE FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. FIND ONE FORTY SEVEN
YOU MAY BE ON MUTE. HI MY NAME
IS JENNIFER WALTON I'M SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF THE FIVE MILLION
NON UNION FREELANCERS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA I AM IN
FAVOR OF TWO TO FIVE. OUT THANK
YOU TO FIVE SEVEN. AND I AM
HOPING THAT THAT BOTH THINK
THAT. THANK YOU. ONE ONE
HUNDRED ONE ZERO ZERO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YEAH HI MY NAME IS
ADRIENNE DUNNE CAN I'M AN
INDEPENDENT FORM OF SINGER
SONGWRITER COMPOSER AND ALSO A
MEMBER IN THE- OPTIONAL UNITED.
NINE FAVOR OF TWO TWO FAX SEVEN
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NINE FOUR
THREE FIVE FOUR THIRTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
JOHN ACROSS THE PRESIDENT OF
THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
MUSICIANS. EXECUTIVE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF MUSICIANS UNITED
STATES AND CANADA REPRESENTING
SEVENTY THOUSAND PERFECT UNION
SINCE THE END. STATE AND
THROUGHOUT COUNTRY AND FULL
SUPPORT OF TWENTY TWO FIVE
SEVEN THANK YOU THANK YOU. NINE
THIRTY FOUR THREE FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME AT
THAT BE BY PRESIDENT OF TEAMS.
GAME THIRD BLOCK THREE NINETY
NINE THE ENTERTAINMENT DIVISION
AND THE PART OF AB TWENTY TWO
FIFTY SEVEN. THANK YOU. LINE
FOR SEVENTY ONE FOUR SEVEN ONE
PLEASE GIVE A HEN. AND NON
TRANSPARENT AUTHOR. FOUR SEVEN
ONE COULD YOU REPEAT YOUR NAME
AND AFFILIATION. BOTTOM LINE.
FOR SIX NINE FOUR SIXTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. A GOOD
AFTERNOON KATHLEEN DO PROUD OF
CALIFORNIA FREELANCE WRITER CAN
UNITED A FREELANCE JOURNALIST
FOR THIRTY FIVE YEARS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NINE FIFTY
TWO FIVE TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'M SORRY NINE FIFTY TWO YOU
MAY BE ON MUTE. MOVE ON THE
LINE THREE NINETY SIX THREE
NINE SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
SORRY LINE THREE NINETY SIX ARE
YOU THERE. LITTLE LINE TWELVE
NINE ONE TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
A CALLER ON LINE TWELVE IS YOUR
DEVICE ON ME. LINE ONE EIGHT
ONE NINE EIGHT. ARE YOU ON THE
LINE. YES CHAIN DESPERATE ON
BEHALF ASIDE AFTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NINE SEVEN. ONE
MOMENT NINE SEVEN NINE SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAN YOU HEAR
ME YEAH I YES HI MY NAME IS
MADELINE TRIOS I MISS CERTIFIED
INTERPRETER AND TRANSLATOR AND
I NOTICED- TWO THINGS ONE IS
THAT- IN CERTIFIED CHANCES ARE
INCLUDED IN EIGHTEEN FIFTY BUT
NOT IN TWENTY TWO FIFTY SEVEN
WHICH I DON'T UNDERSTAND AND
ALSO THE NUMBER OF- IT WAS
MENTIONED THAT THE TA IS ONLY
THIRTY FIVE SPANISH TRANSLATORS
AND THAT'S NOT A CORRECT BE
CERTIFIED IN ENGLISH FROM
CHENEY SHOULDN'T JUDGE FRENCH
GERMAN IT'S HAPPENING POLLUTION.
TO GET. FINNISH FRENCH GERMAN
HUNGARIAN ITALIAN JAPANESE
POLISH PORTUGUESE RUSSIAN
SPANISH SWEDISH AND UKRAINIAN.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CAN
INFORMATION I GET. AND ONE
FORTY TWO ONE FOUR TWO PLEASE
GO HAND. YEAH IT STARTED TO THE
LEAST OF BILLIONS I AM NOT WE
LAND BY LATER. AND I'M ALSO A
MEMBER OF THE INDEPENDENT MUSIC
PROFESSIONAL THE UNITED POLISH
THAT I'M IN FULL SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NINE ONE FOUR
SIX ONE FOUR SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ASSEMBLYMEMBER MY NAME
IS MARTHA BROWN AND THE FOUNDER
OF CALIFORNIA FREELANCE WRITER
UNITED I AM A CO LEADER AS
WELL- WE FULLY SUPPORT AT
TWENTY TWO FIFTY SEVEN AND BY
TAPPING IT URGENTLY THE STATE
LEGISLATURE CAN SUPPORT ONE OF.
OUR MOST PAPERS CREATIVE AND
TALENTED COMMUNITIES AND MAKING
THEIR INVALUABLE STORAGE HEARD
LOCALLY AND ACROSS THE NATION
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU. LINE
FOR FIFTY EIGHT FOUR FIVE EIGHT
YOU MAY STATE YOUR POSITION.
HELLO MY NAME IS BUT NOT ALL
BOYS I AM AN INDEPENDENT- GAS
NOW BEAR. AND USED GOOD GATOR
I'M COMPOSER AND ALI IN SUPPORT
OF- TWO TWO FIVE SEVEN THANK
YOU. LINE ONE FORTY NINE ONE
FOUR NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE FORTY NINE ARE YOU THERE.
WILL MOVE ON THE LINE FOR SIXTY
FOUR SIX ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MICHAEL YOUNG CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NINE THREE NINETY
SIX THREE NINE SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE MOMENT PLEASE
DIFFICULT IN OUR SIDE HERE.
FINE. FOUR SIX FOUR SEVENTY SIX
FOUR SEVENTY SIX YES I'M IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTEEN FIFTY WITH
AN AMENDMENT I AM AN ACTRESS
AND I WORK IN SMALL THEATERS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NO FURTHER
CALLER THANK YOU THANK YOU-
THANK EVERYONE FOR COMMENTING
SUPPORT AND NOW WE CAN MOVE ON
TO OPPOSITION WE HAVE- ME MAKE
YA STRIKER THE NATIONAL PRESS
PHOTOGRAPHERS ASSOCIATION BY
PHONE AND WILL BE REASON
AMERICA CITED A JOURNALIST BY
PHONE EACH WILL HAVE TWO
MINUTES THINKING OF STARTING
WITH MR. LAST RECORD. GOOD
AFTERNOON AGAIN MY NAME IS RICK
BAKER AND THE GENERAL COUNSEL
FOR THE NATIONAL PRESS
PHOTOGRAPHERS ASSOCIATION. THAT
BIT OF VISUAL JOURNALISTS AND
PRINT AND BROADCAST OVER FORTY
YEARS. WE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY
REGARDING OUR OPPOSITION TO
TWENTY TWO FIFTY SEVEN UNLESS
AMENDED. AS ASSEMBLY WOMAN
GONZALEZ NOTED ON OUR LAWSUIT
WAS DISMISSED BUT HAS BEEN
APPEALED TO THE NINTH CIRCUIT
BUT WE ARE HOPEFUL THAT TWENTY
TWO FIFTY SEVEN CAN HELP US
REACH. EXPEDITED RESOLUTION OF
THE OUTSTANDING ISSUES. SO THAT
THE THOUSANDS OF LIVES
JOURNALISTS CAN BENEFIT FROM
ASSIGNMENT OPPORTUNITIES AND
THEN. THEY HAVE BEEN MISSING.
SO MANY MEDIA ORGANIZATIONS
SEEKING VOID BEYOND NATURE. AB
OKAY INSTEAD. IN THE INTEREST
OF TIME WE STAND BY OUR THE
MONIQUE AND SUBMITTED RIGHT TO
AND LOW FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU TO THE OUT ISSUES THANK YOU
THANK YOU. MR TOBY. THANK YOU
AGAIN MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE ARE YOU A CALL OF
PRESIDENT OF THE AMERICAN
SOCIETY OF JOURNALISTS AND
AUTHORS AND WHICH REPRESENTS
FREELANCE- NON FICTION WRITERS
AND AGAIN IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME I WOULD RESPECTIVELY
RESPECTFULLY REFER THE
COMMITTEE TO MY TESTIMONY INTO
OUR WRITTEN COMMENTS THAT WERE
SUBMITTED EARLIER I WOULD HAVE
LIKED IT JOHN ON ONE ISSUE NOT
ADDRESS YOUR- TESTIMONY. THE
BOTH OF BILLS IN. SECTION DRESS
THE TIGER AND IN THE SEPARATION
DOES NOT RECOGNIZE THE WRITERS
OFTEN ALSO YEAH SHE VIDEO
DURING AN ASSIGNMENT ESPECIALLY
THESE DAYS AND THE DOG RECORDS
ALSO MAKE THEIR STORY USING
BOTH IMAGES AND WORDS. AS
WRITTEN THE PROVISIONS OF THE
PROPOSED SECTION CRYPTOGRAPHERS
ALSO WOULD PROHIBIT A FREELANCE
WRITER COMPUTING VIDEO TO
ACCOMPANY A RIBBON STILL. FOR
NATIONAL PRESS PHOTOGRAPHERS
ASSOCIATION SUGGESTS FOR
REVISION OF THE OVERTHROW DEATH
AND OF MOTION. TO DELETE
REFERENCES TO TERMS THAT
REPRESENT IMPORTANT OUTLETS FOR
THEIR MEMBERS AND QUIRK
FREELANCE WRITERS THANK YOU AND
I'LL BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK THANK YOU SO
MUCH. NOW IT WILL MOVE ON TO
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM IS THERE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION IN THE
ROOM FOR AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY
SEVEN. I DO NOT. ONE OF NEXT TO
OUR MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE. YOUR
POSITION IS IN OPPOSITION WILL
PRESS ONE BUTTON THEY'RE ALL
OVER FIRST ONLINE OF LINE
TWELVE ON TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
LINE TWELVE IS YOUR PHONE ON
MUTE. WILL MOVE BONTA LINE FOR
EIGHTY FOUR EIGHT ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
CRISTIAN A RELEASE I IN MY
DEPEND IF MUSICIAN AND MUSIC
EDUCATOR AND I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT. OF AB. TWENTY TWO
FIFTY SEVEN THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NINE ONE SIX SIX ONE SIX SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE. CALLER
LINE ONE SIXTY SIX IS YOUR
TELEPHONE ON MUTE. MOVE THE
LINE ONE FORTY NINE ONE FOUR
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NOT TO
PARK. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IN MY
ONE FOUR NINE. YES OKAY I WOULD
HAVE GIVEN A NUMBER MY NAME IS
ABOUT INVESTMENT I'M AT FORT
WATER AND FREELANCE CONSULTANT
WRITER AND CARTOONIST REMAINS
THE CALIFORNIA I WOULD LIKE TO
TRY TO CALL IN FOR SUPPORT
SUPPORT TWO TWO FIVE SEVEN OF
AN IMPROVEMENT OVER NOTHING AT
ALL WE ARE FORTUNATE. LANGUAGE
AROUND THE PLACE EMPLOY IS TO
VAGUE OF CHARACTER CLIENT.
CALIFORNIA AMENDED EIGHTY FIVE
FOR STOCK REALISTIC MOST OF.
LINE FOR THIRTEEN THREE A LOT
OF THE- YES HELLO YES BUT IT IS
A TWENTY HANNAH. IN I REMEMBER-
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
AND A DEAF PERSON CALLING
TRANSCEND LANGUAGE INTERPRETER
AND I WANT TO LET YOU GUYS KNOW
THAT I AM OPPOSING. EIGHTY
EIGHTEEN FIFTY AB. TWO TWO FIVE
SEVEN. LESS AND AMEND. IT MADE
TO EXEMPT. SIGN LANGUAGE
INTERPRETERS. AND A REAL TIME
CAPTIONING. FROM THE BATTLE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE FORTY
TWO FOUR EIGHT TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. RILEY STRONG OPPOSITION
THE AUTHOR IS NOT WORKING WITH
NON UNION EIGHT. PEOPLE IT GOT
THEM NOW AND THEN RELATED AND
SHE HAS ONLY WORKED WITH
MUSICIANS AND WRITERS AND IS
NOT OPEN TO WORKING WITH. OUR
OTHER PEOPLE. THANK YOU. IF
THERE IS ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION TO IMPRESS ONE
BUTTONS ARE ALL. THE HELP ON
ADDITIONAL LINE ONE MOMENT.
ORDER ONLINE FOUR EIGHT THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD FOR EIGHTY
THREE. YES THIS IS PETER CLEARS
FROM SAN DIEGO CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG OPPOSITION THE AUTHOR OF
THE BILL IS UNWILLING TO WORK
WITH HER CONSTITUENTS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. FURTHER LINED
IN Q. AT THIS TIME THANK YOU.
OKAY SO LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ON AB TWENTY TWO
FIFTY SEVEN ANY COMMENTS
QUESTIONS OR MOTIONS. OKAY SO
WE HAVE A MOTION WAS AMERICA
REAL SECOND FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER
VEGGIE JONES SAWYER. ANY OTHER
COMMENT QUESTION AND I'LL JUST
SAY THAT YOU KNOW THE IT IS
SOMEWHAT UNUSUAL TO HAVE TWO
BILLS ARE VERY SIMILAR TO EACH
OTHER HEARD BUT AS OF THE
AUTHOR CORRECTLY POINTED OUT.
OF THIS IS ACTUALLY THE BENEFIT
OF THOSE ARE BEING INCLUDED IN
THE BILL BY HAVING A VEHICLE
THAT CAN MOVE MORE URGENTLY
WELL SOME OF THE WORLD HAS BEEN
ALLUDED TO. DURING THE PRE
HEARING. CONTINUE TO. DOUBT
SLOWLY DOWN THE BILL FOR US GET
EXEMPTS IN THAT ARE
APPROPRIATE. FOR THOSE
INDUSTRIES THAT THE AUTHORS AND
WORKING WITH VERY CLOSELY. AND
SAW SOME OF HIS OFFICE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. YEAH I
RESPECTFULLY AND I'VE AND I
JUST WANT TO POINT OUT TO THE
COLORS- I TAKE MEETINGS FROM
ANYONE WHO CALL AND I'VE TRIED
TO TAKE INDIVIDUAL MEETINGS
FROM ANYONE WHO'S SO. PLEASE
CALL MY OFFICE- WE WILL MEET
WE'LL TALK ABOUT IT I MAY NOT
BE ABLE SOLVE EVERY PROBLEM BUT
WE ARE TRYING HARD TO GET THIS
RIGHT. RESPECT LAST NIGHT AT.
THANK YOU- WE CAN HAVE A ROLE
ON THE VOTE PLEASE. CHIEF
CONSULTANT LET. IT IS THE- TO A
PER PATIENTS KALRA. I KALRA AYE.
FLORA I CARILLO. LEO I. DEEP BY
DEEP AIKENS HI CONSOLES I JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER I RIVAS
RIVAS I. RIGHT THANK YOU AND
THAT DOES THAT PASSES
UNANIMOUSLY UNANIMOUSLY ABLE TO
PASS TO APPROACH IS THE MOTION
AND SO LET'S MOVE ON- TO AB.
THIRTY FIFTY SIX ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GONZALES. I KNOW I'M. AB THIRTY
FIFTY SIX WOULD CREATE
WORKPLACE SAFETY IMPAIR PAY
STANDARDS FOR WORKERS WHO
OPERATE UNDER A QUOTA SYSTEM
WHILE WORKING IN WAREHOUSES YES
WE'RE TALKING PRIMARILY ABOUT
AMAZON WAREHOUSE WORKERS IN
MODERN HOUSES COMPANIES THAT
SPECIFIC QUOTAS FOR WORKERS TO
MEET SUCH AS HOW MANY ITEMS PER
HOUR THEY SHOULD PULL IN
PACKAGE FOR MORE THAN THE
MONITOR THE PRODUCT WAS HOW
MUCH TIME OFF TASK OCCURS
INCLUDING THE TIME IT TAKES. TO
USE THE RIGHT. WARNINGS CAN BE
EVEN BEING INVOLVED IN ONE
WAREHOUSE FACILITY IN RIVERSIDE
EMPLOYEES HOW TO WALK FOR SEVEN
MINUTES TO THE NEAREST RESTROOM
LEADING TO ME MANY TO SKIP
BATHROOM BREAKS RATHER THAN
FACE PENALTIES FOR TIME OP TASK
AND SUB POINT A **** I WILL
REMIND MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE FOR WOMEN SOMETIMES
IT'S NOT IMPOSSIBLE IT'S NOT
POSSIBLE TO SWITCH. A BATHROOM
BREAK THESE QUOTAS CAN ALSO
CHANGE OVER TIME FORCING
WORKERS TO ADAPT IN WORK FASTER
TO MEET A HIGHER QUOTA RATHER
THAN WORKING LONGER IN HAVING
TO PAY OVERTIME DURING A CUT
CURRENT PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS
MANY VETS HAVE BECOME EVEN MORE
RELIANT ON WAREHOUSES AS WE
ORDER ITEMS ONLINE TO BE
DELIVERED TO OUR DOOR WHILE THE
CENTRAL WAREHOUSE WORKERS
CONTINUE TO TRY TO MAKE STRICT
AS COVER WORKERS REPORT STERN
IS ALLOTTED FOR FREQUENT HAND
WASHING TO REDUCE POTENTIAL
TRANSMISSION THE CORONA VIRUS
OR TO STAND. EQUIPMENT AND WHAT
STATIONS AND WE'RE BACK TO WORK
LAWPERIODS PEAK CHEFS. SEASON
SUCH AS A HOLIDAY ARE THE
CURRENT PANDA. ACTUAL SENT TO
AM WORKER DURING THE PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS HAVE ASKED THEM
TO WORK MANDATORY EXTRA TIME OR
FACE A SEPARATION OF
EMPLOYMENT. WAREHOUSE WORKERS
ARE SENT ON THE COURSE OF
EVERYDAY LIFE AND EVEN MORE SO
DURING THE CURRENT PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY. HOWEVER THESE
WORKERS ARE SUBJECT TO WORK
STANDARDS AND CONDITIONS WHICH
DO NOT RESPECT THEIR BASIC
HUMAN DIGNITY CLEAN. TASTE
NEEDS- PROPER HYGIENE OR
PROPERLY COMPENSATE THEM FOR
THE BACK BREAKING WORK THAT
THEY ARE PERFORMING. AB THIRTY
FIFTY SIX WOULD ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES FACED BY WAREHOUSE
WORKERS. BY PROHIBITING READ.
TO PROHIBIT REASONABLE AMOUNTS
OF TIME SPENT FOR CERTAIN
ACTIVITIES AS COUNTY TOWARDS
TIME REQUIRED FOR WAREHOUSE
EMPLOYEE TO COMPLETE QUOTA.
THESE INCLUDE ASSESSING IN
USING A RESTROOM HYDRATION OR
HAND WASHING STATION.
DOCUMENTING OR REPORTING A
LABOR CODE VIOLATION. THE
LANGUAGE DOESN'T SAY SO BUT WE
DON'T MEAN GOING TO THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER WE WILL CLARIFY.
OUT DOCUMENTATION. LEGALLY THE
BILL WOULD ALSO THE WORK WEEK
TO PUT AN EX OF AN ESTABLISHED
QUOTA BE COMPENSATED AT ONE AND
A HALF TIMES EMPLOYEES REGULAR
PAY AND ESTABLISH CIVIL
PENALTIES EMPLOYERS WHO VIOLATE
THESE PROVISIONS I WILL POINT
OUT CURRENTLY WE HAVE NO- Y.
DEFINITIONAL QUARTER THE QUOTA
IS SET BY THE EMPLOYER AND WE
ARE CHANGING THIS IT'S JUST
SAYING IF IT IT. BACK TO BEYOND
THE- EIGHT. IN OR- OVER TIME
PAYMENT THEY'RE STILL GONNA TO
PAY OVERTIME PREMIUM PAY- FOR
WORKING. EVEN QUICKER AND-
WITHOUT BREAKS SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY AYE BUT WE'RE
GONNA HAVE A WITNESS AND THEN.
LAST NIGHT BUT- THANK YOU. SO
IT DIDN'T TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
OF WE HAVE BOTH BY PHONE WE
HAVE SHARE OUR CLOTHES SHE HAD
THE WAREHOUSE WORKERS RESOURCE
CENTER BY PHONE. FALL BY ROSE
MERRY- MOLINA OF THE LOS
ANGELES LABOR FEDERATION. A
MISTER KOSCHECK. MANY IT SURE
HER. YES YOUR RECORD WAREHOUSE
RESOURCE CENTER FOR THE PAST
YEAR HE HAS NO ORGANIZING
WORKERS A GOOD ACTOR OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. WHAT THE
BETTER OLYMPIC. WELL TO BE THE
KEY FACTOR IN CAL POINT YOU
CAUGHT WELL LOOK BEFORE. THE
WORKING POOR HEALTH CALIFORNIA
BUT HE THAT THAT SHOW UP
COMPANY BUT THERE ARE THE RIGHT
NOW. CONTINUE TO OPERATE BALK.
WHAT OTHER OF OUR PRODUCTS
HUNDRED BUCKS PER HOUR BUT
THEY'LL BRING. READY TO BUY
THEIR ORDER BUT THE QUOTA EVEN
IF YOU'RE NOT GRANT THEM OR TO
A BENCH AND- THERE'S ALWAYS
HELP HER IMPACT COULD
REPETITIVE CRAP. MENTAL DOT
TRACK THAT LEAD TO PERSONAL. IT
IMPACT KOBE ON THE WORK ORDER
UNDER COURT ABOUT REPORT DR
BILLION FOLKS AND HOMEWORK WE-
WHAT ABOUT THE DROUGHT BUT WHAT
WE ARE DONE CONDITIONALLY. HI
SOMETIMES THE POOR OF A 100%
PER YEAR BUT. THREE THREE THREE
THREE ON AMAZON COM ONE WHAT.
IN RECENT YEARS FOR ABOUT THE
FOR. IF WITHIN. A TALKING WITH
RESPECT TO AT WORK AND WHAT. WE
CAMERON BY TRACKING
SURVEILLANCE WELL IN GROUP OF
MANAGEMENT OF WORK OUTPUT. IT
PUT PRESSURE ON THE DEPARTMENT
ALREADYBUT IF. WE CANNOT KEEP
WITH THE RECORD THOUGHT THAT
WORK DROP YOUR- IT IS HELLO BUT
THE HARDSHIP IT COULD CAN'T
BERTHA PACKED FULL. IT WAS ON
ONE OF THE PLAYER BUT NOT THE
ONLY ONE. OUT OF FOUR EIGHTY
TWO THOUSAND WORKERS WERE HOW
CALIFORNIA COURT ONE OF TWENTY
NINE NOT ALL OF THE WORK ORDER
BUT- WITH THE QUARTER THOUGH
YOUR HONOR TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
FOLKS. IN THE STATE CLOTHING-
AROUND THIRTY THOUSAND AM ABOUT
QUARTER TO WOULD BE AFFECTED BY
THAT THE- MAYBE THIRTY. CORRECT
WHAT WHAT WHAT. WORKERS WILL BE
TO. DO A BASIC IDEA TO TAKE A
CRACK. AT WORK WAS ABOUT THE
DOG. THANK THANK YOU THANK YOU.
A NICE ROSE MERRY MOLINA. THANK
YOU CHEN COMMITTEE CAN YOU HEAR
ME CLEARLY YES. THANK YOU MY
NAME IS ROSE MARIE MOLINA AND
I'M THE ORGANIZING DIRECTOR OF
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
FEDERATION OF LABOR I'LL BE
SERVING AS A PRIMARY WITNESS IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY FIFTY SIX.
THE POLICY PROVIDES SOLUTIONS
TO WORKLOAD AND BREAK ISSUE THE
WAREHOUSING AND DISTRIBUTION
INDUSTRY IS EXPANDING TO ME
CONSUMER DEMAND FOR INCREASED
ARRAY OF PRODUCTS JORDAN RIGHT
TIME BUT MEETING THE DEMAND
COMES AT A SIGNIFICANT COST TO
WHAT. TAKING THE- RECORD. AND
THE ISSUE IS THE EXACT. UNDER
THE PANDEMIC WARM BREAKS ARE
REQUIRE TO MAINTAIN SANITARY
WORKING CONDITIONS. THE PROBLEM
IS THAT THEY TECHNICALLY HAVE
BREAKS UNDER CURRENT LAW. BUT
THEY DON'T HAVE THE LIBERTY TO
TAKE THEM WITHOUT COUNTING
AGAINST A PRODUCTIVITY.
ULTIMATELY AND PENALTIES FOR
WHAT THE- CENTER IN THE USAGE
OF BREAKS. I'D LIKE TO SHARE
THE TESTIMONY OF A WAREHOUSE
WORKER YES AND YEAH BUT AT. IN
HER WORDS. I READ THE WORKING
AN AMAZON WAREHOUSE WITH THAT
BUT IF YOU KNOW COUNTY. THE
WORK WAS VERY INTENSE AND
STRESS. I HAD. TWO HUNDRED
ITEMS PER HOUR. CAMERA WITH.
I'M OFF TRACK HI MY- WHICH
STARTS TO ACCUMULATE AFTER STOP
YOU CAN CRITICS WHEN IT. IF YOU
GET TO YOU GET IN TROUBLE.
TAKING A RESTROOM WITH THE-
SOMETIMES WHEN I HAD YOU THE
RESTROOM I WOULD ASK THE COURT
AGREED MAKE A SCAN. BUT NOT GET
PENALIZED. THEN I HAD TO. RUN
THERE WERE TIMES EVERYTHING
USING THE- AT ALL OF MILLBRAE.
I WAS FIRED I HAD MINUTES
UNEXPLAINED TIME OFF. I FELT.
AND I FELT THAT BOTH THE BALL.
BUT YES SHARES IF THE-
OCCURRENCE. AS ADVOCATE. WE
AGREE THAT SPEED UP THE
NECESSARY AND WORKPLACE
UNFUNDED. IS HIGH. BUT IT MUST
BE SUSTAINABLE AND STATE.
ULTIMATELY THIS BILL PROVIDES
CLARITY TO WORKERS THAT THEY
CAN AND SHOULD TAKE A BREAK
PLEASE THE RESTAURANT TO
RECOVER. AT TO WASH THEIR
HANDS. WITHOUT IT NEGATIVELY
IN. THEIR SEVENTY. AND IF THEY
ARE REQUIRED TO THE FUNDING FOR
ITS WORK. IT WILL BE OFFERED A
PREMIUM FOR THE TRUE. WAY OF
THE- MAKES. FUNCTION BUT A LOT
ALL WE BELIEVE THAT THE FILTER
TO WORKERS IN THE BILL AND THIS.
CONSIDERATION OF THE OF WORKING
PEOPLE I URGE YOU TO YES. THANK
YOU. IS THERE ANYONE ISN'T THAT
WOULD LIKE SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB THIRD FIFTY SO. IF NOT
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY FIFTY SIX.
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT E PRESS
ONE ANOTHER ALL WILL GO TO LINE
FOR SEVENTY SEVEN TO START FOUR
SEVEN SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES. HI MY
NAME IS NOT TOMATO AND I'M
CALLING FROM THE LOS ANGELES
ALLIANCE BRINGING A CONNIE- AND
WE ARE IN COMPLETE SUPPORT OF
AB THIRTY FIFTY SIX AND WE
LEADING RUNNING KIRCHER SUPPORT
ASPHALT. THANK YOU. NINE FOUR
NINE ONE FOUR NINETY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. RESPONSE THE TRIGGER
THE COALITION FOR HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. FIND FOUR
NINE TWO FOUR NINETY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. SHANE GUSMAN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEAMSTERS PUBLIC AFFAIRS
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
LINE FOUR NINE FIVE FOUR NINETY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NAY
BAYARDO WITH THAT YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NINE TWO THREE ONE
TO THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I YES- MY NAME IS MEGAN ARE T.
FROM EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
INSTITUTE OF TAMPA WITHOUT THAT
SO THE CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING
DAY LABOR THE MASTIC WORKERS IN
LOS ANGELES IN FULL SUPPORT OF
AB FIFTY SIX. THANK YOU. LINE
ONE SIX SIX ONE SIXTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
CAPITAL WITH THE PARTNERSHIP
FOR WORKING FAMILIES IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY FIFTY SIX.
THANK YOU. PINE THREE TWENTY
FIVE THREE TWO FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I THREE TWENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WILL MOVE ON TO
LINE FOR EIGHTY SIX FOUR EIGHT
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LETTER
CHEN NUMBERED CAITLYN TAKE UP
FOR THE TRANSPORT WORKERS OF
AMERICA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. POINT TWO OH SEVEN
TWO ZERO SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE CALLER INTO TWO OR SEVEN WE
CAN HEAR YOU PLEASE STATE YOUR
POSITION. LINE ONE EIGHTY TWO
ONE EIGHT TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE EIGHTY TWO WE HEAR YOU
TYPING ARE YOU ABLE TO SHARE
YOUR POSITION ES. THE WEEK OUR
HOME WITH WORKING PARTNERSHIP
USA AND- INSTRUCT COURT. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. ONE ONE THIRTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GRAY
ALL WITH THAT WHEN IT I'M
PULLING FOR. THANK YOU. NINE
TWO OH TWO TWO ZERO TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I AM. TWO FORTY
TWO TWO FOUR TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI HIGH COLLAR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN ARE YOU ABLE TO HEAR US.
THE MOVE ON THE LINE FIVE OH
THREE FIVE ZERO THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN IMAGE TIGER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
ALSO EXPORT. THANK YOU.
WHAT
WILL TAKE A SECOND TRY AT TWO
FORTY TWO TO FOUR TO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YEAH HI THIS IS JIM
SMITH CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. YES
HI- SO I DIDN'T GIVE ME A QUEUE
NUMBER BUT ANYWAYS THIS IS
JAMES SMITH FROM TEAMSTERS
LOCAL THREE NINETY SIX AND WE
ARE IN SUPPORT AS WELL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. LINE FIFTY TWO
FIVE TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
FIND FOR SEVENTY NINE FOUR
SEVEN NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. HIDE
BUT THE A ARE FROM THERE I WORK
WITH THE IF THEY ALLIANCE FOR
SUSTAINABLE ECONOMY IN OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA WERE IN FULL
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. YOU KNOW
FOR THE CALLERS IN Q. AT THIS
TIME. I THINK YOU. ARE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF AB
THIRTY FIFTY SIX WE HAVE HERE
PRESENT WITH US BEEN ENDING
WITH CAL CHAMBER. MORNING OR
COULD NOT. COME UP WITH HELPING
HIM WITH PUBLIC RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED TO AB THIRTY FIFTY SIX
WE'VE HAD SEVERAL GOOD MEETINGS
WITH AUTHORS OFFICE WE
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENT SHE'S
TAKING THE DATE. WE STILL
REMAINING CONCERNS ABOUT. THE
NOTION OF THE GOVERNMENT
MANDATING HOW AN EMPLOYER
SCHEDULES WORK DURING THE WORK
DAY- IN EMPLOYMENT LAW WE
GENERALLY LEAVE THE SCHEDULING
OF THE WORK TO THE EMPLOYER AS
LONG AS THE EMPLOYER APPLIES.
ON THE APPLE WHICH IN OUR LAWS.
WE APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT THE
AUTHOR REMOVED THE- CART THE
STATE. YEAH BUT WE STILL HAVE
WITH. TURN WE ARE HAVE CONCERNS
WITH THE NOTION OF. REGARDING
THE PAYMENT OF A- WIN OVER TIME
HOURS WEREN'T NECESSARILY
WORKED- IN A DISAPPEAR SAYS
THERE'S BEEN LOTS OF TESTIMONY
ABOUT HEALTH AND SAFETY ASPECTS
OF THIS THIS APPEARS TO BE AN
OSHA. RELATED ISSUE AND SO SOME
SOME CONCERN ABOUT BLENDING THE
TWO ISSUES TOGETHER OVER TIME.
WITH RESPECT TO OCEAN ISSUES-
WE'RE ALSO CONCERNED THOUGH THE
AUTHOR MENTIONED- THE LANGUAGE
LEARNING FOR IN OF. WE
WILLINGNESS TO CLARIFY THE-
THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT CLAIMS
ARE FILED AT THE WORK SITE AND
I CREATED A NEW- ENTITLEMENT TO
LEAVE TO GO TO- TO GO TO THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE SO
WE APPRECIATE THAT. WE ARE
CONCERNED WITH THE PENALTIES IN
THE BILL FOR THE FORGET
PENALTIES UP TO A THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER EMPLOYEE PER
VIOLATE. SOME OF THAT. IS AN
CONCERNS WE HAVE WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT THIS OPENS UP.
THAT POTENTIAL YOU KNOW LAYERS
OF LITIGATION AND PENALTIES
UNDER- PAGA AND OTHER AVENUES.%
FOR THESE REASONS WERE
RESPECTFULLY POSE BUT WILL
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND OUR CONCERNS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN
THE ROOM- IN OPPOSITION. TO AB
THIRTY FIFTY SIX. OKAY I DON'T
SEE ANYONE SO WE'LL MOVE ON THE
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION ON TH PHONE. EIGHT
AND AGAIN LATER GERMAN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
THIRTY FIFTY SIX. UP PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE ONE TIME. WE NOW HEAR
FROM A LINE OF FIVE OH SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU. HI
I'M ACTUALLY IN SUPPORT. HERE
CAN PUT THE UCLA LABOR CENTER
MY APOLOGIES FOR NOT HAVING
RECEIVED A NUMBER EARLIER. NO
PROBLEM THANK YOU. WHEN NOW
HEAR FROM THE LINE OF FOUR OH
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS THE KEY SIR GARCIA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA GROCERS ASSOCIATION
READ AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU. I HEAR%
FROM THE LINE OF TWO FOUR ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
AT THE THIRTY YEARS OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE IF THE
PRODUCERS REPRESENTING THE
PROCESSING ACROSS THE STATE IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NOW HERE FROM
LINE FOUR EIGHT FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE NEW NOT SURE MEMBERS
THIS IS IVAN ALL TOMORROW ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION WOULD
LIKE TO ALIGN OUR COMMENTS IN
POSITION WITH THOSE-
REPRESENTED BY THE CAL CHAMBER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NOW HERE
FROM THE LINE OF TWO ELEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS NICOLE RICE
CALLING FROM THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WE TOO ARE ALSO
OPPOSED TO THE BETTER THANK YOU
THANK YOU. WE NOW HEAR FROM A
LINE OF FIVE HUNDRED FIVE ZERO
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE FIVE
HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS READY TO BE BE A
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER AND THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE
VERY MUCH OPPOSED TO THIS IS
HURTING MANY MANY PEOPLE IN OUR
ECONOMY. AND WE'RE VERY OPPOSED
TO IT. THANK YOU. THERE ARE NO
OTHER COMMENTERS IN Q. AT THIS
TIME OKAY THANK YOU AB THIRTY
FIFTY SIX ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM ANYONE ASSUME
READY JONES SAWYER. AND I'M
GLAD THAT YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU'RE
GOING TO WORK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN THE CALIFORNIA GROCERS FOOD
PROCESSORS AND A CALIFORNIA MAN
FISHERIES TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION BECAUSE I THINK
THIS IS A AN IMPORTANT ISSUE
THAT WE NEED TO KIND OF HASH
OUT. THE SAY THAT FROM A FROM A
PERSONAL. WHEN IT WHEN I WAS IN
IN COLLEGE MY MISSPENT YOUTH
WHEN I WAS EIGHTEEN I WAS WHAT
THEY CALLED A SWAMPER. SWAPPERS
SOMEONE THAT TAKES ITEMS OFF A
TRUCK. PUT HIM INTO A WAREHOUSE
THE DIN BE DISTRIBUTED OUT. OF
I LASTED ABOUT SIX MONTHS. IN
THAT WAREHOUSE. THERE WAS.
OBVIOUSLY NO UNION BECAUSE I
DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S A UNION
OF INTERNATIONAL SWAPPERS OUT
THERE- I NEVER KNEW WHEN MY
BRAKES WERE. YOUR PEOPLE GOT
HURTS THERE WERE NO WORKERS
COMP. TO THIS DAY I'VE NEVER
SEEN ANY SO SECURITY TAKEN OUT
I WAS PAID CASH. IT WAS AN
OVERTIME. OVER TIME MEANT IF I
GOT TO READ THREE AND LEFT AT
THREE IN THE MORNING I GOT PAID
THAT SAME TEN DOLLARS AN HOUR
ALL THE WAY THROUGH THERE WAS
THERE WAS NO QUESTION ABOUT
TIME IN HALF IF YOU ASKED ABOUT
IT- YOU YOU WOULD DEFINITELY
GOING WELL. BUT WHAT ULTIMATELY
ENDED MY FROM MY AFFILIATION
WITH THIS GROUP. WAS WITH A
GENTLEMAN NAMED BRUCE WHO IS
OUR SUPERVISOR. WHO CAME UP TO
ME AND RESTED THE WORKERS I
AFTER AMERICAN OR MEXICAN
AMERICAN- SOME. YOU COULD SPEAK
ENGLISH. AND HE CAME UP TO A
GROUP OF US ABOUT TO UNLOAD A
TRUCK. AND HE SAID REGGIE HAVE
YOU EVER GONE CAN SHOOTING. AS
TO NOT YOU KNOW YOU GOTTA GO
CAN SHOOTING MAKE ME WE GO
SHOOT SOME MEXICANS AN AFRICANA.
AND SO. I JUST KIND OF STARED
AT HIM. THE FEW WHO KIND
UNDERSTOOD KIND OF LAUGHED AND
I TOLD HIM IT WAS INAPPROPRIATE
BEING THAT HE SAID. HE LEFT THE
NEXT DAY MY HOURS FOR CUT IN
HALF THE DAY AFTER THAT THEY
WERE CUT TO ZERO THE THIRD DAY
HE GAVE ME MY CHECK TELL ME I
WASN'T ORGAN PLOY THEIR- WHAT
IT'S- ME AS A YOUNG PERSON.
EIGHTEEN WE NEED TO HAVE SOME
GUIDELINES. END UP THOSE PLACES.
WHERE A LOT OF US DON'T WATCH
DON'T KNOW DON'T KNOW WHAT'S
GOING ON- YES THIS THIS MAY GO
TO MAYBE THE BETTER RUN PLACES
BUT THERE SOME WAREHOUSES. THAT
REALLY DO IN A SMALLER BUSINESS
ARE IN THERE ARE HIRING PEOPLE
FROM MY DISTRICT ARE IMMIGRANT
THAT NEED. SOMETHING SPELLED
OUT ABOUT THEIR RIGHTS IN BOTH
ENGLISH AND SPANISH SO THEY
KNOW. WHAT HAPPENED TO ME AT
EIGHTEEN WILL NEVER HAPPEN TO
THEM THE TOP CRUCIATE YOU.
COMING TO TALK ABOUT SOMETHING
THAT NOBODY. FEW PEOPLE EVER
REALLY THINKING ABOUT WHAT'S
GOING ON IN A WAREHOUSE ARENA
AND HOW WE CAN MAKE THOSE JOBS
IT'S NOT ONLY SAFER BUT MAKING
SURE THAT THE WORKPLACE IS A
PLACE YOU CAN YOU CAN BE AND
YOU YOU UNDERSTAND YEAH HAVE
BREAKS. UP OUT OF THE UNITED
DOES THE WHOLE OKAY- BUT AT THE
END OF THE DAY THE PAIN INTO
THE SO SECURITY PAINTED TO THE
WORKERS. AND THERE PAIN INTO ON
A INSURANCE SO THAT SOMETHING
DOES HAPPEN THERE'S- THESE
MECHANISM THAT WE SET UP OUR
ACTUALLY PUT IN PLACE AND SO
WHEN IT COMES TO THE THINK OF
JUST EVEN OVERTIME ON BEING
ABLE. TO GET THAT WITHOUT YOU
HAVING TO FIGHT FOR IT BECAUSE
IT'S SOMETHING THAT'S ALREADY
IN THE LABOR CODE IS ALREADY
THERE- I APPRECIATE YOU MAKING
THE EFFORT REALLY WOULD
APPRECIATE. ALL THE OPPOSITION
TO WORK WITH YOU BECAUSE THIS
IS REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT
THANK YOU THURMOND. YES ON IT I
WANT TO THANK YOU OTHER IS WELL
AS COMMENTS FROM DECEMBER JONES
SAWYER- THAT AND I THINK THIS
ISSUE AND HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION IN A REAL MANNER
IS LONG OVERDUE- AND I KNOW
EVEN BEFORE THIS CRISIS WAS
LONG OVERDUE CRISIS. EXPLODING
SOMETIMES WITH THOSE WHO WE
DEEM IS ESSENTIAL WORKERS ARE
REALLY TREAT A SACRIFICIAL
WORKERS. AND ARE GIVEN THE
PRINT THE PROTECTIONS AND
SUPPORT THEY NEED- WE HAD A
PRODUCTIVE LABOR COMMITTEE INFO
HEARING EARLIER THIS YEAR IN
THE IN THE EMPIRE. GUARDING
WAREHOUSE WORKERS NOT AS GOOD
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE LA LABOR
OFFENSE VERY GRATEFUL TO THE TO
THE AUTHOR. TO BRING THIS BILL
FOR I THINK IT'S ABSOLUTELY
TIMELY. AND IT'S SOMETHING
THAT- YOU TO DO TO PROTECT.
WORKERS THAT ALLOW US TO STAY
AT HOME. AND ALLOW THEM. TO DO
IN THE COMFORT OF HOME THEY ARE
ONLY IS. WE TO PROTECT THESE
WERE TO BASS BROKEN WHICH LIKE
TO CLOSE. YES I WANT TO THANK
YOU AND THANK YOU FOR THOSE
COMMENTS- SOME. IT I. JUST TO
BE SURE SWAPPERS ARE A
SUBDIVISION OF THE
INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD OF
TEAMSTERS FLORA AND THEY HAVE
TO. OFFICIALLY CALL THEM THAT
BUT IT IS TO START WORK. JUST
IN CASE. SEVEN YOU KNOW WHAT
WE'RE HEARING MORE AND MORE
ABOUT WAREHOUSE WORKERS AND
DURING THIS PANDEMIC WE'RE
HEARING ABOUT DEATH OF WORK
WAREHOUSE WORKERS BECAUSE OF
THE CONDITIONS UNDER WHICH
THEY'RE WORKING AT SOME THOSE
CONDITIONS DO NOT GIVE RISE TO
THE BILL EIGHTY TO- PERFORM
BASIC HYGIENIC FUNCTIONS WHEN
YOU ARE BEING CLOCKED- BY. AT
NOT EVEN A PERSON YOU'RE YOU'RE
YOU'RE YOU'RE BEING TIME TO
HEAR YOUR YOU HAVE A QUOTA AND
YOU YOU HAVE TO GO AND GO IN
AND YOU CANNOT EVEN TAKE A TO
USE THE RESTROOM OR WASH HANDS
WITHOUT THAT THIRTEEN YOUR CALL
AND THAT TOO IN LAW INTO THE
FIRE. IS NOT. WE SHOULD BE
TALKING ON THE CENTURY. THIS IS
ALTHOUGH NOW IT'S AN AN AOP OR
A- TECHNOLOGICAL WAY OF
DETERMINING HOW FAST SOMEBODY
GOING IT'S NOT THAT DIFFERENT
THAN THE ASSEMBLY LINE. AND WE
NEED TO ENSURE THAT THESE
WORKERS HAVE SOME BASIC LEVEL
OF PROTECTION. IF YOU HAVE TO
USE THE RESTROOM. IF YOU HAVE
TO WASH OR SHOULD WASH YOUR
HANDS IF YOU HAVE TO DOCUMENT A
LABOR DEFICIENCY MAYBE SOME OF
THESE DEATHS ONE OF OCCURRED.
AND SO I THINK IT'S MORE THAN
EVER TO ENSURE THAT. AS
EMPLOYERS CHANGE THEIR MODELS
AND THESE QUOTAS GETS BAD UP IN
ORDER TO AVOID OVER TIME. THEY
GET SPIT UP AT DIFFERENT TIMES
SO YOU'RE ALREADY GOING VERY
FAST PACE AND THEN YOU'RE
EXPECTED GO EVEN FASTER SO THAT
YOU DON'T REACH THE OVERTIME
MARK. THAT'S JUST UNREASONABLE
A AND YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE
INDIVIDUAL THESE ARE PEOPLE
THESE ARE SOLD THESE AREN'T
ROBOTS- AND SO IT'S TIME TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT WAREHOUSE
WORKERS AND I'M GLAD AT AND
I'VE HEARD INDIVIDUALLY FROM SO
MAYBE YOU HAD. DIFFERENT
EXPERIENCES EITHER FROM YOUR
STAFF FOR FANS OR PEOPLE IN-
I'M GLAD THAT WE'RE GOING TO
WORK ON THIS DROUGHT THIS YEAR
AND TRY TO. GET SOMETHING FOR
THIS NEW ECONOMY IN THIS NEW
REALITY. AND HOPEFULLY
EVENTUALLY GET THOSE WORKERS
PROTECTED SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR MY RENT. IF YOU'RE A MOTION
TO PASS APPROPRIATIONS FOR
SUMMER JONES SAWYER SECONDED BY
SUMMER CARILLO. A CRITICAL ROLE
ON THE VOTE PLEASE. MISSION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS KALRA
FIVE KALRA AYE FLORA. FLORA NO
CARILLO. HI DEEP. GONZALEZ
CONSOLES I JONES SAWYER BY
JONES SAWYER HI RIVAS. RIVAS I
GOT THE DOES PASS ON A FIVE ONE
VOTE- WE DO HAVE WITH US
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ I
KNOW SOME OF HIS OFFICE HAS TO
GO PRESENT ANOTHER COMMITTEES
YOU GO TAKE CARE THAT A AND
WILL MOVE ON. RODRIGUEZ AB
TWENTY TWO I DO KNOW THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I BECAUSE HAS
TWO BILLS AND SO LET'S MOVE AS
QUICKLY AS WE CAN BUT CERTAINLY
HERE ONE BOB WE DO HAVE A ONE
PM BREAKING FOR. WE HAVE TIME
TO HEAR ABOUT YOUR BILLS WHICH
IS OF GOING FEW MINUTES OVER WE
CAN DO THAT BUT LET'S LET'S
START AND SEE WHERE WE ARE ON
AB TWENTY NINETY SORRY VEGAS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS GIVING. ME PERCENT
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT TODAY. I
WANT TO BEGIN BY POINTING OUT
THAT NEARLY 80% OF ALL
EMERGENCY MEDICAL TECHNICIANS
AND PARAMEDICS IN CALIFORNIA
ARE CURRENTLY EMPLOYED. BY THE
PRIVATE SECTOR AND THEY PROVIDE
THE SAME QUALITY OF PATIENT
CARE. AND TRIAGE OTHER PUBLIC
SECTOR COUNTERPARTS. THESE
FIRST RESPONDERS WORKING FILLED
WITH HIGH RATES OF MORTALITY
INJURY ON TRAUMA. UNFORTUNATELY
THESE HOUSES ARE CONSIDERED AN
INHERENT PART OF THE JOB. AS
YOU MAY KNOW I'VE BEEN AN EMT
FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS IN THE
PRIVATE SETTING. ALSO YOU MAY
BE AWARE IN THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS. THERE HAVE BEEN
INCIDENTS OF ACTIVE SHOOTER
SUCH OF THE GILROY GARLIC
FESTIVAL. THE BORDERLINE BORN
GROW. SHOOTING A RETORT COUNTY.
THE SAGAS HIGH SCHOOL SHOOTING
IN SANTA CLARITA. AND ONE NEAR
MY DISTRICT IN THE INLAND
REGIONAL CENTER IN SEMINAR DINO.
SPEAKING FROM MY PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE OF THE CAREER EMPTY.
AND FROM WHAT I HEAR FROM
COLLEAGUES IN THE FIELD PRIVATE
SECTOR EMBLEMS WORKERS NEED
BETTER WORKING CONDITIONS. PART
OF THAT IS ADEQUATE IMPROPER
PROTECTIVE GEAR. AB TWENTY
NINETY TO THE STATE STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION. IT WOULD
REQUIRE PRIVATE SECTOR ALBUMS
IMPORTS INFORMED THEIR ALBUMS
AND PLEASE ABOUT THE RIGHT TO
REQUEST SAFETY DEVICES AND
PROTECTIVE GEAR. AS WE HAVE
SEEN RICKOVER NINETEEN THERE'S
A WIDESPREAD SHORTAGE OF
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT FOR
WORKERS IN ALL HEALTH CARE
SECTORS. THE PROBLEM THAT
PRIVATE SECTOR I'M WITH WORKERS
HAVE DEALT WITH AND SUFFERED
FOR MANY YEARS. AB TWENTY NINE
EIGHTY WILL HELP INSURE SAFER
WORKPLACE BY PROVIDING.
PROTECTIVE GEAR TO WORK FORCE
TO HAVE BEEN NEGLECTED AND
OVERLOOKED FOR FAR TOO LONG.
WITH ME TO TESTIFYING IN
PROVIDE TESTIMONY IS COREY
DAVIS. PRESIDENT OF LOCAL
CHAPTER OR TWELVE DASH SEVENTY
WITH THE INTERNATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF EMTS AND
PARAMEDICS. I BELIEVE HE'S
RECALLING BUT YES THANK YOU
SOME RODRIGUEZ I APOLOGIZE I
THINK I MAY HAVE SAID RIVAS HE
WASN'T REALLY SERVICES NEXT AND
FOLLOW ORDER. SO I APOLOGIZE
FOR THAT THE SEPTEMBER YES-
HERE WAS IN A BETWEEN NINETY
TWO AND- WE HAVE IN SUPPORT. OF
TWO MINUTES ARE YOU DAVIS ARE
TWELVE SEVENTY ARE YOU ON THE
PHONE. THE MODEL. IF WE CAN ASK
THE MODERATOR IF MISTER DAVIS
IS ONLINE. BUT MISTER DAVIS-
WERE NOT READY TO HEAR FROM YOU
IF YOU ARE ON THE LINE PLEASE
RESPOND. AND JUST ANOTHER
MOMENT ME MISTER DAVIS IF YOU
CAN HEAR MY VOICE AT THIS TIME
RIGHT NOW- AND YOU'RE UNABLE TO
SPEAK PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
ON YOUR PHONE PRESS ONE ENTER
ON YOUR FONG. OKAY SO IT
APPEARS THAT AT THE MOMENT.
MISTER DAVIS ONLINE SO WHAT
WE'LL DO IS WE'LL SEE DOES
ANYONE ELSE SUPPORT WILL GO TO
OPPOSITION OF MISTER DAVIS GETS
ONLINE WILL CERTAINLY- HEAR
FROM HIM AS WELL IS ANYONE IS
PRESENT IN SUPPORT. OF AB
TWENTY NINETY TWO. ANYONE ON
THE LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY NINETY TWO. AND A FEW A
FEW ARE WHAT WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO I BELIEVE WE HAVE SOME
COMMENT FROM THE LINE OF. FOR
NINETY NINE POINT NINETY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I WAS CALLING
IN FOR THE ROBERT RIVAS JUNE
ZERO FOUR THREE HOTEL IS THAT.
I'LL BE HEARD THAT OKAY HEARD A
LITTLE LATER PROBABLY AFTER A
RECESS SO PLEASE- BUT CHECK
BACK IN AFTER ONE FORTY FIVE PM.
THANK YOU. WELL NOW CARRILLO
LINE OF LINE TWENTY SEVEN JUST
A MOMENT ONE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR
MIND. BOB I BELIEVE YOUR DAY
MISTER DAVIS PLEASE GO AHEAD
SIR. AND CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW
YES. OKAY GREAT A GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY LABOR COMMITTEE OF THE
INTERNATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
THE MPS AND PARAMEDICS IT'S A
LABOR UNION REPRESENTING OF
PROTECTING HUNDRED EMPLOYEES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. DEDICATED
BIRTH RESPOND AS WORK FOR
PRIVATE COMPANIES ALL ACROSS
THIS GREAT STATE. LOOK FOR A
JOB AS A FIRST RESPONDER. EVERY
MEMBER OF EYE P. IS TRAINED AND
IS DEDICATED TO SAVING LIVES I
AM VERY APPRECIATIVE THAT YOUR
COMMITTEE IS REYES AB TWENTY
NINETY TWO WHICH ADDRESS THE
SAFETY CONCERNS AND EMERGENCY
MEDICAL. ASSISTANT IS. IMAGE
PROFESSIONALS FRIEDMAN RESPOND
EMERGENCIES IN THE FACE OF
BEING- WE'RE RESPOND ACTIVE
SHOOTER SITUATIONS MASS
CASUALTY INCIDENTS AND WORK
SIDE BY SIDE WITH POLICE
OFFICERS IN DANGEROUS
CONDITIONS. WE DESERVE THE SAME
LEVEL OF PROTECTION FROM OUR
EMPLOYERS AS EVERY OTHER FRONT
LINE RESPOND ARE OUT THERE. I
MYSELF HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN AN
ACTIVITY OR SITUATION WITH AN
UNKNOWN ASSAILANT AND FOR
VICTOR AS WELL AS- MOBILE.
FALLS INVOLVED IN GUN VIOLENCE
AND STABBING. I CAN ASSURE YOU
THE SCENES ARE OFTEN CHAOTIC
WITH LITTLE SENSE OF CONTROL.
WE ALL. CALIFORNIA JUST. AGER
RECOGNIZES THE- USE EVERY. ARE
YOU WORK ARM IN ARM WITH POLICE
OFFICERS AND FIREFIGHTERS AND
WE ARE ALL. IT IS OUR HOPE THAT
THE INTRODUCTION OF LEGISLATION
ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE WILL HELP
BEGIN THE CONVERSATION FROM
WHAT WE KNOW TO BE A MUCH
LARGER AND DESPERATELY NEEDED
PRIVATE REVITALIZATION OF THE
ENTIRE EMS PROFESSIONAL
FORMULA. AND ACROSS THE NATION
PROTECTING THOSE WHO WILL CARE
FOR US IN TIMES OF NEED IS NOW
MORE IMPORTANT THAN EVER. ABOUT
OF THE TWENTY NINE TO WALK OF
THE BILL OVER THE RESULT CHANGE
TO OUR MEMBERS WORKING
CONDITIONS. WE KNOW THAT THIS
IS THE CHIEF BALL AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU. IS THERE ANYONE ELSE ON
THE PHONE NINE IN SUPPORT
MISTER MODERATOR. SIR WE DO WE
HAVE WHAT ALL LINED UP ONE
FINAL LINE HERE THE LINE OF
FIVE ONE ONE FIVE ELEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN OKAY THIS IS THE
ANY BROWN I'M BACK TO THE
OPPOSITION FIVE SO ALL ALL ON.
OKAY NO PROBLEM. THE BILL HAS
IN THE- OKAY. IS THERE IS NO
ONE ELSE ABOUT SAY A SUPPORT WE
KNOW. WAS IT. WE DON'T I'M AND
SO WE HAVE WE HAVE SOMEONE. ON
VIDEO. IF YOU CAN. WE CAN HAVE
THE PRESS ON VIDEO. THERE IS A
CHAIR IN OPPOSITION. AS CHAIR
IN OPPOSITION OKAY IF YOU'RE
READY FOR THE FIGHT SO HOLD ON
ONE MOMENT THERE THEN AND SO WE
DO WE HAVE A SO. SEAN HENSCHEL
AMER. BY PHONE. ON A FEW GOING
AT ABOUT HALF. THIS IS IDEAL
WORKING. I SAW MUCH GO AHEAD
I'M SORRY ON VIDEO OF SOMEONE
TO GO AHEAD. AMERICAN MEDICAL
RESPONSE IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME THE- TO TESTIFY
UNDER THESE CIRCUMSTANCES- I AM
JOHN HENSCHEL YOUR BEHALF OF
AMERICAN MEDICAL RESPONSE
CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST PROVIDER
OF NINE ONE ONE EMAGEON C. A.
B. SERVICES. READ A PMR MUST
OPPOSE THIS LEGISLATION FOR
SEVERAL REASONS SUBMITTED TO
THE COMMITTEE IN OUR OFFICE
LETTER WHAT PLAN HAS A GREAT
RISK FOR THE AUTHORS YOUR OF
SIR YES ENGINE THREE TURN EVEN
WELL INTENTIONED POLICY WILL
SIGNIFY NECK THE IMPACTS ARE OF.
PROVIDE EMERGENCY SIR. LET'S
FACE. ANY BUILD PORT HOWEVER
THE DATA SIMPLY DOES NOT SHOW A
NEED FOR BALLISTIC BODY ARMOR A
MARK NOT FIND A SINGLE INCIDENT
OF EMT ACTUALLY SHOT OVER ITS
FORTY PLUS YEARS OF BEING IN
OUR IN OUR OPERATION. THIS BE
ATTRIBUTED TO LISTING TRAINING.
DEFERRING TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND NOT INJURING HOT ZONES I
WOULD CALL THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO LOOK TO THOSE
DIRECTLY IMPACTED BY THIS BILL
SHOULD BE NOTICEABLE THAT WHILE
A MAR IS A PRIVATE PROVIDER OUR
WORKFORCE IS LARGELY RECORD BY
APPS ME. AND THEY HAVE NOT
TAKEN A POSITION ADDITION THIS
OLD BODY ARMOR WAS A RICH
ENTERED AUTHOR IN AB TWENTY SIX
ON THE FIRST DAY AT THE
LEGISLATIVE SESSION BACK IN
DECEMBER EIGHT FOUR YOU HAVE.
THE MEASURE ALL DID NOT HAVE A
SUPPORT IS FROM AB ME AND NEVER
TO A IN THIS CAN. FINALLY IT
REMAINS THERE WHY THIS
LEGISLATION HAS BEEN LIMITED TO
ONLY PRIVATE PROVIDERS. ENDED
THAT THE IMPLIED SEEK TO
REQUIREMENTS FOR PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES IS NOT EQUALLY
IMPORTANT. IT IS INSTEAD CARP
OUT OF THE OLD. SEPARATE LAWS
INDUSTRY OF FIRST RESPONDERS
HAS. THAT ESSENTIALLY PROVIDE
THEME SERVICES CREATES A VERY.
AS PRESIDENT. INCLUDES VIOLENCE
AGAINST WORKFORCE IS NOT
SOMETHING ANYONE WANTS TO SEE
AN AREA. MARBLE SAFETY OF IT
BOYS. ROUND WEBER. ANY LOST
AIMED AT A- IN THE- PROBLEM. OR
IS MAKING TO THE AUTHORED WORK
TOGETHER ON A BILL NEXT SESSION
ON HOW. MEANT IT'S FROM BRING
EM. AND SIX IN THE FIELD I AM
OUR RESPECT OPPOSES AB NO
TWENTY NINETY TWO AND REQUEST
THAT COMMITTEE NOW MOVE IT FOR
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU THANK
YOU. IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM. MISTER
MODERATOR IS OR ANYONE ON THE
LINE. AND LATEST GERMAN PLEASE
PRESS ONE NINE ZERO IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND WE HAVE PEOPLE
QUEUING UP JUST A MOMENT. AND
WE'LL HEAR FROM THE LINE OF
FIVE ELEVEN FIVE ELEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MEMBERS ANY BROWN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA AND
BUILD THE STATION AND THE NINE
ONE ONE AMBULANCE PROVIDERS
ALLIANCE. IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BELT FIRST BROKE BRIEFLY I WANT
TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AND HIS STAFF FOR THE OPEN DATA
AND CONTINUE. TO FIND. I GROUND
JUST BRIEFLY IN MOST CASES
WHERE A PARAMEDIC IS CALLED ON
TO WORK DIRECTLY IN COURT-
CORPORATION WITH- COOPERATION
WITH THE PUBLIC SAFETY OFFICER
IN AN ACTIVE HOT STONE THE
THREE RD HAS A SWAT MEDIC. THAT
MISSION. THESE EITHER TRY
DIRECT. WHAT PERSONNEL AND OUR
FURNITURE PROTECTION AND
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT IT'S
SHOCKING. WE ARE. I BELIEVE
THIS BILL CONFUSE THE PUSH TO
THE BELT THAT TO THE YOU. NOW
HEAR FROM THE LINE OF FIVE ONE
FIVE FIVE FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. SUPPORT OF THE BILL HELLO
THEY GOT A CORRECT THAT'S FINE
BUT- HI MY NAME IS DAVID
RODRIGUEZ- ACTUAL I WANT TO
THANK THE MEMBER FOR READING
THE BE ALL. LIKE HIM I ALSO
WORK IN THE I CURRENTLY WORK IN
THE FIELD AND I WORK FOR PEOPLE.
ALL THE- ON THIS LARGEST. AND I
JUST WANT TO SAY YOU ARE. THE
BOOTS ON THE GROUND WE SUPPORT
THIS BECAUSE THERE'S BEEN MANY
TRYING NOT SO MUCH ACTIVE
SHOOTER SINGING BUT TIME WERE
YOU MAY SHOW UP ON A CALL WERE
UNDER THE STATE JUST MYSELF AND
A PARTNER. WHERE ARE YOU WE CAN
PROTECT HERSELF THAT BURKE
RETREATING BACK YEAH. HI MY-
HAVE BEEN. SHOT FIRED UPON. I
DON'T INFLUENCE. TRYING TO. A
BASIC MEDICAL ALSO. AS ONE BIG
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND HOPEFULLY
YOU GUYS. LOOK AT CAN. SUPPORT
THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
BY NO COMMENTERS AT THIS TIME
RIGHT THANK YOU- ON AB TWENTY
TWO ANY COMMENT ON THE
COMMITTEE AND EMOTION. FOR THE
MOTION SIR SECOND. AND THE
SECOND. YES I SHARE GOOD. BUT
RODRIGUEZ THIS IS A HALF DOZEN
ALWAYS AWKWARD BECAUSE YOU AND
I WE TEND TO BE IN LOCKSTEP
THIS ISSUE HAS SETTLE I AM
GOING TO OPPOSE THE BILL TODAY
WHAT. WITH THEIR SOME OF THESE
CONCERNS THAT WE CAN GET WORKED
OUT WE GET TO THE FLOOR. BUT I
AM CURIOUS- AND AM ARE BROUGHT
UP. WHAT IS THE DIFFERENCE AND
WHY DO WE NAM CAR ABOUT. YOU
KNOW THE PRIVATE VERSUS PUBLIC
SECTORS IF THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT IS SO IMPORTANT WHY IS AN
ALL COME. FOR ALL AD HE'S AN
OLDER MAN. WHAT WAS THE THOUGHT
PROCESS THROUGH THAT. NUMBER
I'M GLAD YOU BROUGHT THAT UP
OVERSEE. MENTIONED IN MY
OPENING STATEMENT. OVER 80% OF
ALL. THE EMPTY THE PARAMEDICS
WORK IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR-
THAT'S A DIFFERENT SECTOR
VERSES- THE PUBLIC SECTOR I
BELIEVE THERE. ARE BETTER
PROTECTED WITH THE GEAR.
WORKING SESSION THEMSELVES- THE
PRIVATE SECTOR IS ONE THAT'S
LACKING IN PROVIDING PROTECTIVE
GEAR- FOR THEIR OUR FRONTLINE
WORKERS ALSO THAT'S PRETTY MUCH
THE MAIN REASON BECAUSE ONCE
AGAIN OVER 80% OF THEM WORK IN
THE PRIVATE SECTOR TO THE
PUBLIC AND WHAT ONCE AGAIN I'M
JUST WORKING ON MY EXPERIENCE
OF YEARS OF SERVICE. AND THE
ISSUES ARE FACING SO JUST
WANTED TO LOOK AT GETTING
BETTER PROTECTION FOR THOSE
WILL IS IN THAT IN THREE I
APPRECIATE AND YOU ANY
INTENTIONS ON ROWING THE
DEFINITION OF SAFETY DEVICES
AND SAFEGUARD BY PUT IT WHAT
THAT MEANS. I'M WILLING TO
CONTINUE OFF TENTH. I KNOW WHAT
ONE CO THAT THEY DESERVE UP
ABOUT IS REGARDING NOT ONE
PERSON HAS BEEN KILLED BY A
SHOOTING INCIDENT. BUT JUST
LIKE ONE OF THE CALLER SAID AND
I CAN. THINK BACK ABOUT MY
EXPERIENCES THERE HAVE BEEN
SEVERAL TIMES WORKING IN THE
FIELD THAT WE HAVE BEEN SHOT
OUT JUST YOU KNOW. I DON'T KNOW
IF THEY'RE WAITING TO SEE THAT
SOMEBODY GETS KILLED IN ORDER
TO LET A PROTECTIVE GEAR. BUT
JUST BECAUSE THERE HASN'T BEEN
PRACTICALITIES IN OVER FORTY
YEARS THAT HE TALKED ABOUT
DOESN'T MEAN. THAT THAT AT ALL
THE CURRENT THAN EVER. AS I'M
REFERENCE TO MY OPENING
STATEMENTS THAT THAT OF WITH.
THE GARLIC. THE VOTE. FOR YOU
TO HELP THOSE TYPES OF SAID
THINGS WERE. ALL THESE OF ARE
KERR. IN THAT BREAKS OUT I MEAN
WHAT ABOUT THOSE EMPLOYEE IS
THERE ARE WORK NOT LEAVE A MARK.
HAVE SOME PROTECTION FOR OUR
WORKERS IF THEY'RE STANDING
SIDE BY SIDE WITH. A POLICE
OFFICER IN A FAR FAR THEY MAY
BE HAVING. BETTER GEAR WARRING.
DURING THAT EVENT BUT YET THE
PROP THE- PRIVATE SECTOR.
DOESN'T HAVE ANYTHING- SO ONCE
AGAIN IS JUST LOOKING AT BETTER
PROTECTION FOR THEM- BECAUSE
EARLIER IN THE DAY AND IT
RELEASED. OF ITS OCCUR MORE
THAN. THE EVER. SO WE SHOULD
LOOK UP PROTECTION OUR FIRST
FOR MY WORK AS WELL ALL THAT I
COMPLETELY AGREE. AN IN I'M OF
OFF OF THE BILL TODAY BUT LOOK
FOR. TO SUPPORT FOR CAN WORKERS
OF THESE. SHE'S WITH THE I'M-
NOT A WITH THAT SAID ARE AFTER
I VOTE AS A OF OUR RAW FOR
BRING THIS BILL UP TODAY ON
THIS WEEK AND HAPPENS BE EMS WE
AS WERE ELECT PROTECT AND ALL
OUR FOR RESPOND SO WHAT THE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR THE IRONIC
OR OF EITHER WAY. OF IF WE CAN
HAVE A REAL CALL OF THE. PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS KALRA HI
KALRA AYE FLORA. FLOOR NOT
VOTING CARILLO CARILLO I'D KEEP.
GONZALEZ. JONES SAWYER
CHANCELLOR I RIVAS. RIVAS I
THEY ON A OVER THE FOR THOSE IT
DOES IT IS PASSED APPROVE AND
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN UP FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND- AB
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY SEVEN. MS
RODRIGUEZ GO ON THAT ONE YES.
WITH THAT SAID ONCE AGAIN THANK
YOU TURN MEMBERS AB TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN WOULD REQUIRE
EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEE WORKERS
IN THE PUBLIC OR PRIVATE SECTOR
THAT PROVIDE DIRECT PATIENT
CARE IN A HOSPITAL SETTING TO
PROVIDE ENSURING PLEASE USE
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
OR PPVS. WOULD ALSO REQUIRE
THESE APARTMENT TAKE A WHEN
YOU'RE STOCKPILE OF UNEXPIRED
PP AND PROVIDE AN INVENTORY TO
CAL OSHA UPON REQUEST. FROM MY
NURSES AND HEALTH CARE WORKERS
TREATING PATIENTS WITH
INFECTIOUS DISEASE ARE EXPOSED.
THE HIGHEST RISK OF INFECTION
BECAUSE OF THEIR CLOSE FREQUENT
CONTACT WITH PATIENTS. IT IS
VITAL THAT WE PROTECT THEM BY
ENSURING THAT THEY HAVE
LIFESAVING EQUIPMENT AVAILABLE
TO USE. TODAY I'M JOINED BY
CURTIS LYING ON BEHALF OF THE
SPONSORS THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION ABILITIES ON
VIETNAM. THANK YOU MISTER WE DO
HAVE TEST IN SUPPORT. I EACH
PER PERSON PLEASE HOLD YOUR TWO
COMMENTS TO TWO MINUTES OR
LESS. WE HAVE WHAT IS WHAT THE
GOVERNOR'S AS WELL AS MY GLICK.
WHO WORKS PROVIDENCE ANGEL IN
SANTO I GOT. WHO ARE THE ORDER
LEPERS AGO. THIS IS WHY THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR CURSED BY WITH
THE COP NURSES. SOUTH PARK OF
AB TWENTY THIRTY SO. AB TWENTY
FIVE SEVEN A BOTTLE PA THAT WE
PROTECT WERE AT THE GLOBAL PAN
RAGE AND THE- THIS MEASURE. THE
NURSES ON THE FROM LINE DEEP
INTO HAVE ACT TO THE- AND
DEVICES NECESSARY TO PROTECT
THEM. ALL OVER THE BILL NINETY
FIVE REST THERE'S HAVE BEEN
EVERYBODY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA MARCH TWENTY. NURSES
AND OTHER WERE HAVE NOT SEEN IN
OF THIS IS. IN THEIR UNIT
UNFORTUNATELY I THE FIVE NINE.
FORTY OKAY WORK IN CALIFORNIA
HAVE TO. IN MANY CASE LAWYERS
HELP. OR RAP AND IN THE BY
REFEREE. LEAKING NURSES.
WORKERS ON. OFF ONCE CASES
NURSES HAVE BEEN JUST. FOR
BRINGING IN THEIR OWN. ORDER
FOR DEMAND THAT A PRO PP BE
PROVIDED WHEN THREE. HOPE IT
NINETEEN OF THE PATIENT.
HOSPITAL OUR HELP IN HISTORY.
TO WHAT KNOWN AS ANTI BUSINESS
METHODS INCLUDING JUSTIN TIMES
BEING AND IN TIME FOR TO SEE OF.
THE TICKET ACOSTA RIFFS
CONSEQUENCE THE HOSPITAL TO A
GAMBLE WROTE TO HOW MY PP TO
HAVE HAVE ON ON BOARD. NOW MY
TO HAVE IMPROPER FOR YOU BEEN
SUCH A THIS PAN. ACCORDINGLY AB
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY SEVEN
REQUIRES. ONE YEAR OF NORMAL
CONSUMPTION. ADDITIONALLY
EMPLOYERS ARE REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE AN INVENTORY OF THEIR
STOCKPILES TO CAL OSHA UPON
REQUEST. IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THE HOSPITAL ALREADY
CALCULATING AND REPORTING PP
SUPPLY AND NEED TO CITY GATES-
DAILY. ADDITIONALLY AB TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN SURE THAT
EMPLOYER WHO VIOLATES THIS
REQUIREMENT SO BE ASSESSED THE
CIVIL COUNTY. OF UP TO TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR EACH
SUCH VIOLATION FOR SOMEONE TO
CURRENT CAL OSHA REGULATIONS.
AB TWENTY FIVE. THIRTY SEVEN IS
A MEASURE THAT PUTS FOR REGAL
PROVISIONS THAT WILL IMPROVE
THE SAFETY OF OUR AND OTHER
HEALTHCARE WORKERS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. WE ASK FOR YOUR I BO
ON IS MUCH TODAY. AND I WILL
TURN OVER TO WITNESS OUR AND
MICHAEL YOU LIKE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. I'M MICHAEL
GULICK I'VE BEEN WORKING ON THE
MEDICAL SURGICAL UNIT. FOR
ABOUT FIVE AND A HALF YEARS THE
PROBLEM THANK JOHN TOLD VANITY
FAIR MONICA CALIFORNIA. WHICH
HAD RECENTLY BEEN CONVERTED
INTO AN ALL CO THAT UNIT FOR
ABOUT TWO AND A HALF MONTHS.
BEING PROVIDED ONLY A SURGICAL
MASK AND GOGGLES. WHEN TAKING
CARE OF THESE HIGHLY INFECTIOUS
PATIENT CARE SIMON. ON APRIL
NINTH TWENTY TWENTY MYSELF AND
MY OTHER COLLEAGUES. WORKING
THAT THAT DAY REQUESTED FROM
OUR NURSING LEADERSHIP THAT WE
BE PROVIDED. HOSPITAL ISSUE
NINETY FIVE RESPIRATORS ONE
TAKING CARE OF THE NINETEEN
ASIAN. WE WERE MOTIVATED AND
CONVICTED TO TAKE THESE
ACTIONS. AS WE HAD RECENTLY
RECEIVED INFORMATION OF SOME OF
OUR FELLOW COLLEAGUES TESTING
POSITIVE AS WELL AS THE
CLINICAL JUDGMENT AND DIRECTOR.
OF ARE ATTENDING PHYSICIAN
STATING WE SHOULD NOT TAKE CARE
OF THESE PATIENT CARE SILENCE
WITH THE HOSPITAL ISSUED AN
NINETY FIVE RESPIRATOR. OUR
HOSPITAL ARE A NURTURING
LEADERSHIP AND HOSPITAL
ADMINISTRATION DENIED BEING
ABLE TO PROVIDE US WITH NINETY
FIVE READ RESPIRATORS. WE DID
THROUGH WE DISAGREED OTHER
SAFETY CONCERNS. OTHER NURSING
OF LAW AS NON NURSING CRITICAL
STAFF AND OUR HOSPITAL WERE
BEING PROVIDED- HOSPITAL ISSUED
AND NINETY FIVE RESPIRATORS. OF
INTO. BUT DIRECTORS OFFICE
WHETHER HOW HOW TO PROVIDE AND
WERE GIVEN A DIRECT ORDER TO
RESUME CARE OF THE CO THE
NINETEEN PATIENT CARE TIME IT'S
WITHOUT A HOSTILE ISSUE AND
NINETY FIVE RESPIRATOR. AND
FAILURE TO COMPLY WILL RESULT
IN SUSPENSION FROM WORK AND BE
CONSIDERED PATIENT ABANDONMENT
AND NEGLIGENCE AND PROVIDING
NURSING CARE AND COULD LEAD TO
REPORT TO THE STATE. LICENSURE
BURKE. WE ALSO STATED THAT WE
ARE NOT ABANDONING OUR OUR
PATIENTS AND ARE NOT IN A GOOD
AND PROVIDE NURSING. WE'RE
MERRILEESUP FOR OUR PATIENTS
ARE COLLEAGUES AND OUR- AND OUR
AND OUR FIFTY BY. TO TAKE CARE
OF COVER NINETEEN. ON THE
WITHOUT PROVIDED A HOSPITAL AND
NINETY REST. WE WERE BY IT FOR
MORE PLACED ON ADMINISTRATIVE
LEAVE. PENDING AND THEN THEN
INVESTIGATION WITH THE HUMAN
RESOURCES DEPARTMENT. WE WERE
SUSPENDED FOR ABOUT THREE
WEEKS. ABOUT TWO WEEKS AGO WE
WERE REINSTATED BACK TO WORK
WITH WRITTEN DISCIPLINARY
ACTIONS. ON GETS PUT INTO A
FILE. NURSES WE ARE TAUGHT TO
QUESTION EVERYTHING. BUT IF
WITHIN IF INVOLVES CONCERN
ABOUT. SAFETY FOR OUR PATIENTS
OR COLLEAGUES IN OUR- AS A
WHOLE. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
TWENTY ONE IN THE ROOM IT IN
SUPPORT. OF AB TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN. ANYONE MISTER
MODERATOR ON THE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN. HELLO AND PLEASE
PRESS ONE NINE ZERO IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT PRESS ONE
THAT AND ZERO. AND WE HAVE A
FEW PEOPLE LINING UP FOR
COMMENTS JUST A MOMENT. HER
FIRST COMMENT COMES FROM THE
LINE OF. FIVE THIRTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD FIVE THIRTEEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS NOT THE JAY
FROM HERE YOU- CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING WORKERS IN NURSING
HOMES. HOSPITALS PRIVATE SECTOR
STATE INCLUDING THOSE
REPRESENTED BY U. H. W. AT
TWENTY FIFTEEN I JUST WANT TO
SEE DON'T HAVE A POSITION BUT
WE ARE SUPPORTED THE CONCEPT WE
CAN. SHE THIS ISSUE AND FOR TO
CONTINUE KERR PATIENTS TO
ENSURE THAT ALL WORKERS THE
LEVEL OF P. P. THAT THEY NEED
IN THE FUTURE SO THAT WE ARE
NOT- WORKERS SENT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU. HER NEXT
COMMENT COUNSEL ONE OF FIVE
TWENTY SIX FIVE TWENTY SIX ONE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
JACQUI FOUND ON BEHALF THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE OFTEN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
OUR NEXT COMIC CON SINGLE LINE
OF FIVE TWENTY FIVE FIVE TWENTY
FIVE YEAR ONE IS OPEN. WHICH
DUGGAR CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
KEEP. AND ONCE AGAIN PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK. AND WE HAVE THE LINE
OF THREE FORTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THREE FORTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AND WE'RE GONNA
GO TO LINE UP TO- TO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. VERY GOOD YES THE HARA
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ONE
FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IN
PART MADE ALIVE FIFTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WELL MAKERS LOCAL
FIVE FOUR NINE SUPPORT OF THE
UP WITH US FOR THE- THANK YOU.
AND THERE IS NO ONE ELSE. OKAY
THANK YOU AND IN OPPOSITION
CATHERINE SCOTT OF CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION BY PHONE
GIL BLANCHARD SAGER ALSO COUPLE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL TUITION
THEY SHOULD BOTH ON THE PHONE.
UP TO TWO MINUTES EAST PLEASE
CALPERS. YEAH NOT THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
ALL TESTIFIED FOR BOTH GALA
NIGHT TO TRY AND BECAUSE BY
THAT TIME FOR HOSPITAL NOTHING
IS MORE IMPORTANT TO HELP FIX
THE OF THEIR WORKERS IN FUTURE.
RESERVE AN FTP FOR ALL. OF THE
NOT A MATTER OF DESIRE OR BY.
OF REALITY. AS THEY WERE HARD.
PP FOR MY GIVER THE COLD
NINETEEN AWFUL FIFTY A GLOBAL
VICE THROUGH THE CAN DO TO A OF
FACTORS. INCLUDING OVERSEAS
MANUFACTURING ISSUE. IN THE MAN.
HI UTILIZATION. THE SHORTEST
HEALTH ALEX KEEP ON WORKERS
OKAY SO HOW RISK IN ACCORDANCE
WITH THE W. H. O. ET THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. AND CAL OSHA GUIDANCE
OCTOBER NOT COURT ORDER AND TO
PROTECT THEIR WORKERS. THE MATH
SHORTAGE AND WE GET A BATH IN
THE CHALLENGING. WHAT THE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC OF THE PPV
ARE BEING LEARNED. HI RIGHT.
NOW FOR MANY. OKAY YOU. WHEN
YOU DON'T THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ARE TO FIND WAYS TO
MAX ITS AVAILABLE HEALTHCARE
WORK IT IS NOT THE SYSTEM BY MY
EXTRA WHEN THERE'S NOT ENOUGH I
THINK WE NEED TO THINK
DIFFERENTLY FORWARD ABOUT HOW
TO MAKE SURE ALL HEALTHCARE
WORK FOR THAT THEY WORK IN A
HOSPITAL. BUT I WOULD BE BE.
THE BILL THAT. HE SEEMS LIKE A
VIABLE IS FACT BECAUSE UNDER
THE VERY OPEN I'M ONE OF THE
LESSONS FROM COVER IS THE THIRD
BE HOT BUT DURING A PANDEMIC OF
THE WORK IN SAN DIEGO AND NOT
DEMAND ROCK POLITICAL SHIFT
UNLIMITED RESEARCH WITH BETWEEN.
YES AND BETWEEN CARE FOR THE-
FOR EXAMPLE THE NURSING DOCTOR
NEEDED PP CONCERN A HOPPER WITH
AN AYE THE REQUEST FOR RUNNING
AFOUL THE LEGAL MAN UNDER BELT
AS WELL AS THE KIND OF. WHEN IT
COMES THE STORE AND USED THE PP
LAW STOCK ARE NOT THAT WAY TO
ME THREE FOUR THERE ARE MANY
ISSUES WITH A RAYS. TOWARDS
THINKING ABOUT COST. THEN BILL
MOTHER ALSO BE HIGHER I COSTS
IF YOU EXACTLY THE LARGE CAR.
WHILE MAINTAINING YOUR ARE. AT
THE CAN TO FACE THE THREAT OF
CODED WE MUST WORK WITH THE
FATE COUNTY HEALTH CARE
ENTITIES EMPLOYEES LARGE TO
BOTH OF THE BY TRAIN AND
DETERMINE THE BEST PLAN FOR PDP
SHORTAGE ABOUT. AND FOR
FORTUNATELY. THE BILL AND IT
CURRENT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
ONE IN THE ROOM IN OPPOSITION
TO AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY SEVEN.
SAMAT ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE.
YES AND AGAIN LATE IN GERMAN
ONE THAN ZERO FOR YOUR COMMENTS
BUT WE HAVE A THE LINE OF ONE
NINETY ONE NINETY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI THIS IS NEAR MORE
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
THE STATION ALSO OPPOSE
MUKTANANDA THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NOW CAROLINE OF FIVE TWENTY
EIGHT FIVE TWENTY EIGHT ALIGN
SO. AND THANK YOU. KNUCKLE ONE
OF FOUR NINETY THREE FOUR
NINETY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON. ON BEHALF OF
THE DISTRICT HOSPITAL
LEADERSHIP FOR WITH THAT OPPOSE
THE ONCE A MONTH. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. JUST A MOMENT WE'LL
HAVE ONE FINAL COMMENT. ANYONE
ELSE WISHING TO COMMENT MAY
PLUS ONE AND ZERO. WE'RE GOING
TO THE LINE OF FIVE TWENTY
SEVEN FIVE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR
ONE IS OPEN. CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MAKE AND WEBER ON BEHALF OF THE
UNITED HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION. WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S WORK ON
THIS ISSUE HI BUT REMAIN
OPPOSED MUST AMENDED AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU. THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENTERS PLEASE
CONTINUE. ALL RIGHT THANK OU
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. ANY COMMENT
QUESTION. MOTIONS. WE HAVE A
MOTION RESERVE A CAREER ON A.
B. AND A SECOND FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER USE WITH US. ANY
OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS I
DO THINK A LOT OF LESSONS ARE
BEING LEARNED RIGHT NOW IN REAL
TIME AND ONE OF THEM IS THAT
HAVE OUR FACILITIES AT A LITTLE
BIT MORE AND HAVE. BEEN THE
CASE VIRGIN SEES IS HIS THAT
OCCUR. AND I THINK I'M I'M-
FOR. CERTAIN THE BURKE WITH
OPERA. IN TERMS WHAT THAT
ACTUALLY LOOKS LIKE
ALTERNATELY. US ALREADY GUESTS
DO YOU HAVE ANY OF CLOSING
COMMENTS ARE JUST RESPECT RAIL
TRAVEL. THANK YOU- WE CAN HAVE
THE ROLE TO. BE TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN. SENATE HE PASSED
TO APPROPRIATE CALL. I AYE
FLORA. LARA NOCARILLO CARILLO
I DEEP. DID NOT VOTING GONZALEZ.
JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER HI
RIVAS RIVAS AYE ALL RIGHT THAT
IS PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS AND
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF THIS AND GET
IF I CAN'T ON MOMENT I
UNDERSTAND YOU'RE HAVING SOME
MICROPHONE ISSUES HEARING. ON
AN OUNCE OF THE BUT AGAIN FOR
THE CONSENT ITEMS TO AB. TWENTY
SEVENTEEN TO TWENTY THIRTY
TWENTY THREE SEVEN. NINE EIGHT
THIRTY FIVE. THIRTY ONE SEVENTY
THREE THREE SIX NINE FOR THOSE
WERE NOT WERE NOT ABLE TO HEAR
THE ROLL CALL THE VOTE WAS TWO
ZERO AND WE WILL NOW BE IN
RECESS UNTIL TWO PM. OF THE
SERVER DEEP OF MINIATURE IF YOU
SEE A TIME IS IT OKAY IF I ADD
ON ON YEAH BEFORE GOING TO WHEN
I WAS GOING. BECAUSE IT'S FREE
TO LEAVE THE MOMENT. DEEP THINK
UP. EIGHTY THREE FIFTY SIX.
IT'S A FILE ITEM THREE. YES SO
IS AN AYE VOTE. GO SO THE BILL
IS OUT EVERYONE HAS VOTED ON IT
I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE
ON IT AND THEN THE OTHER ONE I
SEE IS FILE HI THIS WE GET
TWENTY. OF THE IS THE FORMER I
BEFORE WE HER BEFORE THIS ONE
WAS ONE REGARDING THE ABLE
EXACTLY THE AS WORKERS OF WATER
RICH VERY NOBLE NO OKAY. RIGHT
NOW. ON. ON TWENTY NINETY TO
THE NO. OKAY ON TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN IS NOT ONLY THAT
IT. SO YEAH YOU'RE ALREADY
REGISTERED OR NOT VOTING BUT ON
TWENTY BY THIRTY SEVEN SO ON
TWENTY NINETY TWO YOUR I KNOW.
THAT OKAY SO YOU'RE CAUGHT UP
RIGHT NOW AND WE'LL BE IN
RECESS UNTIL TWO. THANK HELLO.
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN WITH.
BUT
WE'RE BACK IN SESSION FOR A
LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE
HEARING- FILE ITEM FOR AB
TWENTY FORTY THREE FOR TWENTY
FORTY THREE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS MR RIVAS WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. MY PHONE HAD A TEXT
MESSAGE FROM YOU SO I RAN DOWN
THE HALL. TO GET HERE. AND AS
THE CHILDREN TO GET SOME
EXERCISE ANYWAY BUT- THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES I
LIKE TO START BY THANKING
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
EXCEPTIONAL EXCEPTIONAL LEVEL
OF ASSISTANCE TO MY OFFICE ON
THE BILL WITH. A SHORT FRAME
URGENCY AROUND IT I ALSO TO
EXTEND A SPECIAL THANKS TO. MY
COLLEAGUES ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA. BOTH OF WHOM
ARE JOINT AUTHORS ON THIS BILL.
A FULL FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT. THIS BILL ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO ZERO FOUR THREE. WHICH
ADDRESSES THE OCCUPATIONAL
SAFETY AND HEALTH OF OUR STATE
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS. AS WE GET
THROUGH THIS COVER NINETEEN
HEALTH CRISIS NOW EVERY DAY A
FARMER ACROSS OUR STATE RISE
EARLY. THEY LEAVE BEHIND THE
FAMILIES- TO PACK INTO CROWDED
BUSES. THEY WORK SHOULDER TO
SHOULDER IN THE FIELD. THEIR
DAYS THE LONG WAY. THE WORK IS
HARD IT BREAKS DOWN YOUR BODY
OVER TIME. MY GRANDFATHER WHO
REYES MADE THROUGH THE
FARMWORKERS. THE PHARMACY TIRE
LIFE AND I SAW HOW TIRELESSLY
HE WORKED. HE DID HIS WORK DAY
IN AND DAY OUT. I AND HE DID IT
FOR NOT MUCH MONEY MANY
FARMWORKERS ARE UNDOCUMENTED
THEY LIVE THEY THEY'RE THEY
THEY ARE THEY LACK ACCESS TO
QUALITY HEALTHCARE. THAT THAT A
LOT OF US FOR GRANTED CHRONIC
HEALTH CONDITIONS ARE COMMON
AND VIRUSES VIRUSES CAN SPREAD
QUICKLY. YOU SEE IT'S NOT JUST
THAT THE FARMWORKERS WORK. IN
CLOSE PROXIMITY TO EACH OTHER.
THAT THEY HANDLE THE SAME TOOLS
AND THE- A QUICK. BUT THAT THEY
LIVE IN CLOSE PROXIMITY TO EACH
OTHER. AND THE LACK OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
CALIFORNIA ALONG WITH THE MANY
WITH THE LOW WAGES THAT MOST
FARMWORKERS EARNED MEANS THAT
MANY MANY FARMWORKERS LIVE IN
VERY ARE THE CONDITIONS SEVERAL
FAMILIES TO ONE APARTMENT OR
SMALL HOUSE. OF SOME IT'S SIX.
TO KEEP THEM SET. THEM ISOLATED
IN SEPARATE. AS LONG AS THIS
PANDEMIC CONTINUES OUR
FARMWORKERS ARE AT RISK AND
LIKE OUR ELDERLY POPULATION
LIKE ARE HOMELESS POPULATION
FARMWORKERS ARE VULNERABLE THEN
I IN I BELIEVE WE HAVE A MORAL
RESPONSIBILITY MORAL DUTY TO
PROTECT VULNERABLE. AND WHEN IT
COMES TO THE TO FARM
AGRICULTURE WORKERS- WE YOU
KNOW. IT SURE THAT WE PROTECT
THEM IS AN URGENT URGENT
MATTER. YOU KNOW A COVERT
NINETY OUTBREAK IN THE FARM
WORKER. THE COMMUNITY WITH
THREATEN OUR FOOD SUPPLY WE
NEED OUR FARMWORKERS TO STAY
HEALTHY SO THEY CAN STATE JOB
ARE FARMWORKERS KEEP FOOD ON
OUR TABLES AND THEY KEEP OUR
GROCERY STORE SHELVES STOP.
CLEARLY FARMERS AND
AGRICULTURAL PLAYERS ARE
PARTNERS IN THIS EFFORT. MOST
OF THEM UNDERSTAND THE RISK
THAT FARMWORKERS SPACE THEY
CARE ABOUT THEIR EMPLOYEES- AND
THEY WANT TO KEEP THEM SAFE.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT RIGHT NOW
WE HAVE A PATCHWORK OF SAFETY
GUIDANCE ACROSS OUR STATE AND
SUCH GUIDANCE CAN BE. VERY
DIFFERENT FROM COUNTY TO COUNTY.
AND IT'S NOT ALWAYS CLEAR OR
STANDARDIZED AND THIS BILL IS
DESIGNED TO CREATE A CLEAR
UNIFORM STANDARD THAT APPLIES
TO ALL AGRICULTURAL WORKERS IN
OUR STATE IN CALIFORNIA. IT'LL
MAKE THINGS EASIER FOR FARMERS
WHO WANT TO IMPLEMENT BEST
PRACTICES AND IT WILL KEEP
FARM. SAFE WHICH IS IN
EVERYONE'S BEST INTEREST. AND I
LIKE TO CALL OUT ONE LOCAL
EFFORT WHICH I THINK WORKED
EXTREMELY WELL SOON AFTER THE
PANDEMIC KIT IN THE COUNTY OF
RAY REPRESENTATIVES OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT INDUSTRY THEY CAME
TOGETHER- BUT TO AGREE ON
COVERT NINETEEN RELATED
AGRICULTURAL WORKPLACE SAFETY
GUIDELINES. AND NOW THESE THESE
GROUPS CRAFTED A DOCUMENT THEY
LAKE BEST ACTRESSES FOR KEEPING
FARMERS SAFE. I BEEN UPDATED
REGULARLY. IT'S BEEN A GOOD
RESOURCE FOR AGRICULTURAL
EMPLOYERS ACROSS THE DISTRICT.
I'LL BUT WE SHOULDN'T BE MAKING
THESE DECISIONS ON A COUNTY BY
COUNTY LEVEL IT. TOO
INCONSISTENT IT'S TWO ONE EVEN
IT'S TOO COMPLICATED FOR
FARMERS AND IT LEAVES TOO MANY
FARM WORKERS AT RISK. WE NEED A
SINGLE BUST A SET OF STATEWIDE
GUIDELINES TO PROTECT
AGRICULTURE WORKERS FROM KOBE
NINETEEN. THIS LEGISLATION JUST
THAT BY ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE
IN THREE WAYS FIRST IT REQUIRES
AGRICULTURAL PLAYERS TO
IMPLEMENT CAL OSHA'S ALREADY
DISSEMINATED COVE IN NINETEEN
HEALTH AND SAFETY GUIDELINES
FOR AG FROM POINT. BUT
GUIDELINES ARE NOT ENFORCEABLE.
SO SECOND THIS BILL ALSO IT
DIRECTS CAL OSHA STANDARDS
BOARD TO ADOPT OCCUPATIONAL
HEALTH AND SAFETY STANDARDS.
FOR KOBE NINETEEN INFECTION
PREVENTION STANDARDS THAT CAN
BE AND FORCE. THE STANDARDS ARE
WILL INCLUDE BUT SHALL NOT BE-
LIMITED TO SANITATION PRACTICES
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
AND PHYSICAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS. AND THIRD AB TWO
ZERO FOUR THREE IMPLEMENT A
TARGETED OUTREACH CAMPAIGN TO
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS ON CAL
OSHA'S BEST PRACTICES TO STAY
SAFE FROM COLBERT NINETEEN.
THIS CAMPAIGN SHOULD CONSIST OF
PUBLIC SERVICE AND OUT UP- THE
PUBLIC SERVICE ANNOUNCEMENTS
WORKPLACE SIGNS IN ENGLISH AND
SPANISH MAKING IT ACCESSIBLE TO
ALL FARMWORKERS. WHEN YOU TAKE
THIS ALL TOGETHER THESE
PROVISIONS PROVIDE CLEAR AND
STANDARDIZE GUIDANCE TO FARMERS
ABOUT HOW TO KEEP THAT PLEASE
SAFE. THE BILL ALSO EMPOWERS
FARMWORKERS WITH INFORMATION TO
THEMSELVES SAFE BECAUSE
EVERYONE HAS A SHARED
RESPONSIBILITY TO PREVENT THE
SPREAD OF COVERT NINETEEN. WE
ALSO PLAN TO MEND THE BILL WHEN
POSSIBLE IN SOME IMPORTANT
WAYS- WE'D LIKE TO ADD AN
URGENCY CLAUSE SO THAT THESE
POLICIES CAN BE IMPLEMENTED
MUCH MORE QUICKLY. WE ALSO HOPE
TO CELEBRATE THE TIME LINE FOR
CAL OSHA TO ADOPT THE STANDARDS
BY LEVERAGING THE EMERGENCY
REGULATION PROCESS OF THE APA
THE ADMINISTRATIVE. THE
PROCEDURES ACT AND MAKE NO
MISTAKE WE ARE THE MEN OF A
PILE OF IN C. WITH A NO. IT
ENDED. THE STANDARDS ARE. TO
ADDRESS THIS. NOW FOR
FARMWORKERS SICK. AND OUR FOOD
SUPPLY. THREATENED I RECKON
THAT SOME AGRICULTURAL
EMPLOYERS MAY OBJECT TO WHAT
THEY'VE US TOP DOWN
REQUIREMENTS FROM BUT I THINK
MOST ARE EAGER TO HAVE A CLEAR
SAFETY GUIDANCE RIP REPLACING A
COUNTY BY COUNTY PATCHWORK IT'S
MUCH EASIER TO KEEP YOUR FOR
SAFE. IF YOU KNOW OTHER GROWERS
ACROSS OUR FALL ON THE SET.
I'VE BEEN IN CONTACT IN IN
CLOSE TOUCH WITH FORMER. AND
THE EYES AS- THESE RULES TO
WORK FOR EVERYONE BUT WE MUST
ALSO STAY CLEAR EYED ABOUT WHAT
WE NEED TO DO HERE- WE NEED TO
PROTECT OUR VULNERABLE
FARMWORKERS AS THEY WORKED
TIRELESSLY TO KEEP FOOD ON OUR
TABLES DURING HIS CONDEMNING
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THIS
BILL DOES. I WILL WITH I THANK
LOCAL. PERFORM FOR FAMILYAND-
SAYS ON FOR LACK WHAT. COMPASS
THE CALIFORNIA THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU SOME MEMBER
RIVAS- IN WE DO HAVE TWO
WITNESSES EACH WITNESS WILL
HAVE UP TO TWO MINUTES THEY'RE
BOTH GOING TO BE. THE PHONE DR
L. LOPEZ. FOR FARMWORKER
FAMILIES MADE MAY BEGIN A
NUMBER OF YOU GET ON THE LINE.
THAT AFTERNOON I AM YES AS HE
SAID I'M DOCTOR AND LOPEZ THE
DIRECT EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CENTER FOR FAR MORE
FAMILIES AND I HAVE BEEN
SEARCHING AND WORKING WITH
FARMWORKERS FOR THE PAST TWENTY
THREE YEARS IN AN ATTEMPT TO
STAND. STRENGTH THEIR LAW. A
PUB AWARENESS AND IMPROVEMENT
OF THEIR DIFFICULT LIFE
CIRCUMSTANCES. I THINK
PROFESSOR RICK MINE UC DAVIS
SUMMARIZES THEIR LIVES TO THE
SAME PLACE THE LONGER
FARMWORKERS ARE WORKING. EXCUSE
ME WORKING IN CALIFORNIA THE
THICKER THEY GET. EXCUSE ME A
LIFE OF POVERTY INCLUDING OVER
CROWDED LIVING CONDITIONS FOR
NUTRITION REGULAR EXPOSURE TO
TOXIC PESTICIDES AND LACK OF
HEALTH INSURANCE TAKES ITS TOLL
FREE THING AND BRIDGE LIVE.
CITY OF ONLY FORTY. THE CALL
THANK AND EXACERBATES ALL OF
THESE FACTORS ADDING YET ONE
MORE ISSUE TO THEIR ALREADY
OVERBURDENED LIVE WHERE AT SOME
FARMWORKERS UNDERSTAND THE
DANGER OF THE PANDEMIC AND WHAT
THEY CAN DO TO PROVE THEMSELVES.
DO NOT IT THE SITUATION THERE
IS NO OPPORTUNITY TO PRACTICE
SOCIAL DISTANCING EITHER IN THE
FIELD OR IN THEIR LIVING
SITUATION THEY OFTEN ARE ON
ABLE TO REGULARLY WASH THEIR
HANDS AND IN MY- DO NOT HAVE A
PERSONAL ACTED THE QUICK BUT IF
THERE ARE. IT ABSOLUTELY IMPACT
THAT WE TAKE ALL POSSIBLE STEPS
TO PROTECT THESE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS WHO ARE PARTIALLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR SUPPLYING TWO
THIRDS OF THE FRUITS AND NUTS
AS WELL AS ONE HALF OF STATE
AND BED. AN OUTBREAK OF COLD IT
PAIN IN THE FARM COMMUNITY
WOULD COMPROMISE THE
AGRICULTURAL ECONOMY AND RESULT
IN WIDESPREAD PAINFUL ILLNESS
AND POSSIBLY DEATH AND THE
COMMUNITY CENTER FOR FARMWORKER
FAMILIES. COURT BE TWENTY FORTY
THREE THE AGRICULTURAL AND
AGRICULTURAL EMPLOYEE CALLED IT
NINETEEN HEALTH AND SAFETY ACT.
OUTREACH CAMPAIGN CRITICS.
PROVIDE AN INFORMAL I ARGUE
NASA'S OSHA GUIDANCE
INFORMATION TO FARMWORKERS I
IMPLORE YOU TO JOIN CENTER FOR
FARMWORKER FAMILIES AND SUPPORT
THE RIVAS BILL AB TWENTY FORTY
THREE THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND
MARCO THERE'S A RAGA OF LAW
CORPORATE DIVA. OKAY ALL OF OUR
LITTLE CARING DOT COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS NOT OFFICIAL
THE SAGA AND I AM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR THE COMMITTEE WELCOME
IF YOU KNOW THE- FORMER SOME
MORE FOR MY- WHY NOT TRY CHIRLA
FUMBLED ABOUT. AB OFF BOB BY A
MEMBERS RELATIONS HAVE. FOR
THERE'S ONE SIR FIFTY FIVE
FARMWORKERS. ONE FIND A WIDE
RANGE OF SERVICE FROM YOU TRAIN.
POLITICIAN OF SO PANELS FOR THE
HOMES. YOUR PREFERRED CONCERN
FOR A PEOPLE IN IN FINANCIAL.
DAHLE OVER 80% OF WORKERS THAT
WE KNOW THAT THAT THE SHOULD
MAKE THAT ABOUT 40% OF POPULAR
IN THE STATE ALSO REPORTED.
PERCENT POSITIVE. UP ON THE
INFECTIONS. IN THAT MISSION
THERE OF SAN FRANCISCO ALONG
OUT OF FOUR. OF THE TWO TEND.
FOR MORE THAN MY FIVE OF
KITCHENS ARE MORE HAVE BEEN DID
TO THE CENTRAL. FINANCIAL WORK.
IT WILL BE PROTECT A SET. WE
NEVER HEARD BE ALL SEEING INTO.
HE NEVER ABOUT FICTION OTHERS
AT MORE PUT THEM HI RISK OF
BEING BY COLOGNE. YESTERDAY AGO
ON THE FARM HOW YOU'VE GIVEN ON
THE SALINAS AREA WHERE THERE
SIXTY WORKERS STAND SICK INTO
THE STOLEN HAVE MORE MY BE
INFECTED. BUYERS AND SEND YOU
SHOULD BACK. YOUR PATIENT MUCH
NEED TO BE A IN THE FIELD ALONG
PERSON PROTECT IT. HE ME
STRONGLY SUPPORT ASSEMBLYMAN
ROBERT VERY WELL AB. TWENTY
FORTY THREE. ACTUALLY ASKED FOR
IT I VOTE FOR THIS GUY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. IS THERE A HERE
IN THE AUDIO WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK CONSERVE OF AB FOUR THREE
AGAIN AS FOR THOSE ARE NOT THE
A PRIMARY WITNESSES NAY. THE
BILL AND OTHER THE BRIDGE
YOU'RE. TO A LITTLE BOY WAS
HERE OR ANYONE ON THE- A MISTER
MOM. ON A SUPPORT OF AB. FOUR
THREE. YOUR POSITION IS IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILLION ME
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME ONE ZERO PLEASE. THERE ARE
SEVERAL IN Q. WILL BE JUST A
MOMENT. AGAIN THE OPERATOR WILL
INSTRUCT YOU ON WHAT YOU'RE
LINE NUMBER IS ONCE YOU'VE
PRESSED ONE GIRL. GO TO LINE
FIVE SEVEN TWO FIVE SEVENTY GO
AHEAD. BACK IN THE CHAIR AND
MARK SHOT BUT CALIFORNIA LEGAL
FOUND STYLE AND SUPPORT AT.
EIGHTY FOUR THREE. FIND FIVE
SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
VERY GOOD SHE HARA ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT
LAWYERS ASSOCIATION AND THE
COURT. HANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
THE LINE. FIVE FIVE THREE NINE
FIVE THIRTY NINE LET'S GO AHEAD.
HER NUMBER PARTY WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT AND ALSO
REGISTRY SUPPORT FOR CLEAN
WATER ACTION AND THE COMMUNITY
WATER CENTER THANK YOU. THE YOU.
NINE FIVE SIX NINE FIVE SIXTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS A RAIN CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE ORGANIZATION
LEAVE THE COMPANY NOT IN THAT
OF WOMEN FARMWORKERS LEADER WE
ARE IN. AS A TWENTY FOUR. MUCH
THANK YOU. FIND FIVE SEVENTY
ONE FIVE SEVEN ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WHAT BACKING DOLLARS
NATIONAL OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CHAPTER AND. THANK I AM FIVE
THREE FIVE FIFTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THAT AFTERNOON
AND MEMBERS JACQUI GRAY WELL IT
YES W. I. STATES COUNCIL AND
THE POOR THANK YOU. YOU. I AM
FIVE SIX THREE FIVE THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS THE IS MICHELLE GALA
BEHALF OF CAL IN THE ALL CENTER
AND OF THE- THANK YOU THANK YOU.
LINE FOR SIX TWO FIVE SIX TWO
PLEASE GO. HOW BUT MOTOR WITH A
CALIFORNIA THANK ME NOT AND
ALONG WITH OF OUR MEN
CALIFORNIA REPUBLIC REFORM.
TESTIFIED ACT NETWORK MEDIA
FINANCE WITH SAM FARMERS HOW
FOR MINOR AND AGRICULTURE
NETWORK AND THE LATINO CO FOR
HELP TELL. THANK YOU. FIND FIVE
FIVE FOUR FIVE FIFTY FOUR
PLEASE GO OUT. IT WAS A YOUR
NUMBER THE COMMITTEE JESSICA
NOT OF THE AT THE KIDS SUPPORT
THE YOU. NINE FIVE FOUR. FIVE
FORTY SIX GO AHEAD. BRINGING
WITH LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR
JUSTICE CANADA CALLING IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
FIND FIVE FOUR FIVE SO FOUR
YOUR LINE OF THE- THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS VINCENT OR
NOT WITH WHAT GROUP ON BEHALF
OF THE NEXT GEN INTO FOUR.
THANK YOU. AND FIVE SIX FOUR
FIVE SIXTY FOUR GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THIS IS WHAT I'M POLICE ON THE
UPPER LEVEL OF OUR AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. FINAL LINING Q.
RIGHT NOW IS FIVE SIX EIGHT
FIVE SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WELL OVER TWO SANTA CLARA
CA WAIT THAT COALITION IN
STRONG WORK THE YOU ROUTE. YOU
KNOW FOR THE AIRLINES CUBIC
TIME THANK YOU WELL WE DO HAVE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. WE
HAVE A BOTH WILL BE A PHONE
MICHAEL MILLER CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF WINE GRAPE
GROWERS. AND ROB MUTRIE THE CAL
CHAMBER SO MISTER MILLER IF
YOU'RE READY ON THE PHONE.
YOU'RE ON THE PHONE BUT DON'T
HAVE AN OPEN LINE RIGHT NOW
PLEASE PRESS STAR AND THEN ZERO.
POLITICALLY. STATE YOUR NAME.
SORRY CARLOS MARKET. IT IS MY
BECAUSE ARE YOU IN APPLIANCE
FOR OPPOSITION NOW HI MATT THIS
IS NOT MY BILL I'M SO SORRY I'M
CALLING ABOUT TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTY FIVE. ALRIGHT WE'LL GET
INTO THAT MIGHT GET A LITTLE
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE HAVE
TWO WITNESSES MILLER CALIFORNIA
OFFICIAL ANGRY GROWERS ARE ROB
WHICH WITH THE- COUCH EITHER
THEM. A MISTER MODERATOR ON THE
LINE OR READY TO. CHIME IN.
COULD YOU STATE YOUR AND YOUR
NAME. CALLER SUPERSTR ZERO.
MICHAEL RATIGAN. OFFER NOT
THERE'S I DON'T HAVE THOSE
PEOPLE ON THE PHONE AT THIS
TIME MISTER IF THEY IF THEY DO
TIME AND WILL GIVE THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY SO IF THERE'S
ANYONE. IN THE ROOM DOESN'T
OFFER. TO AB TWENTY FORTY THREE
IF NOT WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE
LINE JUST FOR NAME AFFILIATION
AND OPPOSITION POSITION SO WE
CAN GO AHEAD AND GO TO THE
PHONES AND IF MR MILLER MUTRIE
SHOW UP ON THE PHONES WILL GIVE
THEM THE OPPORTUNITY. TO
TESTIFY. MORE TEAM HERE ARE
GREAT THE CUTTER. START WITH LA
PROGRAMMERS IMAGE WE HAVE PHONE
ISSUES THERE BROUGH TREAT
CHAMBER POSE MUCH AND THEN I'LL
LOT BY JOINING WITH GET
CONNECTED I'M NOT GOING TO
SPEAK AT THE MORE SPECIFIC ARE
THE MYSTERY MICHAEL. BUT BUT I
DID WANT TO SPEAK TO SOME OF
THE. CONCERNS WE HAVE WITH THIS
BILL. FIRST MAKE THEIR
OPPOSITION IS NOW ABOUT ANY
DESIRE TO NOT ADDRESS. DOCUMENT
THAT AB TWENTY POINT THREE THAT
HAVE BEEN CUT BY OUR- ARE
ALREADY SOMETHING THAT- OSHA
CAN CITE THE PLAYERS FOR- AT
THE BACKGROUND ON THE AYE AYE
PP L. OF PREVENTION PROGRAMS
REQUIRE PLAYERS TO ADAPT TO
THE- IT. YOU HAVE TO DO THE
WORK WHAT COLLEGES. TALKING
MAKE CLEAR TO EMPLOY. THAT YOU
CAN GET PUT TO WORK BY HOW DO
YOU TWITTER THAT BUT HERE'S HOW.
SO IF HELLO CAN TO COME TO WORK
BY AND BE EMPLOYER IN IDEA HAD
NOT MODIFY THEIR I KEEP THE-
HAS NOT. ADDRESS IT VIA
APPROPRIATE PRACTICE AND
POLICIES TRAINING. THAT THEY
CAN BE CITED CREDIT ACTIVE I
PIECE OF THE THERE'S ALREADY IN
THE COURSE LEVER HERE THAT.
FLAG HE TO GET. OUT AT TO KNOW
PUTTING BAD RIGHT. WE ARE CLOSE
TO THOSE DOCTORS THAT ARE. I
WOULD THE COLLEGE OF THAT HELPS.
SOME OF THEM. THEY WERE SHE
TRIED TO WITH USED. AND IT
CREDIT THAT BUT OUR CONCERN
HERE AT THE THAT BUT IT IS
RUSHED TO QUIT PROFIT BEGIN
MEANT COSTED WORK ON. ADOPTING
OF THE- I AS WHICH ABOUT HERE
THE LABOR CODE. GREAT EAGLE.
ABOUT AND I MAY OUT THE DAY
ACTUALLY AGREE WITH YA THE CUT
PATCHWORK REGULATION ISN'T HOW
LOW AND STATE AND ALL OF THE
LEVEL. BUT IT'S NOT CLEAR TO ME
THAT THE LEGISLATION YEAH THE.
ADS BY. BEATING A LABOR CODE
PROVISION WHICH- WOULD BE CROSS
REFERENCE A WHAT IS NOT. I I'VE
GOTTEN DOCUMENT BUDGET CAR LEVY
CHAIN WITH THAT AND THEN WE
HAVE THE BEST OF AMERICAN
REGULATION WHICH- I DID. BREAK
THE SOME OTHER. BUT BUT PART OF
THE PARKING REGULATION BELT.
YOU KNOW IT IT PROBLEM BECAUSE
THE WILD BY MERGING THE BILL'S
REPORT. MARKET YOU RACK WHICH
WE ALL. LAST YEAR. WHAT CREATED
IN ABOUT HERE. PAGE THE
STANDARD BOARD IN ALL. TOGETHER
ALL THE DOLLARS DIFFERENT LOTS
OF PROBLEMS THEY'RE AND IN YEAH
IT DIDN'T WORK DIDN'T REALLY
KNOW WHAT DO. AND I WOULD HATE
FOR IT COULD. DOCUMENT
REGULATED HEALTH SHAPE CARE.
DOT THE- DIFFICULT AREA OF MY
THAT WHAT SO WHAT MOTIVATED AT
MY WILL GET ON I'LL TRY TO GET
YOU COULD GO. TO OUR GOAL IS TO
THAT WE HAVE MEANT FILL OUT
TIME TO DO THE A READ RIGHT
ASIAN. UNDERSTAND WE MUST MOVE
QUICK BUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE HAVE TO DO ALRIGHT BUT THAT
SEPARATE DEADLINE ARE OFF THE
WORD THAT HE WON. IN OUR VIEW
OF BACK IN A CALLOW. **** INTO.
A THAT WITH WEEKS WILL. LET YOU.
LOCATION I'M NOT OUT THERE FOR
MY THANK. YOU IF THE- IT'S
GONNA LINE ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
ENDEMIC CHALLENGE- AND THAT'S
HAPPENING ALL OVER CALIFORNIA-
VISUAL BASIS AS HAPPENING ON A
REGIONAL BASIS BECAUSE COUNTY
BY COUNTY THE REQUIREMENTS VERY
DIFFERENT. A WIDE GUIDELINE.
THAT WHAT I'LL PREEMPT COUNTIES
WE HAVE ONE DOCUMENT THAT WOULD
BE A WONDERFUL THING ABSOLUTE
THAT WHAT YOU HAVE THIS. IS
STANDARD THOSE LOCKED IN THE
REGULATORY PROCESS DOES NOT
SUBJECT TO CHANGE. THE QUICKLY
RECENTLY NOW MADE IN COUNCIL
WITH FEDERAL COUNTY OTHER OTHER
KIND. THAT CREATES GREAT
CONFUSION IN THE WORKPLACE AND
DOESN'T RESULT THE WORKER
SAFETY OMINOUS- AS ROB POINTED
OUT THE AYE AYE KEEPING PROCESS
IS ALREADY THERE. DOES ARE
WORKERS ARE GROWERS ARE ACT
POLICE UPDATING THEIR I USED TO
KEEP WORKERS SAFEST. VERY MUCH
SUPPORT THE TEN OF THE BILL WE
ARE CONCERNED THAT IF YOU A-
STANDARD THAT IS A LOT IN. THE
BAND DOESN'T PRE COUNTIES YOU
CAN TO HAVE ALL THE DOCUMENTS
ARE GOING TO PROBLEMS. KEEP IN
MIND THAT GUIDELINES IN PLACE
RIGHT NOW. BASED ON THE STATE
THAT THEY'RE SUBJECT TO ENGINE
TUITION WITH. THAT MEANS LEARN
MORE THE VIRUSES WE LEARN ABOUT
HOW IT SPREAD THE GUIDE. AND
NOT A GOOD THING WE WANT TO
KEEP OUR WERE PLAY. WHAT THE
SENATE. A LOT CHANGE. SCIENCE
AND THE RIVER FROM WE WOULD
SUPPORT THOUGH IF THERE WAS A
GUY IN PLACE THAT WAS PRINTABLE
TO HISTORICAL STATE LIKE NINE
THE DOCTORS DISCUSS IT IS BOB
THAT WOULD BE A ONE OF THING
AGAIN WE SUPPORT AND HAPPY
PROPOSES THAT TRAPPED BUT WE
VERY MUCH FOR THE WORKING THE
AUTHORED MISTER TO THE
COMMITTEE THE BILL WOULD. HOW
MUCH. WE WANT. IF NOT OF CAN GO
TO THE PHONES MODERATE ANYONE
OFFICE. TO TWENTY FORTY THREE.
THANK YOU FOR POSITION IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL IN THE
PRESS ONE AND THEN THE ZERO. OR
GO FOR THE LINE OF FIVE SIX
FIVE FIVE SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE
OF THE GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE AT THIS IS
MATTHEW WELL. WITHOUT WESTERN
GROWERS ASSOCIATION AND WE BUT
A CLOSER LOOK AT THAT POSITION
ON THE BILL. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. YOU HAVE A FEW MORE
PARTICIPANTS IN Q. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE.
FIVE FOUR ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU A GOOD
AFTERNOON THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE A BRIGHT LITTLE THE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION. AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. TWENTY THREE ONE
FOR THE COMMENDED FOR THE
REASONS STATED BY MR MILLER
MISTER METRIC THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NINE FIVE FOUR TO FIVE
FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
KAREN NUMBERS TO CHECK ON CHAIR
WITH AGRICULTURAL CONTROL OF
CALIFORNIA THE RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION UNLESS AMENDED YEAH.
THANK YOU. YOU KNOW NO THE
LINES IN Q. AT THIS TIME
ALRIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH I'M
WITH BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY FRIENDS BECAUSE-
MOTIONS. AND AMERICAN DOLLARS
SECOND BY SOME RECORD ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS ON A
THANK YOU AS A MEMBER WITH US
FOR BRING THIS BILL FORWARD AT
THE IN A SHORT. DONE WITH OUR
STAFF. IS ALL HER STAFF IS MUCH
APPRECIATED I KNOW THERE'S A
LOT MORE WORK TO DO. CONFIDENT
THAT YOU'LL BE ABLE TO SHEPHERD
THE PROCESS EFFECTIVELY SO WITH
THAT WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
TABLE TO PASS. APPROPRIATIONS
MAY BE KEPT ON THE VOTE PLEASE
CLOSING HER FOR SORRY SERVICE
LIKE TO CLOSE- RESPECTFULLY.
WHEN I VOTE SHOP. THANK YOU.
OKAY MOST PASSED TO PROVIDE
KALRA HI KALRA HI FLORA NO
FLORA NO CARILLO. CREEL I DEEP.
GONZALEZ INSULTS SIGH JONES
SAWYER. JONES SAWYER AYE RIVAS.
RIVAS I. THAT WASN'T CONFUSING
THREE OF US WAS AYE ON ROBERT
REDUCES BILL EXCELLENT THE BILL.
WE'LL GET OUT ON ITS WAY
APPROPRIATIONS AND WILL KEEP
THE ROLE OPEN FOR SUMMER DEEP.
OF AND GO ON NOW TO ITEM SEVEN
AB TWO NINE NINE NINE REMEMBER
EVAN LOW. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- THIS BILL IS
ON BEREAVEMENT LEAVE- THIS IS
FOR UNPAID. ACTUALLY QUITE
SHOCKING THAT WE DON'T ALREADY
HAVE THIS ON THE BOOKS- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. THANK
YOU AND- LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE.
ONE WITNESSES FOR RICO
YOSHIHARA WHO WILL BE
TESTIFYING. BY PHONE AND SO
MISTER STARR IS THERE WE CAN GO
AHEAD AND START WITH THAT TWO
MINUTES PLEASE. AFTER CARE
MEMBERS MARIE GREER SHE HEART
WITH THE CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT
LAWYERS ASSOCIATION I FIRST
WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOW FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD WILD. INTRODUCED BEFORE
WE WERE CUT IN CRISIS. ARE
RELEVANT NOW. IN THE END I WERE
RETURNED FOR I TO DEAL WHAT THE
FAMILY MEMBER WHO HAVE PASSED
AWAY BECAUSE OF THE VIRUS. AND
LET'S JUST OUT I THINK MOST THE
PRICE. NO WORRIES THEY
PROTECTIONS UNDER LAW. DOES
SEEM NONSENSICAL THAT OUR LAWS
DO ALLOW WORKERS TO TAKE LEAD
TO CARE FOR FAMILY MEMBERS BUT
THAT'S NOT THE ONLY MEMBER
PASSES AWAY THEIR RIGHT TO
PROTECT AND THEN. IMMEDIATELY
RIGHT. REALLY HARD. TO HEAR
FROM YOU ARE NOT ONLY DEALING
WITH. CLOSE FAMILY MEMBER BUT
ARE ALSO NOW DEALING WITH THE
LOSS OF THEIR JOB. THE FOR
EXAMPLE WHAT. BIRDS THAT HELP
WORK DRIVE. I SHOP COMPANY
RESULT LOST HER BECAUSE SHE
TOOK A OFF TO ATTEND HER
FATHERS ALL. ACTUALLY PROVED IT
WE GOT BUT WHILE SHE THOUGHT OF
HOW AT FUNERAL HER SUPERVISOR
OF CALLED HER AND TOLD HER SHE
NEEDED TO COME BACK TO WORK.
WITH OF TOWN SHE DID NOT COME
BACK AND HER SUPERVISOR ENDED
UP TERMINATING HER. I'M IN
ANOTHER CASE ONE OF OUR MEMBERS
GOT A CALL FROM A NEW THAT HE
WAS TAKING BABY BONDING LEAVE
AND THAT. PLAY HE CALLED AND
ASKED IF HE WAS ABLE TO. THE
BONDING LEAD TO DO WITH A LOT
OF THE DAY. BUT IN. THE THERE
WAS NO. THAT WE DO WHAT BEFORE
WE'D LIKE TO BELIEVE THAT. AND
WILL DO YOU THE SENATE RIGHT
THING AND ALLOW WORKERS THAT.
ARE IF THEY DO THE- MEMBER. BUT
WE KNOW FROM THE WORKERS WE'VE
HEARD. THERE ARE EMPLOYER. WE
WANT. TO UNDER. AND IT IS THAT
IS THAT THAT WE WILL WAIT AND
I'M WHO DON'T HAVE TO THAT
WE'VE THROUGH THERE AND- OR A
FEW AGO THE LET THAT PROVIDE
TEN DAY ON LEAVE AND WE HAVE NO
HEARD OF ANY ISSUES WITH THEM.
BOB THAT WE SHOULD FOLLOW. HOT
WORKERS AND TAKE IT TO GRIEVE
THEIR LOSS WHEN THEY NEED IT
THE FOR ALL THE DOING OF WE
STRONGLY URGES THE- THANK YOU.
ANYONE PART OF THE TWO NINE
NINE. IF NOT MISS MODERATE ON
AB TWENTY NINE NINETY NINE
ANYONE ON THE PHONES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU YOU ARE IN SUPPORT ME
PRESS ONE ZERO WELCOME TO A
LINE FIVE FIVE. FOUR ONE FIVE
FIVE FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
JUST TENDER ON BEHALF F EQUAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATES AND THE
STRONGER CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES
NETWORK IN STRONG SUPPORT. Q.
FIND FIVE SEVEN ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN FIVE SEVENTY ONE.
PERFECT NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
FIND FIVE SEVEN SEVEN FIVE
SEVENTY SEVEN YEAR OLD. BEAU
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. I AM TO
FIVE SIXTY EIGHT FIVE SIX EIGHT
YOUR LINE OF OPEN. FIVE SIX
EIGHT YOU MAY SPEAK. YOUR
DEVICE MIGHT BE ON MUTE. WE'LL
GO TO LINE FIVE EIGHT FOUR FIVE
EIGHT FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
JACKIE TURN ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS THE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
YEAH. A FEW MORE AND Q. AT THIS
TIME. OR LINE. FIVE FORTY SEVEN
FIVE FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. CAN YOU GO CHECK THE
UNITED PUBLIC EMPLOYEES AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. FIVE EIGHTY
THREE FIVE EIGHT THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. OUR WATER
CALIFORNIA WORK AND FAMILY
COALITION AND THE COURT. THANK
YOU. AND FIVE SIXTY EIGHT FIVE
SIX EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MARK. HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT ARE
YOU THERE. ABOUT. SO WE'RE TOLD
SANTA CLARA COUNTY WHICH THAT
COALITION AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. I'M FIVE EIGHT FIVE
FIVE EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WHICH DUGGAR THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND
FIVE SIX ONE FIVE SIXTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH JENNY
GARY ON BEHALF OF THE DELAYED
AT WORK IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU KNOW FOR
THEIR LINES IN Q. AT THIS TIME
OKAY THANK YOU- IN OPPOSITION
WE DO HAVE ONE WITNESS- BRAND
ADDING REPRESENTING CHAMBERS
STRIVING THE MOST MEMBERS THAT
I CAN HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND FOR WE
ARE TO THE BILL. WE'RE
CERTAINLY SYMPATHETIC.
SITUATION INVOLVING WORKERS WHO
NEED TIME OFF WORK- TO ATTEND
TO A DEATH OF A FAMILY MEMBER
WELL WE HAVE CONCERNS WITH IS
THE APPROACH TAKEN IN THIS BILL
WHICH IS A NEW SCANDAL A
SECTION OF THE- CODE THAT HAS A
GREEN. AND EIGHT WE HAVE CAN.
WHICH TEN DAY MANDATE IS MUCH
MORE SIGNIFICANT THAN PRIOR
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS THAT HAVE
BEEN EITHER THREE OR FOUR DAYS-
AND WE ARE CONCERNED AGAIN WITH
THIS BRAND NEW. SECTION THE
LABOR CODE- STANDALONE SEXUALLY
RECORD WITH A PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION- WE THINK IS GOING TO
LEAD TO FURTHER COSTLY
LITIGATION- AND WHAT WE'RE- AS
A MINISTER. OFFICE THAT
WHATEVER THE PRIVATE RIDE BACK.
THERE WAS A CHANGE IN APPROACH
SO THE PRIMARY ELECTION IS
STILL THE BILL. I WON ALL
MENTION THE- SOME MUCH IN THIS
IS ON AN ORGAN STATUTE- AN
ORGAN DID ENACT A TEN DAY. BUT
LEAVE STATUTES THEY DID IT IN A
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT MANNER
THEY BUILT ON TO THEIR ORGAN
FAMILY MEDICAL LEAVE ACT. SO IT
IT COUNTS AS PART OF TWELVE
WEEKS OF UNPAID LEAVE THAT
EMPLOYERS ALL RIGHT AFTER
PROVIDE UNDER THAT. A STATE LAW
THAT'S A LOT PLACE ONLY TWO
THIRDS OF A CERTAIN SIZE
EMPLOYERS WITH TWENTY FIVE OR
MORE EMPLOYEES. BEEN EMPLOYED
FOR HUNDRED. IS SO THE- SAID
SHOULD FOLLOW ORGANS LEAD. WE
AGREE IF WE'RE GONNA DO THIS IN
CALIFORNIA WE SHOULD PUT IT
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA FAMILY
RIGHTS ACT. RATHER THAN IN THE
LABOR CODE. WITH THE YOU KNOW.
STATE ALONE. A REQUIREMENT IN A
BRAND NEW PRIME OF ACTION-
WE'VE HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH
OTHERS BUZZ. ABOUT MOVING THAT
INTO THE FOR AND WE LOOK FOR.
THOSE CAUGHT. AS FOR THE- THANK
YOU. SIR THE ROOM AND AFTER.
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE AS
MODERATOR- IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY NINE NINETY NINE. SO
PRESS ONE ZERO WE'LL GO TO LINE
FIVE EIGHTY ONE FIVE EIGHT ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. KIM KNOWN AS-
ON BEHALF OF ASSOCIATED
BUILDERS AND CONTRACTORS
NORTHERN HELP CHAPTER IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
FIND FIVE EIGHTY TWO FIVE EIGHT
TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. EIGHT
POINT OF FINDING THE FAMILY
BUSINESS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY IS RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED AND WHAT A LINER
COMMENTS WITH THE SINISTER
ADDING. THANK YOU. NINE FIVE
FIVE FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. A
COUPLE IN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION ALSO ABOUT.
THANK YOU. NINE FIVE FOUR NINE
FIVE FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON YOUR-
FORMULATED FOOD PRODUCERS IN
OPPOSITION ALIGN OUR COMMENTS
WITH THE CAL CHAMBER THANK YOU
THANK YOU. FIND THE NINE FIVE
EIGHT NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DON'T GET BILLS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION LIKE
TO ALIGN HER COMMENTS WITHOUT A
CAP CHAMBER THANK YOU THINK.
FIND. FOUR OH SEVEN FOUR ZERO
SEVEN. HI THIS IS WHAT HE SAID
SEE WHAT THE CALIFORNIA GROCERS
ASSOCIATION WE ALSO ECHO THE
CONCERN FROM THE CHAMBER IN OUR
IN EVERITT ARE IN OUR AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU. LINE FIVE EIGHTY
SEVEN FIVE EIGHT SEVEN YOUR
LINE OF THE- THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS J. CONSTRUCTOR
HERE ON BEHALF OF THAT SHE BACK
EXCEPT INSURANCE AUTHORITY ALSO
LIKE TO ALIGN ARE. COMMON WITH
OF THE MISTER AT BANK
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NINE FIVE
EIGHTY FIVE EIGHT ZERO REALIZE
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON KATIE
HANSON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATIONWE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED. THANK YOU.
TWO ELEVEN LINE TWO ONE ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES NICOLE
RIGHT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION ALL CLEAR
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE FOR THE
REASONS STATED ON THE RECORD
AND CAL CHAMBER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND FIVE NINETY FIVE
NINE YOUR LINE OF BOTH. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS
MELANIE GRIFFITH BUT THE
CALIFORNIA BANKERS AT THAT AGE
AND ALSO IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION FOR THE READER. THAT
THANK YOU. OUR FINAL LINE IN Q.
RIGHT NOW IS FIVE FOUR ZERO
FIVE FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GERMAN THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS BY A BOTTLE
OF THE CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION AND RESPECT
OPPOSITION FOR THE REASONS
STATED BY MR BACK. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. FIND FIVE SIXTY FIVE
FIVE SIX FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SEC. HI FIVE SIX FIVE VERY ARE
YOU THERE. NO NO FOR THE LINE
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU. ONTHIS BRING
THIS ONE BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
AND THE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
OUR MOTIONS FROM ANY OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SERVER
GONZALEZ. THANK YOU- AND I MAKE
MY- I SALUTE SECOND WOULD. I'M
GLAD YOU TOOK THIS APPROACH IN
THE NEIGHBORHOOD WHERE I
BELIEVE THEY WERE PROTECTION.
ALONG YEAH RIGHT BUT ONE IN AND-
YEAH A LOT OF IDEAS WE NOW
ACCEPTED THAT. CERTAIN JOBS
YOUR HAS MA'AM THAT PROTECTION
IS LESS IMPORTANT IS JUST. OUR
RIGHT I IF YOU HAVE A CHILD
DIVING PARENT DIE IN AND YOU
HAPPEN TO HAVE AN PLAYER WITH
WITH TEN EMPLOYEES AT IT THAT.
IS THE NEED TO GRIEVE AND SO.
APPROACH AND LOOK FORWARD TO
HOPEFULLY SEE. ANY OTHER OR
COMMENTS. RIGHT L. SMITH THANK
YOU THIS SUMMER LOW I DO THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT I THINK AS WAS
POINTED OUT THERE'S DEFINITELY
A LOT OF THINGS THAT WE WE'VE
NEEDED TO BE WORKED OUT FOR A
LONG TIME PRICES IN A LOT OF
FOR FRANK. WE DO HAVE- CUSTOMER
CARILLO. SEVERAL LOW ANY
CLOSING COMMENTS. YES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- COMMITTEE MEMBERS- I
SEE ALL OF YOU ARE ON THIS DIET
TO- IN WORKING WITH YOU I KNOW
HOW GREAT HEART AND SYMPATHY
AND PASSION WITH RESPECT TO
THESE THAT WE REPRESENT AND THE
FACT THAT YOU'VE HEARD FROM THE
OPPOSITE IN THIS IS THAT THE
ENGINE. A HAS A- WERE FROM.
AMBER JOE KILLER FOR UNPAID FOR
EVEN LEAVE UNDERPAID LET ME
JUST REPEAT THAT AGAIN THIS IS
FOR ON PAID LEAVE TO CARE FOR.
OF THE ONE YOU ONLY HAVE ONE
SHOT THIS IS A LIFE TO LIVE
ONCE. AND WE GET WE ARE NOT
ALLOWING FOR UNPAID LEAVE AND
YET THIS IS GOING TO BE
DISTINGUISHED AT A JOB KILLER
THAT'S RIDICULOUS AND BACK
MEMBERS I PERSONALLY THINK THAT
SHOULD BE STRONGER THE SHOULD
BE PAID LEAVE. BUT IN FACT I
ALSO RECOGNIZE THE CHALLENGES
THAT EXIST WITHIN IS THIS AN
WITH AN EXACT AND SO WE WANT TO
TAKE A DELIBERATE OF APPROACH
TO BE MY GOAL OF THE INCREASED.
CHALLENGE OF SMALL BUSINESS AND
BIG BUSINESS A LIGHT. BUT THIS
IS DONE IN A VERY GENUINE
EFFORT TO SAY WE RECOGNIZE THE
TOWN IS. THOSE EVERY DAY
CALIFORNIA AND WE'VE ALL BEEN
THERE IF YOU READ THE BILL IT
UTILIZE I MEAN THE IT'S NOT
JUST BREVET LEAVE ON. TO GO TO.
BUT THERE ARE OTHER ASSOCIATED
CHALLENGES THAT EXIST TO TAKING
CARE OF THE LOVED ONES OF THEIR
PROPERTIES OF THE OTHER LEGAL
FINANCIAL CHALLENGES. TO JUST
TAKE CARE OF YOUR OWN WELLNESS.
SO THIS AGAIN MEMBERS IS UNPAID.
AGAIN UNDERPAID HOW IS THIS JOB
OF IT SHOOT IF IT'S GOING TO BE
A JOB KILLER UNPAID E SHOULD
JUST MAKE IT PAID. THIS IS WHY
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR. REALLY LOOK
AT THE SPECIFIC AND JUST TAKE A
PAUSE AND LISTEN TO THE
ARGUMENTS THAT ARE BEING MADE.
AND SAYING. I CAN'T BELIEVE
THIS IS ACTUALLY NOT CALIFORNIA
LAW THIS IS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HOW DO WE NOT HAVE.
ON AID LEAVE. THE ALLOWED FOR.
WORKERS SO AGAIN A TO THIS
COMMITTEE I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE. YOUR CONSIDERATION
AND RESPECT THAT PRIVATE DON'T
GET ME STARTED ON IT'S A
SPONTANEOUS COMMITTEE MINUTES
NOW- BUT- THE- FUN OF BURN OUT
NO WILL CALL VOTE PLEASE. THE
MOTION IS. XIN KALRA FIVE KALRA
HI FLORA FLORA NO CARILLO CREO
I DEEP NOT VOTING DEEP NOT
VOTING GONZALEZ AND SALAS I
JONES. JONES SAWYER AYE RIVAS
RIVAS BY RIGHT THAT'S BEEN
PASSED TO HER APPROPRIATIONS
THANK YOU SOME MEMBER LOW. NEXT
ITEM EIGHT AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY
EIGHT. ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURKE.
THANK YOU MISTER WITHOUT
WORKING YEAH THANK PARRIS OF
IT'S NOT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO START
MAKING A COMMITTEE. FOR WHAT
OFFICE ON BILL AND I'M
COMMITTED TO WORKING SPONSORED
TO CLARIFY WHO THE EMPLOYER IS
FOR THE PURPOSE OF FILE THE
WAGE CLAIM. AB SIX FIFTY
CONSERVE INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
I AM PROTECT DOMESTIC WORKERS
FROM BEING FORCED TO WORK IN
HAZARDOUS CONDITIONS LIKE
WILDFIRES. LAUGHTER DURING THE
DESTRUCTIVE WILD SEASON WE
THOUGHT MEDIA ACCOUNTS AND
ALARMING VIDEOS OF DOMESTIC
WORKERS RUNNING INTO HOMES AND
THAT HAVE BEEN EVACUATED. WE'RE
SURROUNDED BY SMOKE TOXIC AIR
AND- SOME OF THESE WORKERS
STATED THAT THEY DID SO BECAUSE
THEY FEAR THAT THEY WOULD THREE
OUT TELL YOU EVEN IF THEY DID
NOT SHOW UP FOR WORK. AB TWENTY
FIFTY EIGHT ALLEVIATE THAT
FEAR. BY EXPANDING EXISTING
PROTECTIONS AGAINST EMPLOYER
RETALIATION FOR REFUSING TO
WILL AND HAZARDOUS CONDITIONS
TODAY THAT'S SUPER. THIS IS THE
ACTION THAT ALREADY ESTABLISHED
AND LABOR CODE FOR MANY WORKERS
AND IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT THIS
PROTECTION ALWAYS. EXTENDED TO
DOMESTIC FOR. FOR THEM AB
TWENTY SIX FIFTY EIGHT ALSO
GOES ONE STEP FURTHER BY STATE.
ANY PERSON RECEIVING NOTICE TO
THAT AREA. WHO WILLINGLY AND
KNOWINGLY DIRECTS AN EMPLOYEE
TO REMAIN IN OUR ENTER AN AREA
CLOSE TO THE MENACE TO PUBLIC
HEALTH OR SAFETY SHALL BE
GUILTY OF A MISDEMEANOR. MATT
YEAH REAR STILL GOING A
WILDFIRE IN OUR STATE CONTINUES
TO LINGER DOMESTIC WORKERS ARE
AMONG MANY THINGS AMONG MANY
THINGS INCLUDE CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS KEEPERS CARE GIVERS
THEY ARE NOT PART OF OUR LIVES
AND WORTHY OF THE SAME
PROTECTIONS PROVIDED TO
EVERYONE. BUT THAT ARE THE
THANK YOU. ONE WITNESS FOR
TRAINS COULD A LARA'S OFF
MICHAEL MY TO IF YOU'RE ON THE
LINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES CAN
INSURE KALRA PLACED HER FLORA
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MIKE
MARTINEZ SENIOR DEPUTY
COMMISSIONER HERE ON BEHALF OF.
CURRENT COMMISSIONER RICARDO
LARA AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER LOTTE IS PROUD TO
BE THE SPONSOR OF AB TWENTY SIX
FIFTY EIGHT AND FIRST LIKE TO
THANK. ASSEMBLYMEMBER FOR
LEADERS. IN THIS CONSUMER
PROTECTION MEASURE.
COMMISSIONER LARA. COUNTERING
MEASURE BECAUSE IT WILL HELP
PROVIDE FAIRNESS AND EQUITY IN
THE WORKPLACE. FOR MANY HARD
WORKING INDIVIDUALS MANY OF
WHOM ARE IMMIGRANTS. ON ENGLISH
SPEAKERS AND FROM COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR. THE TWENTY SIX FIFTY
EIGHT IS NEEDED NOW TO EXTEND
TO CRITICAL WORKPLACE
PROTECTIONS TO THIS VULNERABLE
SECTORS WORK BEFORE WE FACE NEW
ADDITIONAL THE THIRTY WILD. OR
OTHER PUBLIC. OPEN SURE
DOMESTIC WORKERS IN THE STATE
ARE PROTECTED WITH CLEAR
STATUTORY PROTECTIONS FROM
EMPLOYER RETALIATION AND FROM
WORKING IN HAZARDOUS CONDITIONS.
WITH THAT SAID BUCKLEY REQUEST
DRIVE VOTE ON THIS MEASURE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE IN THE ROOM
IN SUPPORT OF AB IS ASSOCIATED.
NOT A WILL MISS MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY EIGHT.
TO SUPPORT OF THIS BILL PRESS
ONE THEM ZERO PLEASE. THE WINDS
IN QUEUE LINED FIVE SIX THREE
THE LINE IS OPEN FIVE SIXTY
THREE. YOU JUST PRESS THE
BUTTON THE NUMBERS FIVE SIX
THREE OH FIVE SIX THREE YOU'RE
STILL THERE. I'M BACK TO SQUARE
FIVE. NINE FIVE FOUR SEVEN FIVE
FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
WITH. THE END OF THE CHAIR OF
ON BEHALF OF THE UNITED PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES AND THE- WORKERS OF
AMERICA THIS TIME BOTH IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MEGAN LINE
FIVE SIX THREE DID YOU WANT TO
SPEAK TO YOUR POSITION. YEAH
THANK YOU MICHELLE GUILD FROM
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
KNOW NO OTHER LINES IN Q. AT
THIS TIME. I THINK YOU IS THERE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION WE DON'T
HAVE ANYONE IDENTIFIED TO
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION BUT IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN THE ROOM. NOT
POSITION. A MISTER MODERATOR
ANYONE ALL PHONE LINES IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY SIX
FIFTY EIGHT. YOUR POSITION AS
AN OPPOSITION OFTHIS BILL IN A
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
MORNING Q. AT THIS TIME MISTER
CHAIR PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH OKAY LET'S BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE WE DO
HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY
SURE FLORA SECONDED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARILLO. ALL
RIGHT NO FURTHER COMMENT THEN.
THANK YOU SUMMER BURKE ALSO
WANT TO THANK INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER LARA FOR BRING
THIS BILL TO YOU BRING FOR YOU
BRING A FOR TO US LIKE IT MAKE
ANY CLOSING COMMENTS. AND I.
KNOW ROLL CALL THE BILL PLEASE.
MOTION IS TO APPROPRIATE KALRA
FIVE KALRA HI FLORA FLORA I
CARILLO CARILLO I DEEP. DEEP
AYE GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER HI RIVAS
RIVAS HI RIGHT WAS OUT THANK
YOU. ITEM NINE A. B. TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY FIVE. REMEMBER
PATRICK O'DONNELL. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR. THE MOTION
AND A SECOND SIR GONZALEZ MOVES
IT SUMMER CARILLO SECONDS.
SURROGATE O'DONNELL PLEASE
CONTINUE I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY FIVE POINTS PUBLIC
WORKS TO INCLUDE CHARTER SCHOOL
FACILITY PROJECTS RECEIVE
FUNDING THROUGH CONFLICT
REVENUE. FOR THAT INDIVIDUALS
WHO WORK ON THESE PROJECTS
RECEIVE PREVAILING WAGE AND
ALLOW THEM TO BENEFIT FROM
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS. KHAN
BUT REVENUE BOND FINANCING IS
COORDINATED BY A PUBLIC ENTITY.
THE STATE LOSES REVENUE LAW ON
THESE BONDS AS INVESTORS DO NOT
PAY TAXES INTERN THE BORROWER
RECEIVES A LOWER INTEREST RATE.
UNDER EXISTING LAW CHARTER
SCHOOL BELIEVES THAT ENDED BY
STATE EDUCATION BONDS ARE
RECALL TO COMPLY WITH
PREVAILING WAGE AND HIGHER. AND
HIGHER CONSTRUCTION STANDARDS
UNDER THE ACT. PROJECT THAT ARE
FUNDED WITH KAT REVENUE BONDS
DO NOT. WE MUST ENSURE THAT
THOSE WORKING ON OUR SCHOOL
FACILITIES ARE SKILLED AND
QUALIFIED. THIS BILL SPONSORED
BY THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL. IN
THE VIDEO ROOM- IS JEREMY SMITH
WITH THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL I
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE MISTER
CHAIR. THANKS THANK YOU NUMBER
O'DONNELL IN THE WITNESS OF
VIDEO CONFERENCING ROOM AS-
MENTIONED YEAH GERMANY SMITH.
WITH THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
WENT OVER THE VIDEOS READY TO
GO.
AB. ROOM. WILL MOVE. MAYBE
IT WOULD. CAN YOU GUYS HEAR ME
WE CAN HEAR YOU TO FOLLOW IF I
GO AHEAD IN BEGIN THAT BE GREAT
SURE I DIDN'T KNOW IF THAT
VIDEO AT THE START I APOLOGIZE
FOR THE FACT DEVOID OF EVERY
GO. AHEAD OKAY GOOD GOOD AT
DOING MUCH TO BE ABLE TO SEE ME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF GERMANS MET THEIR BEHALF OF
THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL THE
SPONSORS OF AB TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTY FIVE AS- MISTER
O'DONNELL. POINTED OUT THIS
BILL WOULD REQUIRE. CHARTER
SCHOOLS THAT RECEIVE PUBLIC
SUBSIDIES. IN THE FORM. BOND
FINANCING TO BE SUBJECT TO THE
PREVAILING. PREVAILING WAGE
LAW. I RECOGNIZE IN THE PUBLIC
FUNDS ARE BEING USED. AS THE
PROJECT. HI THIS TRACK WE
BELIEVE. CONFIDENCE BUILDING
TRAIN LOCAL WORK FORCE TO BUILD
THE SCHOOLS. AND TWENTY
FIFTEEN- ALREADY DID WHAT THIS
BILL DOES. IS GO DID YOU. A
WITH A- FIFTY. OUR THAT. WELL
THAT WILL SERVICE A I'M A
STIMULUS. DURING THIS PENDANT
RECESSION OF BUYING SHE THE
CHARGE SCHOOLS SURE THEY
BOLLAND. DECIDE TO PURSUE
FUNDING TO WITH IN THIS BILL
PER CAN WORKER WORKERS WITH
LITTLE WHERE IN THE FORM OF THE
PREVAILING WAGE- THAT WILL HELP
THE CONSTRUCTION WORKERS
WHETHER THE CURRENT RECESSION.
WE ALSO BELIEVE BY HIM YOU CAN
TRAIN WORKERS ON THESE
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS- WHICH
THE ONLY WAY TO HELP ENSURE
THAT CHARTER SCHOOL THE LOVERS
SHE SAVE MONEY BY HAD THEY'RE
PROD ON. BUDGET WITH YOUR
CHANGE AUCTION DELAYS. BASS
YOUR DIFFERENCE WORKERS THE PER
WAGE GRAD OF STAY APPROVED
PARTNERSHIP. THAT HIGH SKILL
AND CAUGHT. ON THE BACK AND
FIND WE- ANYTHING IN THIS
RECEPTION IN THIS RECESSION
WHAT EVERY DOLLAR OF TAXPAYER
MONEY NEEDS TO BE SPENT WISELY
AT TAXPAYERS WOULD WANT TO KNOW
CONSTRUCTION EIGHT MIDDLE CLASS.
WE ARE YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE ROOM IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY FIVE. GO IF
YOU WANT TO CALL ONE AT A TIME.
THE MICROPHONE. AND JUST STATE
NAME AFFILIATION AND YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL PLEASE MY
NAME IS CURTIS DAY I'M AN
ORGANIZER WITH PAINTERS AND
ALLIED TRADES DISTRICT COUNCIL
SIXTEEN AND I STAND WITH THE
BUILDINGS PART OF THIS. THANK
YOU. NOT SO IT'S ALL ON HIS OWN
MY NAME IS TANNER CAROL WOULD
JUST COUNCIL SIXTEEN
INTERNATIONAL PLAYERS UNION ON
THE SELLING OUT BY U. P. EIGHTY
AND I STAND WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES THANK YOU. WELL JUST
TORN DISTRICT COUNCIL SIXTEEN
APPRENTICESHIP I STAND WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES THANK YOU. MY
NAME IS DEBBIE STEVENS DISTRICT
COUNCIL SIXTEEN APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM I SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU FOR. WHERE'S MY
GREENLEE WOULD DISCUSS SIXTEEN
REVEREND PAIRS OF KNOWLEDGE
REYES I SUPPORT THE GLOBAL
DRUG- THANK YOU. HELLO MY
NAME'S CHUCK MAGGIE I'M A
DISTRICT COUNCIL SIXTEEN- PER.
I SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
OKAY. MISS MODERATE ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OF AB TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY FIVE. EXPRESS
YOURSELF ONE ZERO WE'LL GO
FIRST TO THE LINE OF FIVE
SEVENTY SEVEN FIVE SEVEN SEVEN
PLEASE GO UP. BUT HOW THE IS
THE THIRD WE ARE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. LINE SIX ZERO FIVE
FOUR SIX ZERO FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH OF THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC AFFAIRS COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. I AM SIX
ELEVEN SIX ONE ONE YOUR LINE UP
LOOK. THE CARE MEMBER CHRISTY
VALMONT CAP OF THE
INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD OF
BOILERMAKERS. UP STRONG SUPPORT
THE MEASURE THANK YOU. NINE SIX
OH SEVEN SIX OH SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD TO BROWN OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. FIND SIX ONE SIX
SIXTEEN OUT UNTIL. MICHAEL
YOUNG WITH THE WAY LABOR
SUPPORT GIVE. I HAVE NOT FIVE
NINETY FOUR OPEN. BLOCKING
OTHER THOUGHT ON A BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
BATTLE OF THE STATE BUILDING
TOWARD THE PORT THANK YOU. SIX
TEEN SIX ONE THREE AS OPEN.
JOHN YEARS WITH DISTRICT
COUNCIL SIXTEEN PLACES LOCAL
SIXTEEN TWENTY ONE WHERE WE
STAND WITH THE BUILDING TRADES
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. SIX
TWO SIX ZERO TO YOUR LINE OF.
ENTER MEREDITH PRESIDENT OF THE
NORTH. THANK YOU. FIND NINE ONE
FIVE NINE YOU OPEN YOUR MIND AS
OF. THAT OPERATE AGAINST
BUILDING TRICKS THANK YOU. DID
YOU YES AND I AM SAM CRANKY AND
THIS WILL SIX AND I WITH THE
BILL TRADES SUPPORT THANK YOU.
FIND SIX TWELVE. SIXTY TWO IS
OPEN. SHE MY NAME IS LENNY
WILKENS RIPS DISTRICT SIX.
LATER LOW ONCE BINDING WE CAN
WE THE BUILDINGS ARE. THANK
FIND FIVE FORTY SEVEN SEVEN
LINE OF OPEN ACTUALLY FOR A
MOMENT PLEASE. I FOR SEVEN NINE
AS A NOW. ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMITTEE WORK OF DISTRICT NINE
IN. THANK YOU. SIX ZERO THREE
SIX OR YEAR LAW IS OPEN. YOUR
TURN KATE ON HERE AT. THE
COUNCIL AND SUPPORT. GIVE. SIX
SIX SIX SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
REMEMBER ANA GONNA BE HALF THE
CAL STATE SO WHAT TRICKLE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S TO I CAL. BUT IT
CAN SHEET METAL WORKERS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY.
SEVEN SIX FIVE THANK YOU. FIND
I'VE NINE THREE FIVE TWENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. JEFF
BUSINESSMEN. SIX TWENTY ONE ARE
YOU THERE. TWO SIX ZERO NINE
SIX OH NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES MY WATER FROM A BUSINESS
REPRESENTATIVE FOR DISTRICT
COUNCIL SIXTEEN ALL FLOOR
LAYERS LOW TWELVE AND WE STAND
SOME POOR WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRICKS THANK YOU. YOU.
BY AND SIX TWENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN SIX TO SEVEN.
DISCONNECTED I APOLOGIZE SIX
ZERO EIGHT SIX AWAIT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI THIS CALDERON IN
THAT REPRESENT DISTRICT COUNCIL
SIXTEEN PAINTERS ALLIED TRADES
CARP ILLINOIS IN STOCK CARLIER
LOCAL TWELVE THEN WE ARE
SUPPORT WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES ON THE BILL. THANK SIX
FOURTEEN POINT ORDER LINE IS
OPEN. MISTER CHAIR MY NAME IS
BRAD DAVIS REPRESENTING
DISTRICT COUNCIL SIXTEEN
GLAZERS LOCAL SIXTEEN TWENTY
ONE AND WE STAND WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY FIFTY FIVE THANK YOU.
ONE TWO SIX TWELVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YEAH MY NAME IS THE
DISTRICT OFFICE SIXTEEN
PRINTERS LOCAL TO NINETY FOUR
AND WE STAND IN SUPPORT WITH
THE- THANK YOU. FIND FIVE FORTY
ONE FIVE FOUR ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WITH OUR HARD WORKING
PARTNERSHIPS LIKE WOULD NEED A
CONSTRUCTION CAREERS PROGRAM
FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH. THE WORK
AND I SEND AND- THANK YOU. FIND
SIX TWENTY THREE SIX TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BUT IT SIX TWENTY
THREE IN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS CARLOS FLORES AND
REPRESENTING DISTRICT COUNCIL
SIXTEEN- PAINTERS LOCAL THREE
SEVENTY SIX AND WE SPENT A
SUPPORT WITH BUILDING TRADES.
THANK YOU. SIX TWO ZERO SIX
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN. I'LL BE
HAPPY CALIFORNIA NEVADA ****
OPERATING ENGINEERS HAPPY TO BE
HERE TODAY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THIRTY THREE THEY'RE
ALL YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BRIAN
HOLD BUSINESS MANAGER OF IBEW
LOCAL FOUR TO EIGHT AND WE
STAND WITH THE STATE BILL
ENCOURAGED AND SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. YOU. IN CUBA SIX ONE
EIGHT SIX EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO YES YOUR ONLINE.
HELLO YES YOU'RE ON THE LINE.
OKAY MY NAME IS KIMBERLY ROBBIE
NUMBER IS A LOCAL FIVE FORTY
FIVE WHAT THE MAKER AND RECALL
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY. BUT YOU.
FINALLY IF THREE SIX THIRTY
FIVE PER LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME
IS STEVE. DISCOUNT SIXTEEN
FLOOR COVERS LOCAL UNION TWELVE
WE STICK WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
YOU THANK YOU ALL RIGHT NOW WE
CAN MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION I
BELIEVE ON THE PHONE WE HAVE
CARLOS MARQUEZ. REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOL
ASSOCIATION AND IF YOUR OFFLINE
GO AHEAD OF UP TO ITS- YOU.
PARK AT HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALTRAIN CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY FIVE.
WEALTHY FAMILY SUPPORTS BUT
PROPONENTS DAVID AND THAT
CHARTER SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION
FUNDING BE MARKET OF ALL. WE
FINALLY. RE THAT TWENTY SEVEN
TO KEEP. THAT DISTRICTS SCHOOL
THAT PAYMENT ARE WITHDRAWN
GENERAL OPERATING FUNDS THE
SAME FUND USED TO PAPER
CRITICAL STUDENT SERVICES
SALARIES GIVEN THE STATE'S
CHALLENGING SET OUT LOOK
FURTHER ENCOURAGEMENT ALREADY
STRAINED UP GET THE BILL IT. AT
THE TOP. REPORTER ON CAUGHT THE
BACK AT TWO EIGHT THE DON'T.
RESORT FOR CHARTER SCHOOLS AT A
TIME WHEN ALL SCHOOLS ARE
GRAPPLING WITH THAT THE TOLD
GET IN REQUIRE WELL ONLY TO A
GREATER ON SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
MAKE EQUITABLE AVAILABLE ORDERS
AS REQUIRED THIRTY NOT. ALREADY
CALLED TO IMPOSE A MORATORIUM
APART. EVEN IF. THIS BILL EACH
WERE CAUGHT STOP AND THINK. LOW
BONTA GRAPHICAL ACT TO CHART
SCHOOL PROGRAM LIKE THE CONDO
BOND THAT THE RELEASE VALVE ON
LOOK AT THE THAT THE CURRENTLY
OUT OF THE CHARTER SCHOOLS WE
ALSO ONE AT THE CARD BOND
PROGRAM. ALL PUBLIC. IN HOUSTON
IDENTICAL. YOUR THE- NO BECAUSE
THE STATE CORRECT. MACINNES
THEM OUT THE BIRTH IN SCHOOL
ANNUAL. AUTOMATIC GRAHAM IS
COST PROHIBITIVE WE WORRY THAT
SOME CHARTERS WILL COULD BUY
THE ON A PRIVATE MARKET WITHOUT
THE SAME RATE PA VETTING IN DO
GALA PROPER THAT YET THAT THEY
WERE. WHICH PROTECTS AGAIN
COMPLICATED INTEREST THE REST.
IN OF ALL. YET THEY WOULD TO
ENGAGE WITH THE AUTHOR EIGHT
MINUTES AND KAYLA YEAR AND HELP
YOU NOW BUT BREAK OVERHAUL TO
THE- BACK YET THEY IS HOPEFUL
THE LEGISLATURE WILL ALLOW SOME
TIME FOR CHARTER STEP ON
IMPLEMENTING AB FIFTY NO FIVE
BEFORE LETTING THE REQUIREMENTS
ARE FIRST. AND KEEP YOUR. IS
ANY. BOB. TEN MOVE ON THE PHONE
LINE ANYONE ON THE PHONE TO
OPPOSITION TO A BEACH SEVEN
FIVE MODERATOR. GIVE YOUR VISIT
AS AN OP. MY PRESS ONE ZERO
ALTHOUGH TO LINE OF SIX FOUR TO
SIX FORTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
HAVE A CAT SO CAL IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. CAN NO NO OTHERS IN
Q. AT THIS TIME OKAY THANK YOU.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS BY
SURE FOR. THANK YOU MISTER
O'DONNELL- GOOD TO SEE YOU I'M
JUST HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS
LAST REVIEWED ON SOMEONE WILL
IT IN IN PRINCIPLE ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF PREVAILING WAGE
AND HAVE BEEN- IN THE PAST AND
WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO BY AM
CONCERNED ABOUT. THIS
PARTICULAR BILL. SIXTEEN
THIRTEEN LAST YEAR THAT WAS
VETOED BY THE ADMINISTRATION IS
ADMINISTRATION. WHAT HAVE WE
DONE DIFFERENTLY AND TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY FIVE TO ADDRESS
THOSE CONCERNS- AT THIS POINT
NOT MUCH. OTHER THAN THEIR BEEN
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND SOME OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS GOING FORWARD I'M
SURE ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS. WILL
BE IVOLVED IN CONVERSATIONS-
TO CAUSE US TO MOVE. THIS BILL
FORWARD AGAIN THIS YEAR.
BECAUSE WE THINK WE'LL FIND
SUCCESS AT THE END OF THE ROAD
THIS YEAR OR LAST YEAR. YOU ARE
CORRECT WE DID. SAY THAT AND
YOU KNOW I DO THINK IN I CARL
IS KIND OF TOUCHED ON HAD
ANOTHER NOTE WRITTEN DOWN HERE
ABOUT YOU KNOW SOME OF THE
FUNDS. TO THE COST OF BUILDING
COMES OUT THE GENERAL FUND FOR
THE CHARTERS AND YOU KNOW RIGHT
NOW YOU KNOW IN IN. SITUATION
WE HAVE. THE COP THE BUILDING
RIGHT NOW- SEEMS. TO BE A
LITTLE BIT- CART BEFORE THE
HORSE. WHEN RIGHT NOW MY JUST
WE JUST WANTS TO OPEN THEIR
SCHOOLS BACK UP. SO IN
PRINCIPLE I AM VERY SURPRISED.
ME LAYING OFF THIS BILL TODAY.
BUT IT IS AN INTERESTING-
DILEMMA THAT WE- THAT WE HAVE
HERE. SO JUST AYE PROCEDURE
INTERESTING THANK. YOU I THINK.
WAS MADE. THEY WANT TO TAKE 20%
OF CONSTRUCTION WORKERS POCKET.
YES SEE IS REALLY AN EFFORT TO
PAY PAY LESS AND GET THE SAME
PROP ULTIMATELY MAYBE. MAYBE
BUT THE FACT THE MATTER IS THAT
WE HAVE A SKILLED TRAINED
WORKFORCE BUILDING. PUBLIC
BUILDINGS. PUBLIC SCHOOLS. THE
PRODUCTS ARE TYPICALLY MUCH
MORE BETTER COMPLETED ON TIME
AND UNDER BUDGET I THINK IS A
GOOD THING. EVERYBODY INCLUDING
FOR USE THAT MAKE UP TAKE I'M
NOT ARGUING ANY OF THAT. I GET
I MEAN I MEAN VERY FOR THE RAID
AND WHAT THEY'RE TRYING TO DO
AS FAR AS- YOU FOR FAMILY. IT
IN SKILLED TRADES FORCIBLE OF
THOSE THINGS AND UNDERSTAND.
THAT IS THE ONLY NOT CONCERNED.
BILL RIGHT. ONE OF MY POINTS IN
YOUR I THINK YOU IT DOESN'T
PAYING OUR OUR INSTRUCTIONAL ON
A JOHN PUBLIC JOB LESS THAT
THAT THE ARE TO MAKE. THANK YOU
THE CENTER. THANK YOU MISTER
O'DONNELL- I SUPPORTED YOUR
BILL LAST YEAR AB SIXTEEN
THIRTEEN- AND I PLAN ON
SUPPORTING THEM AB TWENTY SIX
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY FIVE THIS
YEAR- BECAUSE I SUPPORT%
BUILDING WHICH BUT I ALSO HAD
SOME CONCERNS. YOU'VE ALREADY
ANSWERED SOME RELATED TO THIS
BEING THE EXACT SAME BILL I
KNOW THAT. I THINK THE ISSUE IS
WHETHER CONDUIT BONDS ARE
CONSIDERED PUBLIC OR NOT AND
THERE SEEMS TO BE THE GOVERNOR
DOESN'T. THINK THAT THEY ARE IT
WITHOUT WAS THE VETO MESSAGE
LAST YEAR OF LISTEN. BUT I
THINK THAT WOULD BE THAT MY I
DON'T RECALL SPECIFICALLY WHAT
WAS IN THE GOVERNOR'S VETO
MESSAGE. BUT I DON'T BONDS ARE
AN ANIMAL OF THE PUBLIC SPHERE.
IN FACT- BILL VERY SIMILAR TO
THIS APPLIES TO CALIFORNIA
HOSPITALS THAT ARE BUILT WITH
CONDUIT BONDS BECAUSE THEY'RE
PUBLICLY SUPPORT BONDS SO YEAH
I A- IN YOU KNOW I'M I'M GOING
TO SUPPOR- AND BUT I'D UP SOME
CONCERTS ENDS AND THESE ARE
JUST CAUGHT ON I KNOW CO LOCATE
OF CHARTER SCHOOLS IN
TRADITIONAL SCHOOLS- IS A BIG
ISSUE I KNOW IN LOS ANGELES. WE
HAVE FISH LOCATED IN A LOT OF
THEM WANT TO BUILD THEIR OWN
BUILDING RIGHT EVENTUALLY OR
ARE THEY PLAN AND- AND SO I'M
CONCERNED THAT- THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO HAVE ACCESS TO FUNDS
TO DO THAT NOW BECAUSE OF THAT
WILL REALLY THE BEST ANSWER FOR
ANY PUBLIC SCHOOL WISHES TO
IMPROVE SERVICE FOR BUILDING.
PLEASE IS TO THROUGH THE-
PROGRAM THOSE OF THE SCHOOL
BONDS THAT WE HAVE PASSED
TRADITIONALLY THIS YEAR WE
WEREN'T SUCCESSFUL- BUT- I EAT
THIS YEAR'S BOND AS WELL AS
OTHERS HAD MONEY SET ASIDE
SPECIFICALLY FOR CHARTER SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION. OKAY SO I I'M
SUPPORTIVE OF ENHANCING
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL FACILITIES
AND THE WAY WE DO THAT IS TO
OUR BONDING CAPACITY OF THEIR
VOTER APPROVAL DID MAKE IT THIS
TIME. BUT AGAIN THAT THAT THAT
IS THE- ALLOWABLE VENTURE FOR
THOSE IN THE ON THE CHARTER
SCHOOL STARTED HELLO PUBLIC
SCHOOLS. YOUR NUMBER CREEL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THE
FORMER YEAH HELLO OKAY I THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- SOMEONE WROTE
DONALD I OF COURSE SUPPORT
PREVAILING WAGE I'M IN A VERY
INTERESTING A SAID BEEN GIVEN
THAT. FIFTY ONE WHICHEVER IS
THE HIGHEST DENSITY CHARTER
DISTRICT IN THE ENTIRE STATE
AND A LOT OF THE SAME
CONSTABULARY SOME THAT I SHARE
AS WELL I DO WANT TO. THE GOV
VIDAK MESS HE SAID LAST THIS
BILL WILL EXTEND THE APPLET OF
PUBLIC WORKS LAW TO CHARTER
SCHOOL PROJECTS FINANCED WITH
CONDUIT REVENUE BONDS WHILE I
SUPPORT PAYMENT A PREVAILING
WAGES ON PROJECTS PAID WITH
LIKE FUNDS. CONDUIT REVENUE BY
OUT FOR FINISHED. BEFORE
PROJECTS. I'M SO WHAT MAKES IT
DIFFERENT FROM LAST YEAR I DO
HOPE THAT WE GET AN OPPORTUNITY
TO WORK TOGETHER TO ENSURE
THAT. WE HAVE A WIN THIS YEAR
AND THAT YOU HAVE YOU'VE DONE
THE WORK NECESSARY WITH THE
GOVERNOR SOUGHT TO ENSURE THAT
WE'RE NOT THE SMOKING. WHAT
APPEARS TO BE ANOTHER ORDER
BILL- BUT REALLY ONE THAT'S OUT
WORKING ALL WERE. US AT SURE
THAT LATE. THAT THE- LOOK AT. I
WOULD. CONSERVE HELPED. HOPE TO
WORK WITH AS WELL THANK YOU. AT
THE FOREFRONT SET BECAUSE THEY
RECOGNIZE THE FACT THAT A
SKILLED AND TRAINED WORKFORCE
BUILDS A SCHOOL FOR SO TO A
QUALITY LEVEL ON TIME BUDGET.
THAT'S THE HISTORY COM AND CAN
TELL YOU I HAVE CHARTER SCHOOLS
IN MY DISTRICT TO. ASK IF THERE
WAS CONSTRUCTION TO GO ON TO
THEM I WOULD WANT THAT
CONSTRUCTION TO BE CONDUCTED.
BY A SKILLED AND- OR SEND IT.
IS ALREADY ARE BECAUSE THEY
ACCESS THE CALIFORNIA. SCHOOL
FACILITIES PROGRAM. THOSE THAT
USE THE CONDUIT BONDS WERE
TRYING TO BRING IN THEM INTO
THAT SPHERE INSURING THAT THEIR
PROJECTS ARE ON. TO A HIGH
QUALITY LEVEL AND FRIENDSHIPS
ARE OFFERED HIS APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS ARE THE PROGRAMS THAT
KEEP GIVING. RIGHT YOU PUT
SOMEONE THROUGH APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM. THE GET IN THE MIDDLE
CLASS THEY'VE GOT A SKILL SET
THAT KEEPS THE MIDDLE CLASS
AGAIN THAT IS THE POLICY THAT
KEEPS GIVING ARE VERY SUPPORTER
OF APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS.
THAT THAT WHAT THE CITY TO DO
THIS THOSE PUBLIC SCHOOL
PROJECTS PUBLIC PROJECT. INTO
THE STREET OF A SKILLED TRAIN A
PREVAILING WAGE- PAID WORKFORCE.
AND I THINK THAT'S APPROPRIATE
ON AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS OR- ANY OTHER COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS. ALL RIGHT- WE DO
HAVE A MOTION. YOUR MOTION FROM
THE SUMMER GONZALEZ SECOND
EISENBERG CARILLO. PASTOR
PREACHES CENTER O'DONNELL AND
FOUND THOMAS THAT'S WHEN I VOTE
MISTER HERE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
TAKE A ROLL CALL VOTE THIS.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA AYE KALRA
AYE FLORA. FLORA NOT VOTING
CARILLO. CORREO I DEEP HI STEVE
I CAN SALAS AND SALAS I JONES
SAWYER. RIVAS RIVAS I. RIGHT
THE BILLS OUT THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS.
NEXT UP IS AB TWENTY NINE
NINETY TWO. ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WEBER. THE LONG. WELL OKAY.
WITH THE TEAR IN MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING US TO PRESENT
AB TWENTY NINE NINETY TWO OF I
WANT TO THANK YOU STAFF A
WORKING WITH MY OF MY FELLOW
THIS WAS HIS BILL AND- FURTHER.
HARD WORK IN THE REVISIONS AND
ALL THOSE KINDS OF THINGS HE
LEARNED A LOT IN DOING THIS
BILL SOMEONE THANK YOU STAFF
FOR THAT. I KNOW IT'S A GOOD
BUT I'M SURE. A LITTLE.
OUTDATED AT THIS POINT SO GOOD
AFTERNOON OR IS IT EVENING THE
AFTERNOON STILL STILL- THIS
BILL SEEKS TO EXPAND EXISTING
PROTECTED LEAVE OF TWO DOUBLES
OF ANY VIOLENCE I AND- TO THE
IMMEDIATE FAMILY MEMBERS.
THOMAS AYE SINCE. IT WOULD IT
WOULD ALSO RISE. REASON OF THE-
TO VERIFY THAT IT TIME OR HAS
IT HURT. WE HAVE WORKED WITH
THE CAL CHAMBER WE WILL ONE DAY
JOB KILLER BUILD OUT THEY
REMOVED OPPOSITION. AND ARE
CONTINUING TO WORK ON TRYING TO
HELP US REFINE WHAT THE FORM
DISCRIMINATION MIGHT BE
ENTITLED STRIP FOR
DOCUMENTATION HE'S ME. WE
HONEST THE DIFFICULT SITUATION
BUSINESSES ARE IN AND SEEK TO
ACHIEVE THE RIGHT BALANCE
BETWEEN PROTECTING RIVERS AND
BE SPOT TO TURN A BUSINESS. IN
THE SPINE. CALIFORNIA SAFE THIS.
TO THE- WHOLE SURVIVORS OF.
TWENTY NOT. AND THE SURVEY
FOUND THAT ONE IN FOUR
CALIFORNIA SURVIVORS HAD TO.
FOLLOWING THE CRIME AND TO. A
REPORT THERE'S A BY THE STRESS
AND DIFFICULTY WITH SLEEP
RELATED OF RELATION OF OR BURKE
STUDIES CONSISTENTLY SHOW
SURVIVORS VIOLENT CRIMES WITH
LOW INCOME VIRUS OVERWHELMINGLY
NEED SUPPORT. OF MEETING BASIC
NEEDS FOLLOWING A CRIME
INCLUDING MAINS MAINTAIN STABLE
EMPLOYMENT. THE END OUR HUMAN
RIGHTS COULD YOU. WE REALLY.
THE REPORT I DID RESEARCH
SHOWING THAT THE MAJORITY OF
PARENTS OF HOMICIDE VICTIMS
REPORTED DIFFICULT TO RETURN TO
WORK MORE THAN ONE IN FOUR
FAMILY MEMBERS IN MY VIEW THAT
ONCE IT HIT THEIR JOBS AND WORK
OR BY ITS MISSING TO YOU THERE
BUT ONCE. RIGHT THESE
CALIFORNIA PASS A LOT OF THIS
IS A IMPLEMENTS THE BILL FOR
EVERY GROUPS OF VICTIM THESE
ISSUES TO NOW MORE THAN EVER
DUE TO THE CURRENT UPDATE OF
EPIDEMIC LEGISLATURE. NEEDED TO
IMPROVE UPON. AND TO FORMER
STABILITY SO THAT CAN FOCUS ON
WITH AND SAFETY THIS BILL OF
THE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS
NORM PLOY WHO HAS BEEN A VICTIM
OF A VIOLENT CRIME SHOULD HAVE
TO CHOOSE BETWEEN THEIR
PHYSICAL EMOTIONAL SAFETY IN
THE FINANCIAL CONSEQUENCES OF
LOSING THEIR JOB THIS BILL AND
THAT BY RESERVE BY IN THE LOVE
ONES. TAKE LIMITED TIME OFF TO
SECURE THEIR SAFETY AND HEALING
FOLLOWING A CRIME BY EXPANDING
EXISTING PROTECT LEAVE VICTIMS
OF ANY VIOLENT CRIME AND TO
MEET A FAMILY PROMISE. THIS
WOULD ALSO SPEND DOUBLE A
DOCKING SHOULD THE VICTIMS. OF
CAMPER TO PROTECT BELIEVE WORK
OR REQUIRE REASON.
ACCOMMODATION TO COVER
FOLLOWING THE CRIME. AB TWENTY
FOUR FORTY THREE. OF DOES EIGHT
TO TWENTY NINE NINETY TWO DOES
NOT CHANGE. THE AMOUNT OF LEAD
CURRENTLY OF THE ALLOWABLE IT
ONLY EXPANDS THOSE PROTECTIONS
TO ADDITIONAL GROUPS OF VICTIMS
OF VIOLENT CRIMES IN THESE
UNPAID LEAVES- TODAY WITH A ON
FALL. ON FOR AB TWENTY NINE
NINETY TWO. SHIP EACH. POLICY
CALPERS DIRECT I'M VICTIMS WAS
IN JUST. AND ANDRE TELLS US THE
SENIOR US PA MANAGER FOR. WITH
AND ANDREAS BE TO ANSWER A-
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU DOCTOR
WEBER YES WE DO HAVE TO. A
WITNESS ONLINE AND SALAS AS FAR
AS FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE. AND
MISS GENTEEL OF CONFERENCE TO
SAFETY AND JUSTICE. BOTH ON THE
PHONE SUBMITS HOLLINS IF YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU CAN OVERDO.
PRETTY HEAR ME YES. THANK YOU I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THIS
AFTERNOON THANK YOU DOCTOR
WEBER- APPRECIATE THE
INVITATION TO SPEAK TODAY- AS
YOU MENTIONED- WE REPRESENT A
NATIONAL NETWORK OF CRIME
SURVIVORS MORE THAN FORTY
THOUSAND. COUNTRY IN CALIFORNIA
TWELVE THOUSAND MEMBERS WE
ORGANIZED CRIME SURVIVORS BEEN
PICKED UP FROM COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE MOST IMPACTED BY CRIME AND
VIOLENCE. BECAUSE THEIR VOICES
AND EXPERIENCES ARE OFTEN
MISSING IN PUBLIC SAFETY IN
COMPARISON QUESTION AS YOU
HEARD THE CURRENT CALIFORNIA
LAW PROVIDE THE PLAN
PROTECTION. SHOULD ARRIVE AT
THE CRIME. BUT IN OUR CURRENT.
WITH MEMBERS WE LEARNED THAT
MANY ARE FORCED TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN THEIR SAFETY AND
FINANCIAL SECURITY NO MATTER
WHAT TYPE OF CRIME EXPERIENCE-
AND I THINK AT THE STATE
DIRECTOR OF THIS ORGANIZATION
BUT I'M ALL. I CAN IDENTIFY
WITH IT. I LOST TWO BROTHERS TO
THEM VIOLATE MEDICARE FOR
FISCAL ONE IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
IT. AND TWENTY CONTROL MY- WE
DID NOT LIVE IN THE SAME
HOUSEHOLD. AT THE TIME OF THE
DEATH I WITH THE FULL COUNTY
EMPLOYEES THIRTEEN YEARS OF
SERVICE AND A SOLID REPUTATION
AT THE UNIT LEADER. I USED THE
TIME OFF I BOUGHT IT OFF A CREW
PAID TIME OFF. I WAS BLESSED TO
HAVE LAST QUICKLY DROPPED IT
THERE. AND I RETURNED TO WITH.
ANCHO EVEN. AND THE CHALLENGES
WITH NO SAFETY NET. MY PLAYERS
A STRICT POLICY AGAINST UNPAID
OFF AT THE FAMILY MEMBER OF THE
VICTIM'S EXPERIENCE WHO'S NOT
CURRENTLY REFLECTED ARE NOT
REFLECTED INTO. LAW UNPAID TIME
OFF. PROTECT IT I RECEIVED
NUMEROUS VERBAL AND WRITTEN
WARNING FOR ABSENCE AND HEART
IT'S- I DON'T HAVE THE TIME IS.
A ALL BE. YOU KNOW THE TRIM
THAT END. FINANCIAL YEARS THAT
HAVE BEEN BY THE LOS IN OUR
FAMILY BOB AND ACT TO PROVIDING
WHO ALSO LOST THEIR JOBS AND
HOUSING BECAUSE OF THE
CHALLENGES. OF THE CURRENT FIND
IT AROUND CALLED AT NINETEEN.
EIGHT TO REALLY HELP YOU FIND A
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE MOST
VULNERABLE BEHIND THE COUNTER
AT THE CENTER OF THAT IT
REQUIRES THAT TO BROCK AND
YOU'RE STANDING OF OUR NEED.
AND REMOVE BARRIERS TO STATE IN
HERE. ALL PROVIDE WITH THE
VIOLENT CRIME IN THEIR LOCAL IT
SHOULD BE ABLE TO. HI THANKS
AND BACK THE VICTIM SERVICES
FOR FROM A CRIME THAT IS THE
ESSENCE PUBLIC SAFETY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND- WILL TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS OR IN THE HEAD
THE DIGITAL COPY. THANK YOU.
THERE ISN'T. YOUR ONLINE
GUARDIAN NEXT. THANK DERIVE
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU
DOCTOR WEBER THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE AT MY NAME ADDRESS
AND HE'LL- CALIFORNIANS WITH
EIGHT GAMES AFFECT INTERACT
WITH THE END BACK. ON THE PORT
AS AB TWENTY NINE NINETY EIGHT
ZERO I AND I AND IF YOU'RE ON
THE LINE. NINETY EIGHT TECHNO
TRANSACTION MAY HAVE ABOUT THE
BILL TODAY NOW I I'LL- THE
QUESTIONS THAT. ALLOW THANK YOU
WE'VE GOT A MOTION FOR MYSTERY
OF SOME CREEL IS THERE'S- SOME
OF HIS ALSO SECOND AND IS
ANYONE IN THE ROOM IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY NINE NINETY TWO.
WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE LINES
MISTER MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINES IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY NINE NINETY TWO. YOU YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT AND WANT TO
EXPRESS SO ME PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. FIRST LOGO A LINE OF
FIVE FIFTY FOUR FIVE FIVE ORDER
LINE IS OPEN. JESSICA CENTER ON
BEHALF OF EQUAL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
FIVE SIXTY THREE FIVE SIX THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WE SHOP BE
HALF OF CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT
POLICY CENTER IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE
SIX FORTY EIGHT SIX FOUR EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
THAT FUNDING IS IN THE STATE
POLICY DIRECTOR FOR FIFTY AND
WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS. THANK YOU. POLITICS FOR
THE DELAY LINE FIVE SIX ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CAN I
GUARANTEE HAPPENED LEGALLY THAT
WORK IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. FIND SIX TWO SIX SIX
TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SORRY LINE SIX TWENTY SIX WE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS LYNN
NATION AT WORDS I AM THE CRIME
REVIVER AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE SIX
SIX ONE SIX SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS THE LOCAL
MAJOR AND I AM A CLIENT
PROVIDER AND I AM STRONGLY
WANTING TO BE ABLE TO PASS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. FIND
THREE SIX SIX THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WHAT BACKING ON POLICY
SALAS SENSATION OF POSTAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ONE SIX SIX
SEVEN SIX SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI THIS IS GINA
RODRIGUEZ AND I AM PERSONALLY
AT THE VIPER VOICE FOR OTHER
SURVIVORS AND I AM IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. SIX ZERO ONE NINE
SIX ZERO ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
VERY GOOD THE HARA ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT
LAWYERS ASSOCIATION AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. FIND SIX
THIRTY SIX SIX THREE SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WELL YES GO AHEAD
YES WE CAN CARRY. OUT I AND MY
NAME IS ELIZABETH WALK AMONG
YOUNG AND I AM A CRIME VIBER OF
GUN BUYING THE THOMAS FIVE MY
SON AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO NINE NINE CARE. THANK YOU.
FIND SIX FORTY SIX SIX FOUR SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HELLO MY
NAME'S DAVID YOU THOUGHT-
LITTLE FEDERAL MOTIONS YOU
BARBER OF BROTHER OF SHOES.
WHICH WERE MURDERED IN THE FACT.
IN SUPPORT OF A. B. TO LEARN
AND TO. THANK YOU. LINE SIX
FORTY THREE SIX FOUR THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BUT MY NAME IS
JENNY GUERRERO FOUNDER. THANK
YOU FOUNDATION IN THE CRIME
SURVIVOR IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
NINE NINE TWO. THANK YOU. FIND
ONE TO FIVE POINT TWENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH
AFTERNOON CHAIR NUMBER THIS IS
THE AT THE DIMARTINO WITH
CALIFORNIANS FOR STATE JEFF.
PROUD SPONSOR OF AB TWO NINE
NINE TWO- FORMER STAFFER ALSO
DOCTOR WHETHER AND- VERY
HONORED TO BE ACT. THANK YOU
THANK. WINDS FIVE TO SIX FIFTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS MORE SHAPE PART. AND I
AM LIKE CRIME SURVIVOR
SUPPORTER AND I SUPPORT THE
BILL. THANK YOU. FIND FIVE
FORTY SEVEN FIVE FOUR SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. DANNY BUT
SOMETHING HAPPENED UNITED
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES AND THE
COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF
AMERICA DISTRICT NINE OPEN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. FIND SIX
THREE FOUR SIX THIRTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ALL OUR ONLINE
SIX THREE FOUR IS YOUR PHONE ON
MUTE. HI THIS IS CONTENT I'M A
SURVIVOR OF GUN VIOLENCE AND I
LOST MY BROTHER TO A HOMICIDE
AND I AM STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
THOUGH. THANK YOU. NINE SIX
FOUR FOUR SIX FORTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD SO WE'RE TOLD SANTA
CLARA COUNTY WAIT STAFF
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WITH. OUR FINAL LINE
IN Q. RIGHT NOW WITH SIX FIVE
THREE SIX FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY VICTORIA SHELL
AND I AM OR OF AB. NINE NINETY.
AND THE- LET. OUR CALLER PLEASE
CONTINUE ON. AND I SUPPORTER
THRILLED VERY MUCH AND ONE OF
THE PAST. THANK VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR NO FOR
THE LINE THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU- WE YOU HAVE BEEN AT
BEING A WITH THE CAL CHAMBER.
WE MAY BE EXPRESSING SOME
DIFFERENT OPINIONS YEARS AGO
THAT MR MAKE IT THE STATURE OF
THAT HAVE BECOME A HAVE A
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
I WANTED TO CONFIRM WE HAVE
REMOVED OFFICE. INTO THE BILL
THANK YOU TO DOCTOR EVER FOR
WORKING THIS AND- JUST FOR THE
RECORD. EVERYTHING FELL. I'M
GLAD YOU'RE HERE. THE FIRST TO
CONFIRM THAT CRESCENTA. ANYONE
ELSE HERE THERE IS OR ANY HERE
AND ALL. NO ONE HERE IN THE
ROOM IS OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE MISTER MODERATOR IN
OPPOSITION. TO AB TWENTY NINE
NINETY TWO. YOUR POSITION IS
OPPOSITION. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME. ALL RIGHT- I'M BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
COMMENTS QUESTIONS. IF NOT WE
DO HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR
FROM SOME MEMBER CARILLO
SECONDED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GONZALEZ DO PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS. DR WEBBER- ANY
FINAL COMMENTS I JUST
RESPECTFUL YEAH I BUILT FOR
TWENTY NINE NINETY TWO GET OUT
OVER A MAYBE PLEASE HAVE THE
ROLL CALL ON THE VOTE. THE
MOTION TO PASS APPROPRIATIONS
KALRA FIVE KALRA HI FLORA FLORA
I CARILLO. RIO I DEEP. GONZALEZ
JONES SAWYER. RIVAS RIVAS I
READ THE BILLS OUT MORE HOLDEN-
OPEN FOR THOSE THAT ARE ABSENT
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER. ALL
RIGHT. CLOSE CHANGE POSITIONS
THE. RIGHT MISTER CHAIR.
ASSUMING WE'RE GONNA START WITH
NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN. THINK
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN VERS
AB NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN
INCREASES THE STATUE
LIMITATIONS FOR FILING A WORKER
RETALIATION CLAIM. FROM SIX
MONTHS TO ONE YEAR AND THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESS AND HAS
THE ABILITY TO SEE CHINESE BEES
REVEALING A PLEASE IN THE LEGAL
PROCESS. WORKPLACE RETALIATION
OCCURS EMPLOYERS TERMINATE
THREATEN THE TERMINATION DEMOTE
SUSPEND OR SUBJECT EMPLOYEES TO
AN ADVERSE ACTION INCLUDING
THREATS OF DEPORTATION. FOR
EXERCISING THEIR RIGHTS UNDER
THE LABOR CODE. BUT
TELEVISION'S ONLY BASIS BUT
ALSO A GROWING PROBLEM TO THE
CURRENT POLITICAL CLIMATE
SURROUNDING IMMIGRATION. THE
LAST FOUR YEARS OF AVAILABLE
DATA FROM TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
TO TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN.
IMMIGRATION RELATED RETALIATES
CLAIMS FILED WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR STANDARDS
ENFORCEMENT. HE'S BY NEARLY
2000% AMIDST PANIC BUT GETS
REPORT AN INCREASE IN CALLS
REGARDING HEALTH AND SAFETY
ISSUES AND WAGE THEFT AND THIS
CLASSIFICATION. IT IS IMPORTANT
NOW IS THAT WE INSURE ALL LEGAL
AND ADMINISTRATIVE AVENUE BUILT
FOR COME FORWARD. WORK PLEASE
RETALIATION ESPECIALLY EXTREME
FORMS A TERMINATION OR
VIOLENCE. NEED MORE TIME TO GO
THE RESOURCES AND SEEK-ASSISTANCE. THAT INCOME THEY
OFTEN UP TO ADDRESS THEM
ADDRESS IMMEDIATE FINANCIAL
ISSUES SUCH AS FINDING OTHER
JOB OR MAKING ARRANGEMENTS FOR
THE FAMILY. BEFORE BEING ABLE
TO FILE THE CLAIM. A SIMPLE SIX
MONTH EXTENSION THE FOLLOWING A
WORK SESSION CLAIM WILL GIVE
PEOPLE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CONSIDER LIKE AND- THAT THERE.
WHO TAKE THESE CASES ON BEHALF
WORKERS THIS IS NOT A BILL.
THAT IS INTENDED TO INCREASE
THE NEGATION OF THE OPPOSITION
ARGUES RATHER PROVIDES AN
ADDITIONAL SENSIBLE AND
REASONABLE WAY FOR LOW WAGE
WORKERS TO PURSUE BE WORSE WHEN
THEY HAVE BEEN UNFAIRLY ATTACK
AGAINST. FOR INVOKING THE RIGHT
UNDER STATE LAW. NOW THIS
PROVISION. THAT MANY OF THESE
WORKS TO GET ANY REPRESENTATION.
WITH ME REVISED SUPPORTING
TESTIMONIES CHRISTOPHER SANCHEZ
WITH CHIRLA AMERICA YOSHIHARA
WHAT'S- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR FIRST WITNESS. THE
GIRL ON THE PHONE WITH A BLUE
SO YES THE STRIKE YOU WORK THE
TWO MEMBERS PLEASE EFFORTS WITH
US. ZERO AND- THE HEART OF THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION AND THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA FOR YOUR
COMMITMENT TO THIS ISSUE. I'M
AND YOU CAN IMAGINE OUR LAWYERS
ARE HEARING FROM SO MANY
WORKERS AT THE STATE WHO FEEL
UNSAFE AT WORK BECAUSETHE
EMPLOYER IS NOT TAKING PROPER
PRECAUTIONS TO PROTECT THEM. OF
THE NINETEEN. HEARD A LOT.
TODAY AT. WORK THE AMBULANCE
WORKERS HOW CARE WHAT
FARMWORKERS. WERE WHO ARE ARE
WHO ARE IN FEAR OF THEIR HEALTH
AND SAFETY AND NOT JUST OF THE
ROLE OF THE COPA NINETEEN.
UNDER THE RIGHT NUMBER THAT
WOULD PUT HIM FOR. WORKERS
REALLY MEAN NOTHING IF THEY CAN
BE FIRED. AGAIN TRYING TO A
THIRD RIGHT TO PROTECTION. YEAH
IS THE WORKER ARE AFRAID TO
SPEAK OUT BECAUSE THEY SIMPLY
CANNOT AFFORD TO LOSE THEIR-
ESPECIALLY IN A ECONOMY. AND
FOR THOSE WORKERS WHO DO SPEAK
OUT IF YOU FACE RETALIATION SIX
MONTHS JUST NOT ENOUGH TIME FOR
THEM TO FILE A CLAIM WITH THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER. THAT THE
BILL WILL HELP. BUILD WORKER DE
WITH THE RIGHT BY GIVING THEM
EXTRA MONTHS TO FILE THE CLAIM.
AND THIS IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE
IF WORKERS ARE NOT ABLE TO FILE
WITH THE LABOR COMMISSIONER'S
OFFICE THEIR ONLY OPTION IS
FILE A CIVIL ACTION. AND KNOW
THAT IT IS. HARD WORKERS THE
FINAL WHO CAN. TWO EIGHT. FORTY
SEVEN WILL. HELP WORKERS
ESPECIALLY WAGE WORKER. LEGAL
IS THAT. BUT THE- FOR WITH THE
LOWER. RETALIATION CLAIMS
BECAUSE WILL ALLOW THESE
WORKERS TO RECOVER THEIR
ATTORNEY FEES IF THEY PREVAIL
IN THAT CASE. RATHER THAN
HAVING TO PAY THEIR A CUT OF
THEIR AWARD. AND OTHER REASON
YOU'RE KIND THE EDITORIAL
PUBLISHED THIS. WEEKEND POINTED
OUT. ALLOWING WORKERS TO
RECOVER THEIR ATTORNEYS FEES IF
THEY PREVAIL. DOES NOT
INCENTIVIZE FRIVOLOUS
LITIGATION. OF COURSE THE
LAWYER GETS NOTHING. NOT WE
WENT. AND TALKED A LITTLE WILL
LOSE. THE MONEY PUT INTO WORK
PRODUCT IS. REQUIRED NO MERIT.
IN REALITY. PROVIDE BOX THE
JUSTICE LEAGUE FOR WHICH WERE.
HEY THERE WILL REGARDLESS OF
WHAT THE OF THE CALL AND THEIR
WILL. OFTEN TIED THEIR WAGE.
I'M GOOD BILL WILL HELP ENSURE
MORE WORKERS THEY TO AND THEIR
RIGHTS IN ITALY CODE THE FOR
THE REASONS WE STRONGLY URGE
YOUR- THANK YOU VERY. NEXT PORT
ON THE PHONE. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS CHRISTOPHER
SPONSORS WITCHER THE COALITION
FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS ORGANIZATION DIRECTOR
PROGRAMMING AND OF THE FAMILY
INCOME WORKERS WE'RE PROUD TO
SPONSOR. THAT AS IMMIGRANT
WORKERS UP AND TO OF THE WORST
ABUSE BY THE EMPLOYERS THE BOOK
AND IMMIGRATION SYSTEM OF
PLACEMENT FURTHER IN THE
SHADOWS AND IT'S CREATED A LAP
SITUATION FOR EMPLOYER REVIEWS.
AT THE END OF OUR OFFER THE
BILL IS MORE IMPORTANT NOW THAN
EVER SINCE THE BEGINNING OF
THIS PANDEMIC OFFICE HAS
RECEIVED REPORTS FROM WORKERS
WAS RIGHT HAVE BEEN COMPROMISED
AND- MAD ABOUT. UNDER CONDITION.
FOR THEIR PLAYERS THREATENING.
YOU SHALL WORKERS IF THEY WERE
TO GO GOING. TOWARD THE WERE
CONDITIONS TO PARTY FOR THE
DOORS ARE NOT THE- FROM TIME
THE PREVIOUS OF THE PANDEMIC.
BOB DIFFERENCE THAT WILL THE
WORK FORCE DECREASE THE REPORTS
OF RETALIATION IN OTHER OF
EMPLOYER ABUSES THAT INCREASE.
FOR MARCH FOR YOU TO THE
WORKING WITH THAT WORKERS ARE
VICTIMS OF VARIOUS WORKER
ABUSIVE. YOU KNOW SIX MONTHS OF
ATTIC. IN A WORKERS FOR.
OFTENTIMES HESITATION BERMAN TO
COME PART OUT OF FEAR TO THE
LEGAL STAFF A PLACE IN ACROSS
OUR WITHIN THE GRAY OF COURSE.
I DID IT'S IMPORTANT TO THAT IN
SOME CASE ONE AND ARE WORKERS
COME FORWARD BOB LANE WITH THE
PERSON THAT WE ALL THE BOOKS.
DEPENDING ON THE OF THE CASE.
WE'LL SHOW UP AND YOU PARTY AND
A LOT THE FORTY COOPER OPERATE
BUT THE COMMISSION. WITHOUT ALL
THROUGH NEED THE ALTERNATE
ROUTE. WHICH IS THE FOURTEEN.
SURE THAT REPRESENTED BY WORK
IN ANOTHER PROCEED. OUR WORK
RETALIATION CLAIMS AND- WORK
THE LABOR. AND WE HAVE TO YOU'D
BE PROGRAM. IS FOR THESE
REASONS WE DRIVE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN PART
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT AND SUPPORT
IN THE ROOM. PUBLIC SUPPORT
FORTY SEVEN SEE NOBODY IN THE
ROOM ANYONE ELSE BY THE PHONE.
IN SUPPORT OF HIS OWN IN. THANK
YOU BY PHONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN THEY'RE ALL ALTHOUGH FIRST
ONLINE SIX SIXTEEN SIX ONE SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MICHAEL YOUNG
HELLO FEDERATION OF SUPPORT. IN
LINE SIX SEVEN SEVEN SIX
SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SHANE GUSMAN WITH TEARS IN
SUPPORT. LINE SIX SEVENTY FIVE
SIX SEVEN FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY EIGHT AM ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT. LINE
SIX EIGHT TWO SIX EIGHTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SORRY SIX
EIGHTY TO YOUR PHONE MAYBE I
MEAN. MOVE TO LINE SIX OH SEVEN
SIX ZERO SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ORDER ONLINE SIX SO SEVEN CAN
YOU CHECK YOUR TELEPHONE. BUT
BROWN THE CULPRIT FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU
FIND SIX EIGHTY SEVEN SIX EIGHT
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ORDER
WITH THAT YEAH YOU CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT. LINE SIX FOUR FOUR SIX
FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BIRTH SOBRE TOLD SANTA CLARA
COUNTY WHICH THAT COALITION IN
SUPPORT. THANKS THANK YOU LINE
FIVE FIVE FOUR FIVE FIFTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU GET
CENTER ON BEHALF OF PEOPLE
RIGHTS ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT.
LINE. SIX SEVEN THREE SIX
SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YEAH STRONG SUPPORT. LINE SIX
EIGHT THREE SIX EIGHTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
KAREN ON BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. NINE FIVE FORTY SEVEN
FIVE FOUR SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
JANUARY TERRACE ON BEHALF OF
THE COMMUNICATIONS WORKERS OF
AMERICA DISTRICT NINE IN
SUPPORT. AND WE HAVE THREE
LINES IN Q. WE'LL GO TO LINE
SIX SEVENTY TWO SIX SEVEN TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MARKET AMERICA
ON BEHALF OF THE CHART
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES NETWORK IN
CHILD SUPPORT. FIND SIX SEVENTY
FOUR SIX SEVEN FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. TOP OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY FEDERATION OF LABOR IN
STRONG SUPPORT. OUR FINAL
LINING Q. IT'S SIX NINE ZERO
SIX NINETY PLEASE GO. AND
WHEREVER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN SUPPORT. THANK NO
FURTHER LINES IN Q. AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION IN PERSON HAVE
BEEN FROM CAL CHAMBER THIS IS
OUR MEMBERS THAT HAVE BECOME
AFTER CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE UNFORTUNATELY OUR POST
IN NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN I'M NOT
GOING TO BELABOR THE POINT
WE'VE OPPOSED THE PREVIOUS TWO
VERSIONS OF THE BILL IS GOING
TO BE CLEAR FOR THE RECORD WE
DO NOT OPPOSE EXTENSION OF THE
STATUE IT WAS RELEASED IN. OUR
CONCERN IS ABOUT- WHY SIDED.
JENNIFER FILED IN COURT AND WE
HAVE CONCERNS WHAT THE
PROPONENTS SAY THAT THIS IS
GOING TO DRIVE CLAIMS TO BE
FILED IN COURT- RATHER THAN THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER PROCESS
WHICH IS GOING TO RAISE COSTS
FOR ALL SIDES WE REALLY THINK
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER
PROCESSES A GOOD PLACE TO
RESOLVE THESE ESPECIALLY
WORKERS ON AN INFILL MORE LOW
COST CROSS. THE FOR THE REASONS
WERE. THE SAME. REASONS WE
OPPOSE THE PREVIOUS VERSIONS OF
THE CULTURE HAVE TO AGREE TO.
WITH OFF ON THIS ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE
ELSE IN THE ROOM IT'S
OPPOSITION TO NINETEEN FORTY
SEVEN. CNN ANYONE BY THE ON
PHONE IN OPPOSITION TO NINETEEN
FORTY SEVEN. THANK YOU
COMPETITION ISN'T IS IN
OPPOSITION IN A PRESS ONE AND
THEN THEY'RE ALL WILL GO FIRST
ONLINE SIX EIGHTY FIVE SIX
EIGHT FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BORDERS ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA FIFTY NINE JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY THE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO KNOW
WHAT A LINER COMMENTS WITH THE
DISTURBING. NINE SIX SEVEN
EIGHT SIX SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. IT OFF ON BEHALF
OF THE THANK ACCESS INSURANCE
WITH ALREADY ALIGNER COMMENT
HELP CHAMBER AFFECT. THANK YOU.
LINE FOUR OH SEVEN FOUR ZERO
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I SEE
WHAT THE CALIFORNIA GROCERS
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. NINE FIVE SIX FIVE
FIVE SIXTY FOR. SORRY LINE SIX
FIVE YOU MAY BE ON MUTE. BONTA
LINE. IX EIGHT ZERO SIX
EIGHTY. HI KATIE HANSON THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE.
YOU HAD TO HAVE ADDITIONAL LINE
IN Q. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. THANKS
COMMENT COMES FROM A LINE OF
SIX NINETY ONE SIX NINE ONE
YOUR LINE. THE LINE WILL BE
OPEN APOLOGIZE ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. SIX THAT WILL FIND IT.
GOOD AFTERNOON BRIGHT LITTLE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION IN OPPOSITION TO THE
REASONS STATED BY MISTER I
THINK THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ENOUGH NO FURTHER CALLERS IN Q.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. SEE AN
MISTER CHAIR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THE OTHER. THE PROJECT
THE COMMENTS FROM MR A BANK IN
THE SPAN OF A POINT OF
DIFFERENCE I DO BELIEVE BY
EXTENDING LIMITATIONS YOU
ACTUALLY GIVE MORE TIME TO ROLL
OVER ALL THINGS. WILL BE. TO
GET WORSE BEFORE THAT TIME
EXPIRES BY ALLOWING AND AFTER
SIX MONTHS YOU ACTUALLY DO GIVE
MORE TIME TO ATTEMPT TO RESOLVE
ISSUES THROUGH THE LABOR
COMMISSION BUT THAT RESPECT AS
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR MASSACRE. IT
HAS THE MOTION RIGHT. MOTION BY
CARILLO AND SECONDED BY RIVAS I
BELIEVE OKAY AS FOR THE PAST OF
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA HI KALRA I
FLORA. NO CARILLO. CREO I DEEP.
GONZALEZ JONES SAWYER RIVAS
RIVAS I. WITH THAT ON CALL
CORRECTIVE BELIEVE IT ON CALL
ALL RIGHT MISTER CHAIR WILL GO
TO AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY ONE.
THANK YOU. WHATEVER BILL YOU
WANT TO DO LATER THIS. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
PROUD TO PRESENT AB TWENTY TO
THIRTY ONE WHICH THE FOX WHEN A
PUBLIC SUBSIDY IS DE MINIMUS.
FOR THE PURPOSE OF DETERMINING
IF THE BILL LANGUAGE PLIES
PRIVATE PROJECTS USING PUBLIC
FUNDS. TO PROVIDE THE PUBLIC SO
ZERO PLATTER PROJECT HAS
DIMINISHED. SO LONG AS IT IS
LESS. THAN FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS OR LESS 2% OF
THE TOTAL. COST THIS BILL
EXEMPTS FROM THE FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLAR THRESHOLD CONSTRUCTION
SINGLE FAMILY HOUSING UNITS.
UNDER CURRENT LAW PROJECT IS
NOT SUCH A PREVAILING WAGE LAW
EVEN IF IT RECEIVES A PUBLIC
SUBSIDYIF THAT SUBSIDY IS
DIMINISH IN THE CONTEXT OF THE
PROJECT SINCE THE TURN TO
MINIMIZE AS NOT THE FINEST BUT
YOU THERE'S NO HINTS AS THE-
PUBLIC SUBSIDY. THAT SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED DIMINISHED. LET OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE JUST
MAKE INCONSISTENT. AS TO WHAT
IS DE MINIMUS LEADING TO
CONFUSION AND LITIGATION. WHAT
THE TERM ACTUALLY MEANS FOR
EXAMPLE IN TWO BECAUSE- OF THE
DEPARTMENT APPROVED AS DE
MINIMUS. THE ONE. MILLION
DOLLARS SUBSIDY. ANY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS. SEVENTY
PROJECT SINCE WAS ONLY ONE
POINT 75% OF THE TOTAL PROJECT
COST. THE PUBLIC SUBSIDY FOR OF
A PRIVATE PROJECT THAT IS MORE
THAN FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS OR 2% OF THE TOTAL
PROJECT COST. IS A NOTABLE
TAXPAYER INVESTMENT AND IT IS
REASONABLE TO REQUIRE
PREVAILING WAGES OF THE
DEVELOPER PUBLIC SONS. OVER
THAT AMOUNT. THE NINETEEN AND
DEMOCRATS PUTTING. FINANCIAL ON
OUR WORK FORCE. MANY WORKERS
HAVE BEEN LAID OFF THEIR HOURS
REDUCED OF TAKEN UNPAID LEAVE
TO TAKE CARE FOR THE FAMILY.
MORE THAN EVER CONSTRUCTION
WORK UNLIVABLE WAGES ON PRIVATE
PROJECTS THAT ARE SUBSIDIZED BY
TAXPAYERS. THAT I RESPECT WE
HAPPY I'D VOTE AND BY VIDEO
CONFERENCE DOUBLE WE HAVE. OF
OUR WITNESS JEREMY SMITH WITH
THE STATE BUILDING TRIPS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN
GERMANS WHETHER YOU ON THE
VIDEO CONFERENCE. I AM. CAN YOU
HEAR ME WE HEAR YOUR VOICE WILL
SEE YOUR FACE. WELL ALL I WAS
IN A HURRY OTHER AREAS. OKAY I
AM. WELL THANK YOU- GOOD
AFTERNOON MR VICE CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS-
GERMANS MATH HERE WITH THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL THE SPONSORS OF
AB TWENTY TO THIRTY ONE. OF MR
CALL IT A VERY GOOD JOB OF
LAYING OUT- THE NEED FOR THAT
THE REASONS FOR BRINGING IT
BACK UP A- YOUR- BECAUSE- UNDER
THE- CURRENT. A PRIVATE
DEVELOPER CAN ACCEPT PUBLIC
SUBSIDIES- TOTALING LESS THAN
2% OF PROJECT COST AND NOT HAVE
TO PAY THE PREVAILING WAGE-
THIS IS THE MINIMUM EXCEPTION
WHICH IN AN ACCIDENT TWO
THOUSAND A ONE IS APTLY MET
INSURE THAT PRIVATE DEVELOPMENT
I GETTING. A THE PREVAILING
PERCENT SIGNET COST UPPER THAT
ONE MIGHT. LET EXAMPLE FEES.
ANY IT WAS NEVER MEANT TO MOUNT
THE DOLLARS USED BY A I WITHOUT
PAYING FOR BILLING WAGE I FORTY
THIS IS HOW A FORMER I. R.
DIRECTOR RICHARD MANY AGO LEAVE
THE PARTICULAR. THE BY. SB IT
BECAUSE IT ONLY ONE POINT 64%
PRICE COST AFTER THAT THE I R.
ASSEMBLY IS TO THE ABSENCE OF
ANY LESS GUIDE OR DECISION THAT
ANY THE OF LESS THAN 2% OF
TOTAL PROJECT. ALWAYS TO
MINIMIZE EVEN IF THE- LEGAL
PORTS TO PROTECT BUT SHOULD BE
ON ITS OWN LETTER. THIS BILL
WOULD FINALLY PROVIDE CERTAINTY
REGARDING THE MEANING OF DE
MINIMUS. THE 2% AND FIVE
HUNDRED. DEALING WOULD HAVE NO
IMPACT ON PROJECTS UNDER TWENTY
FIVE MILLION FURTHERMORE AS
MISTER KALRA NOTED AB TWENTY TO
THIRTY ONE DOES NOT APPLY TO
SINGLE FAMILY HOME
CONSTRUCTION. TOOK THEM AND
LAST VERSION OF THE OF WEST OF
THE OPPONENTS. THE FEDEX HAVE
ALWAYS BEEN WILL BE BALLING.
ACCEPTED ON THE PART OF THE
DEVELOPER. IT IS IMPORTANT
REMEMBER. PAYING THE PREVAILING
WAGE IS NOT JUST ABOUT HIGHER
WAGES IT ALSO PROVIDES
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES FOR
HIGHLY SKILLED AND TRAINED
LOCAL FIRST AND APPRENTICES.
YOU CAN TRAIN. PRO THIS CHART
PROJECT AS THE MANY BURNS OUT
PURPOSES OF JOINING AND WOMEN
SO THAT NEW APPRENTICE INCOME
IN AND GET THEIR TRAINING I
LIKE GIRL LAWYER SHOULD BE THE
LAST TOURNAMENT TAXPAYER
DOLLARS WOULD PROVIDE A PRIVATE
DEVELOPERS ON A VOLUNTARY BASIS
SHOULD GO TO PROVIDE THE WAGES.
IT WORKS ARE NOT AND WHAT
PUBLIC BY ARE YOU TO LIVE. FOR
THESE REASONS WE URGE TO VOTE
YESTERDAY ON AB TWENTY THIRTY
ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER SMITH ANYONE ELSE
IN THE ROOM IN SUPPORT. OF AB
TWO THIRTY ONE PLEASE COME UP
ONE OF THE TIME. NAME AN
ORGANIZATION PLEASE THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CURTIS DAY- PAINTERS
AND ALLIED TRADES ORGANIZER- I
STAND TO SUPPORT WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES. THANK YOU SIR.
HELLO MY NAME IS TENOR KAREL
DISCOUNTS A SIXTEEN FOR THE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM I MEAN
INSTRUCTOR AND I AM ON STAND
WITH THE BUILDING TRADES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NAILED IT. HELLO
MY NAME'S CHUCK MAGGIE HOW MUCH
DISCOUNT OF SIXTEEN- PRESSURE
PROGRAM AND FOR THIS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MY GRILLING USUALLY
SIXTEEN PAIRS OUTRAGE OF THE
SUPPORT THANK YOU. REALLY
STEVENS THIS CAUSES SIXTEEN I
STAND IN SUPPORT WITH BUILDING
TRADES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANYONE ELSE IN THE ROOM IN
SUPPORT. ONE MORE THANK YOU SIR.
WELL JUST- IN OUR DISTRICT
COUNCIL SIXTEEN OF FRIENDSHIP I
STAND WITH THE BUILDING TRADES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
ON THE PHONE IN SUPPORT. FOR
THOSE ON THE PHONE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO WE'LL GO FIRST
TO LINE OF SIX SEVEN SEVEN SIX
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SIX SEVEN SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. IN A SPEECH. THANK YOU
AND GOD SPEND WHAT TEACHERS
FOR. THANK YOU FIND SIX ONE SIX
SIX SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YEAH CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION AND SUPPORT. NINE
SIX NINE THREE SIX NINETY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THAT THE
OPERATING ENGINEERS STOP
SUPPORT. FIND SEVEN ZERO ONE
SEVEN ALL ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THIS IS CHRIS CANNOT HANDLE
GEORGETOWN BILLING CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL I'VE BEEN WITH
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
COUNCIL AND STRONG SUPPORT.
FIND SEVEN OH SEVEN SEVEN ZERO
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT'S
CALL AROUND SEVEN OH SEVEN WE
MAKE STATE YOUR POSITION. MY
NAME IS STEVE ALONG
REPRESENTING DISTRICT COUNCIL
SIXTEEN FOR COVERS LOCAL UNITS
WHILE WE STAND IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU LINE SIX NINE EIGHT
SIX NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YEAH IN THIS CARLOS
FLOORS REPRESENTING DISTRICT
COUNCIL SIXTEEN IN OUR LOCAL
THREE SEVENTY SIX AND WE STAND
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL IN TRADE
FROM. LINE SEVEN HUNDRED SEVEN
ZERO ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES THE STAMP OUT YOU WOULD
DISTRICT COUNCIL SIXTEEN
MANNERS LOCAL NUMBER THREE WE
STAND IN SUPPORT. SIX NINETY
TWO SIX NINE TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. A GOOD AFTERNOON LIKE
MONEY GONNA BE AT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS THE
CALIFORNIA STATE I CREATE
COUNCIL. QUESTION SIX COUNTS OF
SHEET METAL WORKERS IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY TO THIRTY WHAT
THANK YOU. NINE SIX NINE FOUR
SIX NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MR CHEN MEMBERS KATE ON HUGE
AROUND WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE COUNCIL BELIEVERS
COSPONSORED CHECK FOR. NINE
SEVEN ZERO FOUR SEVEN ALL ORDER
LINE IS OPEN. YES MY NAME IS
ANTHONY WATER BUSINESS
REPRESENTATIVE FOR DIFFERENT
COUPLE SIXTEEN FLOOR LAYERS
LOCAL TWELVE AND WE STAND IN
SUPPORT WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES. MY SIX EIGHT EIGHT SIX
EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BOB BROWN BUT THEN THEY ARE
WORKERS LOCAL FOUR THIRTY THREE
AND THE POOR BUILDING TRADES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
FIVE NINE ON YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I DID LIMóN DOLLARS WITH THIS
ACCOUNT SIXTEEN PAINTERS AND
DRY WALL FINISHES LOCAL FORTY
SEVEN I STAND WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
LINE SEVEN ONE THREE SEVEN
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. DOUG
SERVERS- WITH THE INTERNATIONAL
BROTHERHOOD THE BOILERMAKERS IN
SUPPORT. LARA LINE SIX SEVENTY
FOUR SIX SEVEN FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ROBERT THE LA COUNTY
FEDERATION OF LABOR IN STRONG
SUPPORT. SHE THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME THERE ARE NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS IN KIßM. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WAS LIKE WE HAVE ONE
IN OPPOSITION TO TESTIFY BY
PHONE STEVEN CREWS FROM CBI.
CORRECT GOOD AFTERNOON- VICE
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CAN HEAR ME
OKAY. WE HAVE YOU. GREAT THANK
YOU- YES STEVE CREWS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION OPPOSITION
TO TWENTY THREE POINT TWO
THIRTY ONE WE HAVE SUBMITTED A
LETTER TO THE AUTHOR AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR CONSIDERATION SO
I'LL BE BRIEF AND JUST
HIGHLIGHTED OUR TOP MY CONCERNS
I KNOW THAT- THE CHAIRMAN KALRA.
THEY WOULD WOULD HAVE GIVEN THE
PREVIOUS VERSIONS OF THE BILL.
AND I WOULD WANT TO POINT OUT
THE RGRETTABLY THAT TWENTY TO
THIRTY ONE HAS BEEN TAGGED AS
THE HOUSING KILLER BY
ORGANIZATION BECAUSE OF THE-
COST. THEIR NEW HOUSING STOCK
IN PARTICULAR NOW THAT WE'VE
SEEN A LARGE DROP OFF AND- OF
THE VET. I'LL WANT TO MAKE SURE
OUT THAT. THOSE TWO. PERCENT
DRESS. TO PUT THAT 2% INTO
STATUTES IN FACT WHEN GOVERNOR
BROWN BE TOWED TO SIMILAR
MEASURES AND SUBSEQUENTLY
GOVERNOR SOME UP WITH FIVE
TWENTY EIGHT POINT OUT THE 2%
WAS LONG ANY PRACTICE NO MAY
WAS. MAKE THE CASE WITH
INSUFFICIENT AND SO WE WOULD
WITH A WHOLE AGREE WITH THOSE
STATEMENTS OUR CONCERN IS WITH
THE FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLAR THRESHOLD INCLUDING THE
BILL. GIVE IT UP IT IS THE XIN
WITH STATE AND LOCAL. ON GREEN
BUILDING TECH. AND OTHER
EFFICIENCY PROGRAMS WE KNOW
THAT THAT THRESHOLD WOULD BE
QUICKLY TRIGGERED AND
SUBSEQUENTLY REQUIRE PREVENT
WAGE. ON OTHERWISE I
RESIDENTIAL DEVELOPMENT- THIS
WOULD ADD AS MUCH AS EIGHTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND COST TO A
NEW HOME. IN JUST ONE EXAMPLE
IS THE NEW COLOR HOME PROGRAM.
BUILDERS BUT NOT PARTICIPATE
THIS PROGRAM AND WORSE YET THE
PROJECT WOULD NOT BE BUILT AT
ALL BECAUSE THESE COST DRIVERS.
INTERPRETERS YOU MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE TWENTY
THIRTY ONE THANK YOU. THANKS
VERY MUCH STEVEN. ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY THIRTY
ONE IN THE ROOM. PLEASE BEEN
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THAT HAVE
BECOME AFTER THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE APOLOGIES
FOR NOT BEING ON THE PRIOR
LETTER WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL. YOU KNOW THAT SAYS. FOR
PRESS. FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE IF
YOU TO TAKE IT TO A SPECIFIC
DOLLAR AMOUNT IT'S NO LONGER IN
THE CONTEXT THE PROJECT THE
PERCENTAGE IS ONE THING BUT
WHEN YOU TIED TO A SPECIFIC
DOLLAR THEN IT LOSES ALL
RELATIONSHIP TO THE CONTEXT OF
FOR THOSE WHO ARE. MUCH BEEN
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION IN.
ONE OPPOSITE ON THE PHONE. IN
IN OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO WILL GO
FIRST THE LINE OF LYING. SIX
NINE SIX SIX THANK YOU SIX YOUR
MIND IS OPEN. KIM STONE ON
BEHALF OF A THIRTY THE BUILDERS
AND CONTRACTORS NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN RESPECT
OPPOSITION. MISTER VICE JOURNAL
FOR THE LINES IN Q. AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
MODERATOR- ANY COMMENTS BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE IN THE
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEE IN THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE WITH THANK YOU MISTER
SURE THAT THAT IS A NEW ONE
HOUSING KILLER SO I GUESS I
HAVE CHOCOLATE HOUSING. BILLS
ON MY RESUME AND COMING FROM
SAN JOSE- THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT
BUILDING HOUSING IS OF CRITICAL
BUTTONS- BUT- BUT BUT THE
OPPOSITION BECAUSE COST DRIVERS
I CALL LIVING WHICH IS ON THE
CALL ACTUALLY. THE HOME. OF AN
ALL IN OUR ONLY EIGHT HOURS AND
SO IF WE'RE TO GIVE POP SUBSIDY
YOU HAVE TO MAKE SURE NOT ONLY
THE QUALITY OF THE WORK THAT'S
BEING DONE IS- IS WHAT WE
SHOULD EXPECT BUT ALSO THOSE
THAT ARE BUILDING THE HOMES
BASED ON THE PUBLIC SO PLEASE
DON'T YOU KNOW I THINK I. QUITE
LARGE PUBLIC SAID BILLION CAN
HAVE I YOU'RE IN OUR GREAT
STATE WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK I VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR MADAM SECOND
PLEASE CALL THE BILL A MOTOR.
OKAY FROM PERFECT. THE MOTION
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS KALRA
AYE KALRA AYE. FLORA FLORA NOT
VOTING CARILLO CARILLO I DEEP.
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I JONES
SAWYER. RIVAS RIVAS HI. FOR
BILLS ON CALL BUT NO I HAVE
PASSPORT PERFECT THANK YOU SO
MUCH. MISTER CHAIR MOVING ON
THE AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT
THANK YOU I THINK IT WAS SURE
MEMBERS FOR THE OPTIONS AND IF
YOU AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
EIGHT. WHICH WOULD ABBOTT OF
EMPLOYER MANDATES IN PROGRAMS
CONSTITUTE NECESSARY
EXPENDITURE FOR DIRECTORS-
WORKERS AND JOB CAN THE
PROHIBIT OF CURRENT PLAYERS
FROM ACQUIRING JOB UP TO PAY
FOR OR REIMBURSE THEM THERE OF
IS FOR ALL YOUR- WHEN. GOVERNOR
THE SOME HEALTH CARE TO BEEN
MISSING JOB. AND A CON. OR THE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE COST
IMPLEMENTED A TRAINING FOR CAN
OF A- ACOSTA CAN BE FORGIVEN
AFTER A DSIGNATED. PERIOD OF
TIME OF IMPLANTS. HIRING DIRECT
PATIENT CARE WORKERS AN APT IS
TO COVER THE COST. AMENDED
TRAININGS PLACES AN ADDITIONAL
FINANCIAL BURDEN APPLICANTS
SEEKING EMPLOYMENT. SPECIALLY
RECENT GRADUATES ALREADY FACING
FINANCIAL PRESSURES OF STUDENT
LOAN DEBT. A LACK OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. THERE'S A LOOPHOLE
THAT ALLOWS HEALTHCARE EMPLOYER
THANKS A LOT OF THE RIVER
EMPLOYERS TO REIMBURSE
EMPLOYEES FOR ANY MAN A TRAIN.
CALIFORNIA HAS A GOAL NURSING.
ONLY EXACERBATE THE SITUATION
AND THE NEED TO RECRUIT MORE
HEALTHCARE WORKERS AB TWENTY
FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT WOULD CLOSE
LOOPHOLE BUCKLER FIND AN
EMPLOYER MANDATED. THINGS
CONSTRUED AS A NECESSARY
EXPENDITURE PROHIBITING
HEALTHCARE EMPLOYER COMPELLING
DIRECT PATIENT CARE WORKERS AND
JOB APPLICANTS TO PAY FOR
EMPLOYER MANDATED TRAININGS.
AND GRATEFULLY I THINK MOST OF
ACTUALLY DON'T DO THIS BUT
THERE'S CERTAINLY QUITE A FEW
THAT DO ONLY WANT TO CLOSE THAT
LOOPHOLE- BOB THE SURVEY OF A
TO PROVIDES SUPERB SUPPORTING
TESTIMONY IS TAYLOR JACKSON.
THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION IMAGE STEIGER. OR
LABOR FEDERATION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ABOUT MISTER CHAIR AT
TAYLOR JACKSON FROM CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION. IF YOU'RE ON THE
LINE. MODERATORS TAYLOR JACKSON
ON THE LINE. ONE WHAT THE LINE
IS NOT OPEN PLEASE REMAIN ON
THE LINE. TAYLOR JACK COMPUTER
GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR CAN YOU
HEAR ME WE HAVE YOUTH HELLO
TAYLOR. AT HI I'D GIVE IT BACK
TO ME THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION WE ARE THE SPONSORS
OF AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT
LABOR CODE REQUIRES EMPLOYEE
PAY FOR COLLEGE NOT VERY FOR
WORKERS TO PERFORM THEIR JOB.
OR COSTS INCURRED BECAUSE THEY
FOLLOW THE DIRECTIONS OF THEIR
EMPLOYER THE COURTS HAVE RULED
THIS INCLUDES EMPLOYER REQUIRE
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM FOR
TRAINING. BUT A BETWEEN. WE
PROTECT TO DROP OUT TO ENSURE
THEY ARE PROTECTED IN THE SAME
WAY THE LAW PROTECTS EMPLOYEES
CNN HAS BEEN FIRSTHAND OUR
EMPLOYERS IMPOSING THESE CALL
ON JOB APPLICANTS- AT WHAT.
THEY'RE TO PROPER JOB
APPLICANTS IN CONTRACT MAKING
THE FUTURE EMPLOYER RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE CORE TEAM TO BELONG TO
THE EMPLOYER DOES NOT BELIEVE
ABILITY TO PAY FOR IT IT
SHOULDN'T. ALL EMPLOYEES MUST
FOR WORKERS CURRENTLY RESPONSE
TO THEIR WHITE OR SORT OF A
PROGRAM FOR THEM TO LEGALLY
PRACTICE NOT SPECIFIC EMPLOYEE
CLASSIFICATION FOR NURSES OF ME
AND THEIR ASSOCIATES ARE
BACHELOR'S DEGREE AND THERE AND
CALLED. THEM AND THIS BILL
REALLY CRAFTED TO WHO DOES
EITHER ALONG WITH BALLING
TRAINING OR EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM
THIS WILL ENSURE THAT BEFORE
WORKERS TECHNIQUE BECOME
EMPLOYEES THEY'RE NOT TRAPPED
INTO PAYING FOR. COURT AND THE
SURE OF OUR DETERMINED SHOULD
BE BY BY THE- IT IS QUITE TIME
TO CLOSE THESE LOOPHOLES BACKED
ACTORS ARE USING AND NURSES
AFTER I VOTE ON AB TWENTY.
EIGHTY EIGHT. VERY MUCH EITHER.
MET A PHONE GET YOUR SHARE
MEMBERS MUCH TIGHTER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL DIAZ AND HERE A REALLY
COVERED. WE WANTED REALLY
EMPATHIZE THE POINT THAT THIS
IS REALLY THE WAY THAT IT IS
THAT EVERYJOB WHERE TO SHOW UP
BUT CERTAIN SKILLS. AND GET
THEIR ASKED TO GO. DIGITAL
TRAINING THAT OUT YOU WILL
LEARN HOW THE EMPLOYER. WOULD
SOMETIMES IT'S AN HOUR
SOMETIMES AT THE DAY SOMETIMES
IT'S A WEEK OF TRAINING. AND
WAS OF THE AMOUNT. ABSOLUTELY
YOU SPEND UNDER THE BORDERS
CONTROL. HE TO THE STATION AND
IT'S UP. SOMETHING THE SHOULD
BE THAT'S WHY LABOR CODE SO
CLEARLY DICTATES THAT BE THAT
WAY. AND SO- THE FACT OF THAT
WORK ARE IN SOME OF THESE CASES
BEING ASKED TO DO THIS TRAINING
ARE NOT BEING PAID FOR IT AND
IF THEY HAVE TO PAY THEM. BACK
FOR A- ARMS WILL COST. AN. NOT
JUST THOSE WORKERS ALL TO
EMPLOYERS DON'T ENGAGE IN KIND
OF ACTIVE BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO
COME WITH THE THAT WE THINK
BUSINESS SECTION A BILL IN YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MITCH ANYONE IN THE ROOM. PART
OF TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT. CN
NINE ANYONE ELSE ON THE PHONE
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY EIGHT. ME PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO TO POSITION IS IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL WILL START WITH
NINE SEVEN TWO FIVE SEVEN
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
OUR ONLINE SEVEN TWENTY FIVE
YOUR PHONE MAY BE ON MUTE.
BLOOM WILL MOVE ON THE LINE SIX
OF SEVEN SIX ZERO SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. IF YOU JUST
AROUND. TEACHERS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THERE ARE OTHERS IN A
PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO. SEVEN
UNDERLYING Q. ME JUST A MOMENT
PLEASE. DOES YOUR MIND OF THE
LINE. SEVEN TWENTY NINE SEVEN
TWENTY CUED UP WOULD YOU LIKE
TO SHARE YOUR POSITION. I
BELIEVE UNTIL JULY NUMBER BUT
IF YOU JUST CUED UP HE MAKES
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOU'RE BEING
TOLD THE LINE NUMBER JUST A
MOMENT. NO THERE ONE SEVEN
TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS ROXANA TIENEN I'M
FROM LOS ANGELES ALLIANCE FOR A
NEW ECONOMY AND I WANT TO
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB THIRTY TWO
SIXTEEN WE ARE WORKING WITH OUR
WORKERS TO OUR OUR REGION THAT
ARE IN. NEED OF THE ATTACK AND
BE A FIFTY ADDING SUCH REMOTE
SEVEN DAYS PLEASE. SENATE RIGHT
IN LEFT AND- WINDS THIRTY SEVEN
THREE ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
COLOR NINE SEVEN THIRTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD.
KENYA CAVITY IN SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA WORK AND I'M
COALITION. THANK YOU. ALIGN
SEVEN THIRTY THREE SEVEN THREE
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. VERY
VERY HARD ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYER LAWYERS IN
THE NATION AND SUPPORT. SEVEN
TWENTY THREE ONE TWO THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THE CALL
CAME FROM GOVERNOR'S DESK THE
CONTENT TO PHYSICAL STRONG
SUPPORT. ONE SEVEN ZERO EIGHT
SEVEN ONLY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HAVE A FROM NINE SEVEN ONLY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES ARE THE
WITH PHYSICIANS FOR SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY AND CALIFORNIANS
FOR HELPING GREEN ECONOMY AND
WEARING STRONGLY SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY TO SIXTY. ONE I THINK
THAT WAS THE WRONG BILL MA'AM.
BUILDING THAT MY STE THEY MAY
BE ALLOWED ONE BOOK BUT- THE
LAST LANDING WITH SEVEN TWO
EIGHT SEVEN TWO EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I THE LAST MONDAY WITH
THE RIGHT AND I'M AND TRONG
SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH JUST TO CLARIFY A WAY
THAT WAS TESTIFYING WAS IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY EIGHT AS AB FIVE EIGHTY
EIGHT. TO BE REGISTER JUST PORT
THERE WAS FOR AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY EIGHT. ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION. THE ONE IN
OPPOSITION BY PHONE. BY PHONE
IF YOUR IN OPPOSITION OF THAT
BILL IT'S ONE THAT ZERO WE'LL
GO TO LINE FIVE FIVE FIVE NINE
FIVE FIFTY. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU ALICE HAWTHORNE AT
THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION WE ARE NOT OPPOSED
TO THE BILL WE GET IT ISSUE A
LETTER OF CONCERN- UPWARDS OF
THE- TO THE EXTENT THE BILL
CLARIFIES EXISTING LAW
REGARDING CONDITIONAL POINT
MENTOR CALLING BACK CAUGHT. WE
ARE CONCERNED WITH THE USE OF
THE WORD APPLICANT IN THE BILL
AND WHAT THAT IMPLIES ABOUT OUR
OBLIGATIONS HOWEVER WE
APPRECIATED IT WILL DISCUSSION
WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE
SPONSOR. YOUR HOPEFUL WE CAN
WORDSMITH IN WHICH TO PRISON AT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION GOING
ONLINE. SEVEN THIRTY FIVE SEVEN
THREE FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI YES THIS IS JILL THOMPSON
FROM PUBLIC COUNSEL BUT I
WANTED TO- SPEAK ON BEHALF OF
AB THIRTY TWO SIXTEEN I THINK I
DID IT INCORRECTLY SORRY.
THAT'LL BE THE NEXT BILL COMING
UP SO JUST A CALL BACK YOU WILL
GET TO YOU APPRECIATE THAT.
THIRTY TWO SEC COMING UP NEXT.
NO FOR THE OUTLINED IN. WE DO
HAVE ANOTHER LINE NINE SEVEN
TWO EIGHT TWO EIGHT PUT HEAD
START MY DAY WITH RIGHTS TO
GATHER I THINK I WAS ALSO
SPEAKING FOR THIRTY TWO
SIXTEEN. THAT IS OKAY WE WILL
REGISTER THAT SUPPORT ON THE
NEXT BILL APPRECIATE THAT
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT I'M
SORRY IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY FIVE. EIGHTY EIGHT BY
PHONE. WHEN IN Q. AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM. SEE AN
NINE. BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. ANY QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. MISTER CHAIR
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE SPOKE
WITH US FROM THE EVIL. THANK
YOU MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THIS CREEL MOVEMENT
IS. NOT IN. THE HOUSE. OKAY
MOTION TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA BY COLOR I
FLORA FLORA I. HI CARILLO I
DEEP. GONZALEZ INVOLVED BY
JONES SAWYER. RIVAS I RIVERSIDE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW WE'RE
MOVING ON TO A. B. THIRTY TWO
SIXTEEN. AS CHAIR. THANK YOU
WITH SURE AB THIRTY TWO SIXTEEN
THIS WILL PROVIDE NECESSARY
LEAVE IT LEAVE AND JOB
PROTECTORS PROMOTE HEALTHY
WORKPLACES AND TO PROTECT THE
ECONOMIC WELL BEING OF
CALIFORNIA'S WORKERS AND
FAMILIES IN THIS GLOBAL HEALTH
CRISIS AND IN FUTURE STATES
REGENCY. WHAT ABOUT TWO MONTHS
OR SO THE ITSELF TO HELPING
BEND THE CURVE AND REDUCE THE
IMPACT. OF NINETEEN VIRUSES
HAVING ON OUR COMMUNITIES.
CALIFORNIA IT'S COUNTIES AND
CITIES AND LOCAL COMMUNITIES
HAVE MADE GREAT SACRIFICES TO
PROVIDE FOR THE OVERALL PUBLIC
HEALTH. WHAT DOES VIRUSES
DEMONSTRATE IS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S LEAVE AND
WORKPLACE PROTECTIONS ARE
WOEFULLY INADEQUATE TO ADDRESS
AND RESPOND TO THIS AND OTHER
STATES THE MARGIN SIX. THIS
BILL IS A REFLECTION OF THE
REAL TIME NEEDS COMPOSED BY
COVER NINETEEN. THAT IS EXPAND
ACCESS TO ON PAID JOB PROTECTED
LEAVE HELPING TO ENSURE THAT
EMPLOYEES TO STAY HOME IF THEY
OR A LOVED ONE. HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED BY COVER NINETEEN AND
NOT PLACE OTHERS AT RISK
MISSION. IT ALSO EXPANDED PAID
SICKLY PROVISION TO BE MANAGED
ORANGE. FOR THE THEMSELVES
THEIR WORK. AND GREATER PER
HEALTH. IT ALL HELPED TO ENSURE
THAT WHEN THE ECONOMY IS READY
TO RE OPEN AS IT IS STARTING TO
DO ALREADY. OF THE LIFE BLOOD.
FOR THE STATE'S ECONOMY. CAN
GET MOVING QUICKLY WITH THE
WORKERS IN MIND. THE WORKERS
CAN GET BACK TO WORK QUICKLY
AND SAFELY TO THESE TALISMAN OF
A RITE OF ATTENTION. OF THE
NINETEEN IS MAGNIFIED EQUITIES
ARE LEAVE LAWS WHICH HAS BEEN
EXACERBATED BY THE RECENTLY
ADOPTED FEDERAL FAMILIES FIRST
COURT CORONAVIRUS ACT WHICH
EXCLUDED. BUT TOLD CHRISTMAS
ACCESSING THE FEDERAL. THE
PROGRAM. MILLIONS OF WORKERS
ARE ALSO EXCLUDED FROM
ACCESSING LEAVE UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA FAMILY RIGHTS ACT
BECAUSE THEY DO NOT WORK FOR
THE RIGHT SIZE EMPLOYER. NOT
MANY CALIFORNIANS DO PORTION
PEOPLE COLOR IMMIGRANTS WOMEN
PROVIDING ESSENTIAL SERVICES
DURING THIS TIME. OF ISN'T
IMPOSSIBLE CHOICE BETWEEN
WORKING WHILE SICK OR LOSING
THE INCOME THAT ALLOWS THEM TO
FEED THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES. TO MY MYSTERIES SUCH
AS HOTEL HOSPITALITY EVENTS
CENTERS A BUILDING SERVICES A
LAID OFF ONE THIRD OR MORE OF
THEIR EMPLOYEES. WORKERS IN
THESE INDUSTRIES ARE
OVERWHELMING PEOPLE OF COLOR
AND IMMIGRANTS WERE ALREADY
ECONOMIC BEING PHYSICALLY HIT
HARDEST BUT OVER NINETEEN. WE
MUST ALLOW EMPLOYEES IMPACTED
BY COVER NINETEEN RECOVER AWAY
FROM WORK WITHOUT FEAR OR
RISKING THEIR EMPLOYMENT OR
PLACING THEIR COWORKERS. AT
GREATER RISK YOU MUST ALWAYS
LOOK THE ALSO LOOK TO THE
FUTURE AND IMPLEMENT IMPLEMENT
LONG TERM POLICIES. THAT WILL
HELP GET PEOPLE PER CRISIS LIKE
THIS IN THE FUTURE IT'LL ALLOW
FOR EXPECTATIONS PLEASE WHEN
THERE ARE THERE ARE LOCALIZED
NUMBER SEASON CAT PLEASE WITH
HIS HIS WILDFIRE. YOUR STATE
WHY EMERGENCY. THE WE ARE
CURRENTLY FACE. WE CAN NOW WAIT
AND WE MUST NOT WAIT TO ACT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. BOB WHAT TODAY WE HAVE TO
TEST FROM THE PHONE MARIE
SOLIDER RIVERA WITH CALIFORNIA
WORKING FAMILY COALITION. VIA
THE VIDEO VIDEO CONFERENCE ROOM
SIR FOX OF THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION AND WE WILL ALSO
HAVE CHEN. BOB GERRY BUT LEGAL
IT WORK. FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND FOR ANY DATA TO
HELP ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK
MEASURE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER WILL GO TO MARCELLA OF
FIRST BY PHONE. MR MODERATORS
MARCEL ON THE PHONE. ARE IN A
LISTEN ONLY MODE AFTER LINE IS
NOT OPEN PLEASE PRESS ONE STAR
THAN ZERO IN THIS CIRCUMSTANCE
STARS ARE ALL PLEASE. ABOUT A
SERRA FLOCKS IN THE VIDEO
CONFERENCE ROOM. WHAT'S YOUR
CHAIR MEMBERS CAN YOU HEAR ME
OR SEE ME WE CAN HEAR YOU AND
NOW WE- EIGHT OKAY. THANK YOU
CHAIR MEMBERS- SERRA CLOCKS
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION- WE
ARE A PROUD CO SPONSOR. SB
THIRTY TO SIXTY. I'M GONNA LET
BY ONE OF MY CO SPONSORS SPEAK
ABOUT THE LEAD PROVISIONS OF
THIS BILL BUT I WANTED TO TALK
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THE RIGHT TO
RECALL AND XIN FOR HOTEL AND
YOUR WORDS AND BUILDING SIR.
WHICH IS. TO MAKE. YEAH BACK TO
WORK AND TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CAN GET OUR ECONOMY UP AND
RUNNING AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
CLOSE TO HAPPEN ALL THE WORKERS
HAVE LOST THEIR JOBS IN
CALIFORNIA DUE TO THE PANDEMIC
MANY OF THESE ARE WORKERS WHO
HAVE SPENT DECADES ON THE JOB
AND SPENT TEN TWENTY THIRTY
YEARS WORKING THEIR WAY UP FOR
MINIMUM WAGE. PAYING JOBS THAT
CAN SUPPORT THEIR FAN BASE ON.
RECALL PROVISIONS ARE STILL
IMPORT. AND WORK OFFER SO MUCH
PROTECTION TO THESE WORKERS
BECAUSE THEY ARE SURE THAT YOU
WON'T BE REPLACED BY NEWER-
LOWER PAID WORKER. IT PROTECTS
OLDER WORKERS I'M AND THE TO
WORRY THAT THEY WON'T BE ABLE
TO FIND A NEW JOB OR IF THEY DO
FIND A NEW JOB THEY'RE GONNA
HAVE TO START AGAIN AT NEW WAGE.
THIS IS ALSO GOOD FOR WORKERS-
AN EMPLOYERS BECAUSE- EMPLOYERS
WERE ABLE TO BRING BACK THEIR
MOST EXPERIENCED AND SKILLED
WORKERS ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
RE OPEN THAT. PRODUCTIVITY
GOING TO BE. THE CALL FOR TEN
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF OTHER
CUSTOMERS AND THOSE WORKERS.
THESE ARE NOT LAWS THAT ARE
NEW- ESPECIALLY THE RETENTION
LAWS THAT ENSURE THAT IF
THERE'S A CHANGE OF OWNERSHIP
DUE TO THE ACCOUNT I SAYS THAT
THE WORKPLACE IS ABLE TO STAY
IN PLACE. THESE ARE. ISN'T IS
THAT HAPPENED AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL AND WE HAVE AT IT THE
STATE LEVEL HAVE A RETENTION
FOR GROCERY WORKERS- AND THE
SOMETHING ENGINE LAWS THAT HAVE
BEEN IN PLACE IN WASHINGTON DC
SINCE. EIGHTEEN NINETY. I THERE
ARE CLEAR THE CONSTITUTIONAL
ARE CLEARLY NOT FEDERALLY
PREEMPTED AND THEY HAVE ALWAYS
BEEN IMPORTANT BUT NOW FACING
THIS ECONOMIC CRISIS IS EVEN
MORE IMPORTANT THAT GET ARM
SKILLED. AND EXPERIENCED
WORKERS BACK TO WORK AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE THANK YOU SO I'LL
JUST. WE GUARANTEE YOUR- DATA
SORRY. NO PROBLEM THE BUDGET
THAT. IS MARCELLO BACK ON THE
LINE TO HAVE MARCELLA BY PHONE.
IF NOT WE'LL MOVE TO PUBLIC
COMMENT ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMIC
MIGHT BE BETTER IF I COULD A
DIFFICULT JENNA GEHRY SPEAK
INSTEAD OF MARCH WELL I'M NOT
SURE IF IT'S GOING TO BE ALL
OKAY TO THE FOR THE- LAST. OF
THE-ABSOLUTELY. GARY ON THE
PHONE. YA HEAR ME YES WE HAVE
YOU JENNA. OKAY GREAT- YES MY
NAME IS JENNA GERRY AND I'M A
SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY AT
LEGALLY THAT WORK FOR A
NONPROFIT IT FOR THE RIGHT ONE
CUP ACROSS THE STATE A CAL. AT
WE HEAR. WORK EVERY YEAR I WAS
IN THE LAST THREE MONTHS ALONE-
THAT ARE DEALING WITH. THESE
ISSUES WERE THAT FIND IT CARE
OF THEIR OWN HEALTH THEIR
FAMILY'S HEALTH. AND TO HOLD
THEIR JOB AND PROVIDE FOR THE
FAMILY BUT ARE UNABLE TO DO SO
BECAUSE- START AT. OUR EIGHT A
MEDICALLY BUT THAT LEAVES OUT
SO MANY WORKING CALIFORNIANS.
AND WHILE. YOU KNOW BEING
PROGRESS BEING MADE AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL THAT IMPLEMENTED
EMERGENCY PAID BACK AND
EXTENDED. HEY BELIEVE HER CAL.
CLOSURE THE FEDERAL LAW BECAUSE
OF ITS ATTENTION PLEASE OUT. OF
MILLION. OR AB. IF YOU.
NECESSARY COVER THE WAR
EVERYWHERE SHALL TO TAKE OF
THEMSELVES AND THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS WITHOUT THE RISK OF
LOSING THEIR JOBS- IT IS IT IS
ESSENTIAL DURING THE TIME THAT
WE HEARD FROM THE FAMILY MEMBER
THAT EVERY WORKER HAVE THE
ABILITY THANK HATE. BECAUSE
BELIEVE THAT IS LIKE TYPICALLY
IT BECAUSE THAT IS. A SIMPLE
NOT POSSIBLE FOR MANY LOW
INCOME WORKERS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA- SO I'M AT I WILL
AND THERE BUT I AM HAPPY DANCE
ANY QUESTIONS THAT COME UP
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CHEN A ONE L. SO. THE A. B.
THIRTY SIXTEEN BY PHONE. FOR BY
PHONE WOULD BE ONE THAN ZERO
WE'LL GO FIRST TO LINE OF SEVEN
THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. AB
FIFTY. THREE WITH THAT HELLO
CAN YOU WORK AND FAMILY
COALITION IN SUPPORT. NEXTBOOK
OF A LINE SEVEN TWELVE SEVEN
ONE TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. DAVID
FIVE REPRSENT AN A. R. P. WE
STAND STRONG IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. NINE SIX TWENTY NINE SIX
TWO NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS KATHY LONG WITH THE
PARTNERSHIP WORKING FAMILIES IN
STRONG SUPPORT AT EIGHTY THREE
SIXTEEN THANK YOU WE'RE WE'RE
TRACKING DOWN. YEAH. SEVEN OH
SIX ONE SEVEN OH SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HEALTH NETWORK INTO
PORT. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE SIX
SEVEN SEVEN SIX SEVENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF
OF UNITE HERE THE TEAMSTERS THE
AMALGAMATED TRANSIT UNION. JEAN
IF UNION AND THE UNITED-
UTILITY WORKERS OF AMERICA ALL
IN SUPPORT THANKS. GOING ON THE
LINE SIX SIX THREE SIX SIXTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. PERFECT
EXAMPLE OF NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. NEXT WE'LL
GO TO FIVE SEVEN SEVEN FIVE
SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SHOP BUT MAKING ON BHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG SUPPORT.
LINE SEVEN FOUR SIX ONE SEVEN
FORTY SIX MINE IS OPEN. AND
MEMBERS OF THE FAMILY ANDREA
THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS PROVIDENCE STRONG
SUPPORT. NINE SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN
FIVE OLD PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALL
OUR ONLINE SEVEN FIVE ZERO YOU
MAY BE ON MUTE ON YOUR OWN
DEVICE. I'M I'M SUPPOSED TO BE
TESTIFYING AND I DON'T KNOW I
WASN'T GIVEN ONLINE NUMBER. I'M
BOB MY NAME IS MAHDI SALEH
THEIR RIVERA. YOU KNOW I AM
TESTIFYING ON A. B. THIRTY TWO
SIXTEEN I'M SO SORRY I DON'T.
OKAY SO YOU'RE ON THE ASSEMBLY
ASSISTANCE. ARE SO YOU'RE ON
THE PHONE WITH AB TWO. THIRTY
TWO SIXTEEN I'M ON THE PHONE
FOR A. B. THIRTY TWO SIXTEEN IS
THIS HAPPENING IT IS HAPPENING
NOW AND WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF
PUBLIC COMMENTS SO PLEASE ADD
YOUR COMMENT AND WE WOULD JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS OR BECAUSE- THE MOVE.
FACE OKAY I'M SORRY I I'VE BEEN
WAITING ALL DAY AT I APOLOGIZE.
I WANTED TO SAY GOOD AFTERNOON-
I MONEY CELEB NVIDIA THAT HE
BETTER NOT EVER- RESIDENT OF
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SIXTY THREE I
COME TO YOU IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF EIGHT TO SIXTEEN IS THE
FOUNDER. OF LONG. WE ARE. HELLO
WORKING. THE STATE WIDE
ALLIANCE OF ORGAN IN IN THE YOU
KNOW OVER WINNING THAT HELP
WORKERS AND FOR TAKE THE TIME
THEY NEED TO CARE FOR
THEMSELVES AND EACH OTHER I
ALSO- SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY TWO
SIXTEEN AS THE MOTHER OF TWO
YOUNG CHILDREN EDUCATED THE
CARE GIVER ELDERLY. THE SPOUSE
OF A WORK. WELL ONCE HAD GOOD
MEDICAL COVERAGE AND MORE THAN
ENOUGH TO PAY OUR MORTGAGE WE
ARE NOW AMONG THE MILLIONS OF.
RELYING SOLELY ON UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE AND WAITING TO BE
ISSUED MEDI CAL ONE STATE
EMPLOYEES WORK THEIR WAY THE
TRUMP. WELCOME CAN'T. EVERY
PROVISION WILL BE ESSENTIAL I
FOUND EMPLOYER RECOVER ENOUGH
TO REHIRE HIM. BUT EVEN ONCE
YOU START WORKING AGAIN WHAT
WILL HAPPEN TO MY FAMILY IF HE
BECOMES INFECTED WITH COVERT
NINETEEN. WITHOUT PAY TIME OFF
HIS UP BE INFECTING OTHERS OR
BECOMING. OR BEING WITHOUT AN
INCOME AGAIN. SUPPLEMENTAL PAID
SICK DAYS AND JOB PROTECTION
SHOULD BE- SHOULD HE USE THEM
WOULD PROVIDE A THIRD OPTION
WHICH IS QUARANTINING THROUGH
INFECTION AND RECOVERY. THIS
BILL. HELLO NINETEEN PLEASE LET
NINE ALSO AND SHE ECONOMIC
RECOVERY EVEN IF ONE PARENT
HAVE TO SEE HOW TO CARE FOR
YOUNG CHILDREN AND THE ELDERLY
THANK YOU SO MUCH RIGHT IN
ADDITION ABOUT THE THAT'S
PLEASE. PEOPLE LIKE ME AND- I
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIRTY TWO
SIXTEEN TO CREATE MUCH NEEDED.
ACTION FOR PAID FAMILY THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
MODERATOR WE WILL GO BACK TO
THE NATIONAL SOME WORK ON THE
ON. THANK YOU AND THERE ARE
MANY MINES IN Q. WILL GO TO SIX
NINETY SEVEN SIX NINE SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. THANK YOU
SIX SEVEN FOUR SIX SEVENTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ROBERT NOTE
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
FEDERATION OF LABOR IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. SEVEN FORTY
THREE SEVEN FOUR THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BLACK STAND OF PINE
AND FROM THE LOS ANGELES
ALLIANCE FOR NEW ECONOMY AND
STRONG THE COURTHAVING PASSED
SIMILAR PIECES OF LEGISLATION
DOWN HERE THANK YOU. SEVEN
THREE SEVEN FIFTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE HM THREE FROM
THE CALIFORNIA CHILD CARE
RESOURCE NETWORK IN STRONG
SUPPORT. I AM FIFTY FIVE SEVEN
FIVE FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CALIFORNIA BUT- SEVEN FIFTY SIX
SEVEN FIVE SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI TOLERANCE SEVEN FIVE SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HOME OF THE
LINE SEVEN TWO TWO SEVEN TWENTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY I AM A
FAILURE OF CALIFORNIA BECAUSE
BONSER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
FIND SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN SEVEN
FIVE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AT THE MOMENT BUDGET FOR
PROGRESS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
FIND FIVE FOUR ONE FIVE FORTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. OUR CALLER
ONLINE FIVE FOUR ONE YOUR
DEVICE MAY BE ON MUTE. WILL
MOVE WELL MICHAEL OPENED FIVE
FOUR SEVEN. ONE FIVE FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. JANUARY
TERRACE THE COMMUNICATIONS
WORKERS OF AMERICA DISTRICT
NINE IN SUPPORT. AND SEVEN
SIXTEEN SEVEN ONE SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN SEVEN IN GIRLFRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
LINE SEVEN EIGHTEEN SEVEN ONE
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE OF
THE ON BEHALF OF EQUAL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES AND A CHARGE HEALTH
ADVOCATES NETWORK A DRUNK THE
PORT. NINE SEVEN ZERO NINE
SEVEN OH NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
JENNIFER LOPEZ RECTOR OF NAY
ROUTE WHICH MAKE CALIFORNIA
WEREN'T STRONG SUPPORT. FIVE
NINETY EIGHT FIVE NINE EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE WORLD
WILL END THIRD REPRESENTING THE
CENTRAL COAST EARLY CHILDHOOD
ADVOCACY NETWORK STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. SEVEN FORTY TWO
SEVEN FOUR TWO PLEASE LISTEN.
HI THIS IS MY THOUGHT ARKANSAS
FRESHENER PUBLIC HEALTH
RESEARCHER AT HUMAN IMPACT
PARTNER WHEN. HI IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTY TWO
SIXTEEN THANK YOU. I AM TO
SEVEN FORTY FOUR SEVEN FOUR
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. BILL
THOMPSON AND THE DIRECTING
ATTORNEY OF THE WOMEN AND GIRLS
RIGHTS PROJECT AT PUBLIC
COUNCIL IN LOS ANGELES WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS MEASURE
THANK YOU. SEVEN SEVEN ONE ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS AFFECTED BY THAT I LIVE AND
WORK IN THE CITY OF BACKGROUND-
AND I'M CALLING MY STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY TWO ONE
SEC AT THE TURN OF THE CHILDREN
IN GRADE SCHOOL HERE IN
SACRAMENTO THE NUMBER WHAT. I
ONE. QUOTE IF THE FORTY
EMPLOYERS WHICH WOULD ALLOW THE
TO STAY AND FACILITATE A
PRODUCTIVE DISTANCE FOR THEIR
CHILDREN BENEFITS OFFERED BY AT
THIRTY TO SIXTY BRIDGE THAT GAP
YOU CREATE A VENUE PUBLIC GET
TAKEN IN YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
NAME IN ORDER. PLEASE I'M FIFTY
TWO SEVEN FIVE TO YOUR LIFE BUT-
ALEX TO CAPRI ON BEHALF OF HER
SIDE CALIFORNIA'S INSTRUCT THE
PORT. SEVEN THIRTY SIX SEVEN
THREE SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THOMAS CAN'T IMMIGRANT WORKERS
ONLINE ALSO KNOWN AS Q. WHAT
COLLEGE LOS ANGELES AND WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB THREE
TWO ONE SIX. I AM FIVE. THREE
FIVE FIVE THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THAT'S A GREAT WHAT THE FCW
WESTERN STATES COUNCIL IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK. FIND
SEVEN FORTY NINE SEVEN FOUR
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CORRECT
PALMER ON BEHALF AT PRESS IT
AWAY AND STRONG SUPPORT. THIRTY
SEVEN THREE ZERO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AND THE SECRETARY AT THE
FAMILY VIOLENCE HELLO CHURCH
THE URGES FROM OR ANY MONTH
THAT THANK YOU. NINE SEVEN TWO
THREE SEVEN TWENTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI SEVEN TWENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WILL MOVE
THE LINE SEVEN SIX THREE SEVEN
SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES SHE HARD ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION PROUD CO SPONSORS
OF STRONG SUPPORT. WELL LINE
SEVEN SIX FOUR SEVEN SIXTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ALEXANDER
SAYS EXACT. NINE SEVEN OH EIGHT
SEVEN ONLY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SEVEN HUNDRED AND EIGHT WE CAN
HEAR YOU. PHONE NUMBER. NINE
SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN. BARBARA
BEARING NATIONAL STATE POLICY
ADVOCATE FOR THE NATIONAL
COUNCIL OF JEWISH WOMEN IN
STRONG SUPPORT. OVER LINE SEVEN
SIX SEVEN SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS FOR OTHER THAT I LIVE IN
NORTH HOLLYWOOD AND I- I AM
WITH GROUND GAME LOS ANGELES
AND I URGE STRONG SUPPORT FOR A
BI THIRTY TWO SIXTEEN. YOU ON
YOUR LINE IS OPEN I FOR ONE. WE
ON WORKING PART TO CHECK HER.
WE HAVE LIKE HERE BUT WITH IT
THEY MIGHT STRONG. THANK YOU
LINE SEVEN FIVE ONE SO FIFTY
ONE P. GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS ONE
OF THE UMBRELLA EITHER AND I
WITH THE TIME FOR CANADA'S BUT
DON'T LOOK ANGELES UP PROGRESS
IN A LOOK BACK YOU. AND I'M IN
THE WORK OF AB FIFTY TWO THE.
POINT ALLIANCE SIX NINE SIX
NINE GO AHEAD. A PUBLIC SERVICE
THE CENTRAL WORKER PARENT AND
CARE GIVER I LIVE IN WALNUT
CREEK AN ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
SIXTEEN- YOUR STRONG SUPPORT
FOR A BI THIRTY TWO SIXTEEN AND
THANK YOU FOR CIRCLE. IN OUR
FINAL COMMENTED QS SEVEN FIVE
FOUR SEVEN FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES ALLOCATE COUNTY A
WORKING FAMILY COLLECTIONS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY TWO
SIXTEEN THANK YOU. THIS DEVICE
SURE I DO HAVE ONE MORE LINE
AND Q. ONE SEVEN SEVEN ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN SEVEN SEVEN ONE. I
PUT THE CALIFORNIA WITH THE
PROCREATION AND WHERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. NINE SEVEN SEVEN TWO
WAS ALSO IN Q. WILL ALIGN SEVEN
SEVENTY TWO IS GO AHEAD.
FINALLY THE REPRESENTING
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
UNIVERSITY WOMEN AND REPORT.
THIS TIME THERE ARE NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS IN THE QUEUE THANK
YOU SO MUCH ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION IT'S A GREAT ONE
BEEN FROM CAL CAME IN
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM THAT. A
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE. LAST OF THE DAY BIG
BILL I ONLY HAVE TWO MINUTES I
DON'T SPEAK AS QUICKLY AS
JENNIFER BIRTH. SO I WILL
SIMPLY DIRECT MEMBERS TO OUR
LETTER OF OPPOSITION WOULD TO
EXPLAIN SOME OF THE SPECIFIC-
CONCERNS WE HAVE WITH THE BILL
BUT I WANT TO EMPHASIZE TWO
POINTS IN THE LIMITED AMOUNT OF
TIME HAVE. FIRST OF ALL. IN OUR
OPINION THIS BILL THAN JUST THE
CURRENT CRISIS OR FUTURE THE
MILLER CRISIS WE UNDERSTAND
THERE'S AN UNNECESSARY
CONVERSATION TO HAVE ABOUT WHAT
PROTECTIONS APPLY TO WORKERS IN
THE CURRENT CRISIS THAT
CONVERSATION HAS BEEN HOW THAT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL IN THE BLOOD
NOW AT THE STATE LEVEL. WE PRO
AND ARE HAPPY TO ENGAGE IN THAT
CONVERSATION. WHAT MAKES IT
DIFFICULT FOR US TO ENGAGE IN
GOOD FAITH IS WHEN THIS BILL IS
LOADED UP LIKE A CHRISTMAS TREE
WITH EVERY LEAVE RELATED
PROPOSAL ADVOCATES HAVE BEEN
PUSHING FOR THE LAST DECADE OR
MORE. THESE INCLUDE BRING IN
SIR DOWN FROM FOR MORE POLICE
TO ONE OR MORE EMPLOYEES NOT
JUST FOR THE EMERGENCY LEAVE
FOR ALL PURPOSES UNDER SO FOR
EXPANDED THE DEFINITION OF
FAMILY MEMBERS OR SURPRISE
AGAIN NOT JUST FOR THE EMERGING.
PURPOSES FOR ALL. THE FRONT.
BRINGING FOR YOU DISBILITY LAW
FIBER PLEASED TO ONE AND MAKE
AN UNRELATED CHANGES PAID
FAMILY LEAVE AGAIN WE'RE HAPPY
TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE NEEDS OF
EMPLOYERS TO WORKERS UNDER
CRISIS BUT OVER THERE ARE IN
AND IT MAKES IT VERY DIFFICULT
FOR US TO EAT EVEN BE IN A
PLACE WHERE WE CAN TO GET TO
HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
BILL. FROM THE TOP COVER
STATION ABOUT THE- FAMILY.
LEAVE AND THE NEED FOR. SICK
LEAVE BUT LET'S NOT BUSINESS AS
AN EX. TO ENACT A LAUNDRY LIST
A PERMANENT POLICY CHANGES THAT
ARE PROPOSED IN THIS STUFF. THE
SECOND ONE TO MAKE IS THIS BILL
DOES NOT ACKNOWLEDGE THE
ECONOMIC CATASTROPHE FACING
EMPLOYERS AS WELL AS WORKERS.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT MANY WORKERS
ARE SUFFERING RIGHT NOW AND
MANY OF THE PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL DEALING WITH EMERGENCY
FAMILY AND MEDICAL LEAVE. AND
PAID SIX. ARE EIGHT. IN THOSE
WORKERS. TURN THAT THE
CUMULATIVE BURDEN OF ALL THESE.
IS BEING PLACED A 100% ON THE
BACKS OF EMPLOYERS. BELIEVE
PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL APPEAR
TO BE IN ADDITION TO LEAVE.
ENACTED IN RECENT WEEKS IN THE
FEDERAL. LEVEL GOVERNOR
NEWSOME'S EXECUTIVE ORDER FOR
FOOD SECTOR WORKERS. AND AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL IN THE MOST RECENT
ENACTMENT. MORE IMPORTANTLY
THESE SKILLET OF OBLIGATIONS
ARE BEING IMPOSED ON EMPLOYERS
OF ANY SIZE WITH NO IT
KNOWLEDGE MEANT THAT MANY
EMPLOYERS HAVE BEEN SHUT DOWN
FOR TWO MONTHS WITH ZERO
REVENUE COMING IT. AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL WITH THE NAKED
EYE CRLA AND THE CARES ACT
THERE WAS AT LEAST AN
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT. BY POLICY
MAKERS THAT WE NEED TO FIGHT
WAY DOING SIMPLER SO. I AM WITH
THESE ARE SHOULD. CREDIT TAX
PEARLS. AND ONE MEMBERS PLAYERS
DOLLARS DOLLAR NEW OBLIGATIONS.
THANK WITHOUT THE REAL THAT WE
CAN'T PUT THIS OBLIGATION
COMPLETELY ON THE BACKS OF
EMPLOYERS AT SOME POINT THIS
CONVERSATION BECOMES MERELY
ACADEMIC AS I RESOURCE FOR THE
SAID 52% OF. BECAUSE IT'S NOT.
NOW THE WORD DEALING OVER THE
NEXT FEW MONTHS SO WE NEED TO
FIND A WAY TO HAVE THIS COVERS
TOGETHER AND REALISTICALLY THIS
IS GOING TO BE A THEORETICAL
AYE THANK YOU SEE REASONS WE
OPPOSE THE BILL. YOUR ENERGY
FOR RARE WHETHER. WELL ANYONE
ELSE IN OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION BY
PHONE AB. THIRTY TWO SIXTEEN.
AB SOME IN Q. OTHERS MAKE YOU
UP BY PRESSING ONE THAN ZERO
WE'LL GO TO LINE SEVEN OH EIGHT
SEVEN ZERO EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WE CAN HEAR YOUR LINE
SEVEN ONLY BE OPPOSITION. THEY
WILL MOVE ON THE LINE SEVEN
FORTY SEVEN THANK YOU SEVEN
FOUR SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE OF DON'T ADVOCACY ON BEHALF
OF AB CA NO OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN RESPECT BUT FOR
THIS. SEVEN TWENTY THREE SEVEN
TWO THREE YEAR ON AS A- CALL
AROUND NINE SEVEN TWENTY ARE
YOU THERE. OVER LINE SEVEN
SIXTY SIX SEVEN SIX SIX WITH GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING PRESTAR
CHAOS HERE ON BEHALF OF
FEEDBACK ACCESS INSURANCE WITH
ALREADY A LINER COMMENTS
CALGENE BUT WAS BACK. THANK YOU.
NINE SEVEN SEVEN FOUR SEVEN
SEVENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ARE THERE ANY CON ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATED GENERAL
CONTRACTORS IN OPPOSITION TO
THIRTY TWO SIXTEEN THANK YOU.
FIND FOUR ZERO SEVEN FLORAL
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI A
WITH THE SUGAR TO WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA GROCERS ASSOCIATION
ALSO RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. NINE SIX NINE ONE
SIX NINETY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
A LINE SIX NINETY ONE YOUR
DEVICE MAY BE A NEW. QUIET
LITTLE CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION FOR THE REASONS
STATED BY MR EVENT THANK YOU.
FIND SEVEN FORTY EIGHT SEVEN
FOUR EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS KATIE
HANSON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THE LINE
SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN TWO ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CARE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE LARA KNOW AND HATE
CHECK ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
THE TRICK MUTUAL CALIFORNIA
FRESH REDUCES EACH IN
CALIFORNIA COTTON GENERATING.
BAR WHAT THE QUICKENING DEALERS
GROWERS THAT. AMERICAN STAFF
HERE GROWERS CALTRAIN TOMATO
GROWERS ASSOCIATION WESTERN
ACROSS THE THIRD IN OTHER
ACCESS EACH AND IN OPPOSITION.
NINE TO ELEVEN ONE ONE ONE IS
OPEN. YES THIS IS NICOLE RIGHT
FOR THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION LEAD TO ARE OPPOSED
TO THE BILL THANK YOU. FIND SIX
EIGHT ONE SIX THIRTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS IVAN ALL TOMORROW ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. I AM FIVE HUNDRED
FIFTY FIVE FIVE FIVE FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I LIKE TALKING
TO THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION ALSO POST. WE HAVE
ONE LINE AND Q. SEVEN SEVENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON STATE FOR DEATH ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY AND THE FAMILY
BUSINESS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
IT WOULD LATER COMMENT THAT
THAT THAT THAT YOU'RE HAVING.
THANK YOU FOR THE LINES INTO
IT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
MODERATOR. BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. COMMENTS THIS
GOES ALSO. ACTUALLY I'D LIKE TO
ASK- GEN A COUPLE QUESTIONS
JUST. AND MAYBE IT WASN'T.
MAYBE TO FINISH YOUR LIST OF
GRIEVANCES- I DON'T HAVE THAT
AT. I AM. I DIDN'T HEAR YOU
TALK ABOUT THE RECALL PROVISION
TO YOU GUYS OKAY WITH THAT. WE
HAVE. BECAUSE ONLY A FEW
MINUTES- LETTER DOES NOT LEARN
THE CONCERNS WE DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS WITH THAT PROPOSAL. WE
THINK- THERE ARE SOME LEGAL
ISSUES AS WERE RAISED WHEN THE
CITY OF LA WAS AN ACTING THAT
BOTH CONTRACT- BECAUSE ISSUES.
AND POTENTIAL AND ARE IT AND-
AREN'T A PREEMPTION ISSUES. WE
ALSO SEE THERE SOME PRACTICAL
CHALLENGES WITH THE- PROPOSAL
IT SAYS YOU HAVE TO RECALL
WORKERS IN ORDER OF SENIORITY
AND GIVE. EACH WORKER AT TEN
BUSINESS DAY OPPORTUNITY TO
RESPOND. TO YOU OFFER THAT JOB
TO WHAT THE MOST SENIOR WORKER
YOU GIVE THEM TEN BUSINESS DAYS
IF THEY SAY NO WE'RE DON'T GET
BACK TO YOU. THE NEXT WORK.
AFTER WORKER TEN STAYS WE'VE
GOT A REAL CHALLENGE WHEN IT
COMES TO. RE OPENING AND IS
GONNA BOG DOWN IF YOU WANT TO
GIVE UP THEIR FEET. IN THOSE
COVER INDUSTRIES. EXPLAIN THERE
ARE NO BETTER BUT WE- SELECT.
PROVISION AS WELL. HAVE YOU
BEEN HELPING AT HOME WITH ALL
THOSE KIDS. YOUR MOTHER THANK.
I WAS CURIOUS BECAUSE YOU DON'T
BRING IT UP AND I THINK THAT'S
ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
PIECES THE BILL OBVIOUSLY.
JOINT UNLESS. MY COLLEAGUE FOR
BRING IT FORWARD I THINK WE
KNOW WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THIS- HOPEFULLY AS A
MINISTER PREPARATIONS I DON'T
THINK IT'S BEEN MOVED ON WITH
THE BILL AND I YOU KNOW THIS IS
EXTRAORDINARY TIMES AND
EXTRAORDINARY MEASURES ARE
NECESSARY SO THANK YOU FOR.
THIS BIGELOW. THIS CAR. HEY WE
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND ANY
OTHER YES MISTER JONES SAWYER
AND I AND I APOLOGIZE I HAD TO
LEAVE THE ROOM AND YOU MAY HAVE
ALREADY DISCUSSED THIS IN AND
WE CAN TALK ABOUT IT LATER I'M
GOING TO GO HEAD OVER TO BE I
JUST TO MAKE SURE. ARE WHEN IT
COMES SINCE THIS IS FOR AND IS
COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE IMMIGRANT
BUSINESSES THAT MAY NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO CAPITAL FROM THE
FEDERAL AND NOT THERE WE KIND
OF WRAP AROUND OUR ARMS AROUND
AT TO MAKE SURE I'M DATE GET
HARM THIS OR WEEK. BIG EMPLOYER.
SINGLE EMPLOYER MY DISTRICT BUT
SMALL BUSINESSES ARE THE SINGLE
EMPLOYER IN MY DISTRICT AND SAW
THERE THERE'S PROBABLY TEN
TIMES MORE PEOPLE WORKING
BECAUSE OF. BEING IN A SMALL I
DISTRICT BENNETT USC AND SOUL
LET'S FIGURE OUT A WAY THAT
THEY DON'T GET HURT BECAUSE
THAT'S WHEN. THE WHOLE. OF A-
AGAIN I APOLOGIZE FOR NOT YOU
MAY HAVE TALKED ABOUT IT
EARLIER APOLOGIZED FOR NOT NOT
BEING HERE AND IF YOU WE WILL
WE CAN DO THIS OFF LINE HERE.
TELEVISION PLAN MY CLOTHES ON
OKAY. ANYONE ELSE ON THE
COMMITTEE. I WOULD JUST SAY YOU
KNOW- THE CHAMBERS COMMENTS I
MEAN THIS IS A MEAN THROWING
GONZALEZ THIS IS A BIG BILL.
THERE IS A LOT IN HERE I MEAN
YOU COULD PROBABLY HAVE FIVE OR
SIX BILLS OUT OF THIS ONE
THERE'S A LOT OF MATERIAL HERE
AND I ACTUALLY APPRECIATE RIGHT
HE'S- DONE SO YOU'RE YOU'RE- ON
THE SMALL BUSINESS ASPECT OF
IT. BECAUSE A LOT OF THESE
BILLS WHAT DO FIND THE- SEARS
ISSUE YOU BRING UP LIKE THE
ETHNIC STORES AS- SMALL. STORE
GET SUCKED IN THANKS OF THE
LEAD THAT WE TALK ABOUT. IT
TOOK ME. WHAT ARE DISTRICT
MIGHT IS NOT DIFFERENT. RELATES
TO THE SMALL COMMUNITY. SO IT
IS A HUGE CAN. BUT I WOULD JUST
ENCOURAGE YOU KNOW THE CHAIR
AND I KNOW YOUR HEART ALL OF
THIS BUT- LET'S FIGURE OUT A
WAY THAT WE CAN TRY TO PROTECT
THE SMALL BUSINESSES THAT SAID.
HOW THE AXIS. WE LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU. I'M SAY THE- THIS
THE- THING. THE BIG WISHES HE
SAID INTEREST IN THE FIRST
DRAFT OF IT. ALL THAT BEING SO
A COUPLE POINTS I AGREE
COMPLETELY THE SUMMARY JONES
SAWYER THAT LOOK AT THE END OF
THE DAY WHEN WE'RE IN NUMBERS
TO SEE WE HAVE TO LOOK AT WHO
IS AND WHO HAS THE LEAST
ABILITY TO RESPOND. YOU START
WITH THE WORK LAID SERVICE
SECTOR I HAVE TO GO HOME AND
TAKE CARE LOVE ONES. THERE THEY
HAD THE LEAST OF IT BOB AND
FLEXIBLE THE AT AMP OR MENTOR
UNDER THE BILL OF PROTECT THOSE.
A REALLY THE MOST. I THINK TO
LOOK AT OKAY NOW THE BILL. CONS
YEAH A PLUS EMPLOYERS YOU HAVE
A LOT AND IS THE YOU HE'S WILL
HAVE YOU. YOU HAVE A SMALL
BUSINESS I THINK IT'S A UPON OF
US THIS HOW WE HELP THOSE THAT
THOSE LIKE THE NATIONAL. AND SO
WE SUBSIDIES PUBLIC BECAUSE WE
HAVE EMERGENCY FUNDS TO GO TO
THOSE SMALL BUSINESSES FIRST
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE LEARNING A
LOT THIS WERE STEM FROM THE
FEDERAL BILL. DID NOT HAPPEN.
IN CALIFORNIA WHETHER IT'S- OR
YOU KNOW OF THAT THAT'S
HAPPENED MY DISTRICT. OR YOU
KNOW ES DE. UPDATE LIKE RIGHT
NOW. WE SHOULD ALWAYS FOCUS ON
THE SMALL BUSINESSES THAT DON'T
HAVE THE WHEREWITHAL. TO
WITHSTAND THAT KIND OF PAIN.
AND SO I AGREE COMPLETELY WITH
THAT THE MENTAL AND FOR DICK TO
HAVING FOR THE CONVERSATIONS.
WITH YOUR SUMMER I'M SORRY. AND
ON THE RIGHT TO RECALL- WITH
THE CHAMBERS OPPOSITION
INDICATE. WHAT HURT. I'M AN THE
NEW RISK WORKER I THINK IMPLIES
THAT. AT THE FIRST OPPORTUNITY
OF THOSE THAT ARE SENIOR AND
HAVE THE EXPERIENCE WOULD BE.
JETTISONED THAT THAT YOU KNOW
THAT SHOULDN'T BE THE CASE SO
THAT THE IN THE NUMBERS AND
SEE. THOSE THAT HAVE THAT
SENIORITY SHOULD BE THE FIRST
CONSIDERED TO BE ABLE TO RETAIN
THOSE JOBS AND CERTAINLY.
PROCEDURALLY COULD BE BIGGER
IT'S AN UNNOTICED ALL. FOUND
OUT AND TO SEE IF THEY'RE
INTERESTED RETAIN. SINCE YOU
WERE ON THE IS AND GO FROM
THERE. STARTING AT THE TOP OF
LIST AS TO WHO KNOWS THE MOST
SENIORITY. SO I MEAN THERE'S
DEFINITELY A LOT THAT YOU
WORKED WE CAN TO WORK ON IT. I
ACTUALLY SUPPORT- APPRECIATE-
THE JOINT AUTHORS SENATORS ALSO
IS. AND THE WORK HE'S DONE ON
THIS. WAS OUR STAFF IN WORKING
WITH MY STAFF AND I WOULD JUST
LOOK AT WE THINK THIS IS A-
PERSON. HOW TO SAVE THE MOST
USED AS ANY OTHER DAY. THEY
ACTUALLY DO FAR MORE TO PROTECT
THEIR WORKERS BUT- EVEN.
ORDINARY TIMES AYE. THIS IS THE
LEAST WE CAN DO. RECOGNIZING
WHAT WE'VE BEEN GOING THROUGH A
STATE RECORD RIGHT RECOGNIZING
WHAT OUR WORKERS HAVE BEEN
GOING THROUGH. UP ISSUE. HE'S
SPEAKING DO AT THIS CON BUT
ACTUALLY GET MEANINGFUL
LEGISLATION TO THE GOVERNOR'S
DESK THIS HERE SO THAT WHEN
THERE ARE EMERGENCIES IN THE
FUTURE THE EXPECTATIONS ARE
VERY WELL. BUT THEN I THOUGHT
FAST WHEN I BUILT. SHARE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA FIVE COLOR
HI THE FLOOR FLORA NO CAREER.
OUR BY A DEEP THAT VOTED IT'S
NOT PUTTING THEMSELVES CONSOLES
RIGHT JOHN THERE ARE TIMES
WHERE I RIVAS. RIVAS BY. HOW
BILLS OUT MISTER CHAIR WILL
WAIT FOR YOU. MY NOTES A LOOKS
LIKE A SORT OF VICE CHAIR FOR
AS WELL AS THE FAMILY MEMBERS
CARILLO RIVAS BUT ON
EVERYTHING. WE DO HAVE TO.
NINETEEN SEVEN OF A NOTS KALRA
BUILT ON MY BILLS WE HAVE A
SENATOR DEEP GONZALEZ AND READY
JONES SAWYER WHO WERE NOT- IS
NOT PRESENT THE TIME TO WRAP
PRESENTS OTHER BILLS WOULD HAVE
SO IF YOU CAN. BUT IT WILL GET
BACK TO THIS IS THE ONLY ONE
THAT WE DIDN'T GET ENOUGH. OF
IT AT ALL. GET IT OUT. BUT THE-
AB. NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN. DEEP
MIL WHAT DO YOU KNOW THE-
AUTOMATIC GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
MISS JONES SAWYER YES EIGHT ONE
THREE YES ALL RIGHT THE BILL IS
OUT AND SO LET'S START FROM THE
TOP AB TWENTY FORTY THREE. I
BELIEVE SAMBAR DEEP WAS NOT
HERE AT THE TIME FOR. ITS A
FALLEN FOR AB TWENTY FORTY
THREE YES. THE THIS AND I AND
THE BILL WAS ALREADY ELTON WITH.
FOR IS AB TWENTY FORTY THREE
FILE ITEM REPORT TWENTY FOUR
THREE. ITEM NUMBER FOUR YEAH
I'M GONNA GO DOES GOING TO
STRIP DOWN FILE ITEM LIST AND
THAT WAS. YES CORRECT ALL
RIGHTS THAT ONE'S A THAT WAS
ALL DONE. ON TO THE NEXT ONE.
FILE FIVE. AB TWENTY NINETY TWO
RODRIGUEZ ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ. HI THE ON COMPLETE
THANK YOU FILE ITEM SIX. AB
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY SEVEN
FREDDIE RODRIGUEZ A SUMMER
FREDDIE RODRIGUEZ GONZALEZ. I
THINK YOU WERE GET ON FILE ITEM
SEVEN WE'RE GOOD ON EIGHT
REGALO FILE ITEM NINE O'DONNELL
AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY FIVE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES SAWYER. I
READ THE OPEN IS DONE THANK YOU.
THEN THE BOTTOM TEN WEBER AB
TWENTY NINE NINETY TWO BUT DEEP.
I LEAVE I GONZALEZ RIGHT HI
JONES SAWYER BY HI THE BILL IS
COMPLETE WE JUSTIFIED ELEVENTH
WILL GO TO BUY- TWELVE AB
TWENTY TO THIRTY ONE KALRA DEEP.
BY JONES SAWYER BY THANK YOU
THE ONE IS SAID TO COMPLETED.
FINE THIRTEEN AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY EIGHT KALRA DEEP HI.
JONES SAWYER BY. HOW TO RIDE
THE BILL'S COMPLETELY JUSTICE
AUTUMN FOURTEEN I BELIEVE
EVERYONE VOTED ON CONSENT. SO
WE ARE ADJOURNED THANK YOU
EVERYONE. FOR THE JOB NINE.